Ja, und der sieht wirklich spektakulär gut aus. Man kann es nicht anders sagen.
Es ist Chord, das man als Chord erkennt.
Die Streifen laufen nicht von oben nach unten, nur am Arm, sondern von innen
nach außen so ein bisschen. Ja.
Es bringt also wirklich was mit. Und du sitzt jetzt hinter, vor einem Fenster,
also zwischen mir und einem Fenster und ich sehe ungefähr 17 Milliarden Farben, die schimmern.
Ja, die Sonne strahlt hinein.
So kann man nicht in den Krieg ziehen.
Nee, so geht es wohl nicht.
Bist du nicht vorbereitet?
Das ist vielleicht eher die Ausgehuniform dann. Ja, noch nicht kriegstüchtig.
Also es war doch ein wahnsinniger Monat, oder?
Du bist eine Blendgranate.
Ja, es war doch ein wahnsinniger Monat, als wenn man das so alles mitbekommt,
wie die Debatten verlaufen.
Ich hatte ja erst gedacht, es kühlt jetzt so ein bisschen mal ab.
Die Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz begann. Dann war das das große Selfiespektakel dort.
Also inzwischen geht man gar nicht mehr zu Berlinale, um sich sehen zu lassen,
sondern man geht eher zur Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz.
Und produziert sich dann bei Social Media. Und da sieht man schon,
wie sich etwas verschiebt.
Ja, und der Journalismus klärt auch nur, wer war zu sehen und wer war wann zu
sehen und wer war nicht zu sehen. Das war alles im Grunde.
Ja, Macron war nicht zu sehen, aber andere waren zu sehen und es ist erstaunlich,
wie sich das so verlagert hat, dass es als etwas Selbstverständliches geht.
Also es gab, wenn ich mich daran erinnere, 2017,
18, 19, die Sicherheitskonferenzen, da fanden die statt,
da wurden die natürlich auch vom Journalismus rezipiert, aber es war nicht ein
Social Media Event und es war vor allem auch nicht ein Event,
wo irgendwelche Podcaster rumspringen und Comedians und weiß ich nicht wer.
Und inzwischen ist das einfach so ein Place-to-be geworden, wo man lustig netzwerken
kann und man sieht eigentlich daran schon, wo sich was verschoben hat.
Das stimmt. Diese Selfies, ich habe nur das eine von Jagoda Marinic oder wie sie heißt gesehen.
Was ja dann auch nochmal gekontert oder gekontert wurde durch irgendwie,
also ich krieg's selber gar nicht mehr zusammen, aber man kann ja auch,
ansonsten inhaltlich hab ich nur mitbekommen, Stimmung war schlecht.
Ja.
Es wurde nichts weiter reportiert, außer die Stimmung war schlecht und Heusgen
hat seine Moderatoren aufgefordert, den Silberstreif in allen Moderationen,
in allen Diskussionen, in allen Panels zu suchen.
Und das ist im Grunde, sonst haben wir auch mal ein bisschen mehr auf die Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz geschaut, aber von meiner Seite war es das im Grunde schon. Für mich auch.
Ich habe mir einige Sachen angesehen. Wir haben gleich nochmal eine kleine Überraschung.
Aber sonst hat mich da überhaupt nichts verblüfft. China hat das gesagt,
was in Davos auch schon gesagt wurde. Es gab ein Panel zu Indien.
Da hat man nochmal gesagt, dass Indien eine super Demokratie ist.
Man hat eigentlich nichts Neues gesagt, außer nochmal dann natürlich die Nawalny-Geschichte
dort groß gespielt, was auch sicherlich sinnvoll ist, das da zu tun.
Genau, Nawalny klammern wir als Thema auch mal aus. Wir wollen es jetzt nicht
sozusagen da einordnen in dieses Social Media hier und Dings und da und alles
nur Selfies und dann Nawalny.
Aber das ist ein Thema für sich, auf das wir zu sprechen kommen.
Naja und sonst geht ja der Diskurs munter weiter.
Also wir haben jetzt zwei Jahre lang diesen Krieg und es wird in den Medien
fortlaufend immer noch dasselbe Theaterstück gespielt.
Wenn zum Beispiel Scholz sagt, Taurus-Lieferungen gibt es nicht,
dann kommt man auf die Idee, wen interviewt man?
Natürlich Anton Hofreiter, Woffen, Woffen, Woffen und der sagt dann sowas hier.
Naja, ob diese Ängste haltlos sind, das liegt natürlich im Auge des Betrachters.
Scholz weist auch darauf hin, Frankreich und Großbritannien sind in einer anderen
Position als Deutschland. Das sind zwei Atommächte. Deutschland ist das nicht.
Ja, und das macht das Ganze noch schlimmer, weil er nämlich damit immer sozusagen
mit der Atomfrage spielt und er damit genau auf das aggressive Narrativ von Putin hereinfällt.
Putin ist ein Verbrecher, Putin ist ein Imperialist, aber Putin ist kein Selbstmordattentäter.
Und bis jetzt, die ganzen 20 Jahre, wo wir Erfahrung mit Putin haben und ja
auch während dieses Krieges, es war immer so, wenn wir Schwäche gezeigt haben,
wenn wir zurückgewichen sind, ist er aggressiv vorangegangen.
Klarheit und Stärke gezeigt hat, ist er zurückgewichen und deshalb hält da einfach
Scholz an den 20 Jahren falsche SPD-Politik fest und das kann uns, wie gesagt,
alle in große Schwierigkeiten bringen, wenn das Putin ermuntert,
weitere Länder anzugreifen.
Ich würde mal gerne wissen, was meint er damit, wo Deutschland oder die NATO
Stärke gezeigt hat, dass Putin da zurückgewichen ist?
Wir haben ja jetzt erlebt, wie man immer mehr geliefert hat und rote Linien
waren plötzlich keine Und Game Changer auf Game Changer folgten und das hat
ja nicht dazu geführt, dass Putin irgendwo zurückgewichen ist.
Also ich weiß gar nicht, was er da erzählt.
Und dann haben wir hier wieder diese Argumentation, die wir glaube ich vor anderthalb
Jahren im Podcast hatten, die auch Katharina Barley vorbrachte.
Nein, es kann keine Eskalation geben, denn Putin ist zwar ganz böse,
aber er ist nicht verrückt oder er ist verrückt, aber nicht ganz böse.
Also man tauscht das immer so aus.
Er ist völlig irrational, aber er ist so rational, dass er das auf keinen Fall tun wird.
Ja, das ist ein schmaler Grat, vor allem der Vermutungen.
Man ist ja weit weg und Scholz hat auch schon über ein Jahr nicht mehr mit ihm telefoniert.
Anders als, glaube ich, Macron. Und Macron zieht eine viel härtere Linie,
also der scheint vielleicht auch ein bisschen mehr zu wissen oder so.
Ich würde auch sagen, man konnte lange, Macron kam ja ins Amt und hat sofort
diese Soborn-Rede gehalten, also rückblickend sofort.
Da war ja lange so ein ach, der Junge, ach, der Grünschnabel und so weiter.
Nur das kann man ja jetzt auch nicht mehr aufrechterhalten. Und ich fand es
interessant, Robin Alexander hat heute Morgen in seinem Podcast Machtwechsel gefeiert.
Wie Scholz umrahmt von so einer Boomer-Klicke dargestellt, die sich sozusagen
verabschiedet von der Realität und noch die inneren Überzeugungen einmal durchprügelt, also Mützenich,
dann der ehemalige Berliner Bürgermeister, wie heißt er nochmal und so weiter,
die da so im Hintergrund Scholz umrahmen mit, nee, nee, das ist schon alles.
Und da muss ich sagen, beginnt jetzt für mich auch weniger die,
okay, ich will jetzt auch nochmal durchdenken, was ist da an psychischen Kapazitäten
und so weiter verteilt, sondern steckt in diesem Boomer-Ding selber ein Argument.
Moment, weil wir haben ja gerade eine Boomer-Generation, die sich so ein bisschen,
wir werden es vielleicht nachher, wenn wir Zeit haben, noch an Josef Hader hören,
der sein Bühnenprogramm, in dem er einfach als Boomer auf der Bühne sitzt und
so monologisiert und einmal expliziert, was wir häufig den Boomern unterstellen,
wo er das in der Sternenstunde Philosophie nochmal richtig auf die Spitze bringt,
richtig auf die Spitze treibt, insbesondere mit einer Verurteilung der Politiker
der Boomer-Generation.
So, und mittlerweile wird man hin und her gerissen mit solchen,
ich will jetzt nicht sagen, der Kern der Diskussion, sondern so fast popkulturelle
Umrandungen und Deutungen, Berlin-Astrologie und was auch immer.
Aber das führt doch eigentlich zu nichts.
Es führt genau zu nichts und die große Gefahr ist, und das war eben von Hofreiter
so ein ganz kleiner Hinweis nur, Putin ist ja kein Selbstmörder.
Oder? So, und dann würde ich sagen,
Mal abwarten. Wir hatten gerade eine Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz,
die eröffnet wurde, mit einer Witwe, die vor Ort erfahren hat,
dass sie ab jetzt Witwe ist.
Da ist also ein Mann sehenden Auges für seine Überzeugung und für sein Russlandbild
gestorben. So, er wurde ermordet.
Es gab mehrere Mordversuche. Er ist trotzdem zurück nach Russland gegangen und Nawalny.
Ist… Obwohl man ihm ganz klar gesagt hat oder er das auch wusste,
dass das für ihn nicht gut ausgehen wird.
Genau, die Drohungen standen im Raum und trotzdem ist ja für diese Überzeugung,
für dieses Russlandbild, wie sich das zu Putins Russlandbild unterscheidet,
können wir ja nochmal klären.
So, also man sollte jetzt nicht immer davon ausgehen, dass man es nur mit Playern
zu tun hat, die auf jeden Fall überleben wollen.
Also für die so das Wichtigste ist, die eigene Geschichtsschreibung noch so
lange wie möglich mitzugestalten.
Dann könnte Putin es sich einfacher machen. Er hat sowieso alles so orchestriert
dort, dass er im Prinzip nicht mehr abgesegt werden kann. Er müsste nicht zugleich
noch expansionistisch und all das sein.
Er verfolgt schon eine größere Mission, wie man ja auch in diesem obskuren Interview
mit Tucker Carlson hören konnte.
Ja, also so wie er das jetzt, es könnte durchaus sein, dass in diesen allen
zerfransten Diskussionen, die wir jetzt haben, inklusive noch irgendwelchen
Boomer-Gruppen, Aburteilungen, Generationenkonflikte oder wie auch immer,
es einfach passiert, dass wir morgen eine ganz andere Nachrichtenlage haben.
Und dass es vielleicht doch stimmte, was so ein bisschen unter der Hand erzählt
wird in einigen Journalisten-Podcasts, dass Putin einfach Olaf Scholz gesagt
hat, wenn meine Krimbrücke zerstört wird, setze ich Atomwaffen ein.
So, und jetzt ist das eine Waffe, die die Krimbrücke zerstören kann.
1 plus 1 ist 2. Und man zieht das einfach durch.
Oder es ist genau das Gegenteil. Olaf Scholz sonnt sich in seinem nicht manifestierten,
aber latent flächendeckenden Wachstum.
Ich bin der geruhsame Staatsmann, ich halte die Meute, die Journalistenmeute
unter Kontrolle und deeskaliere einen Konflikt. Kann auch sein.
Also es kann mittlerweile alles sein.
Ja, wir können es ja nicht mehr analysieren, wenn wir uns ansehen,
wie Macron sich jetzt in den letzten Monaten verändert hat.
Er war der Zögerliche ja eine Zeit lang gewesen, der auch immer stärker machte,
dass man wohl doch diplomatisch vorgehen sollte,
was dann zu Schlagzeilen führte, wie Macron denkt wie Sarah Wagenknecht oder
solche Sachen gab es ja bisweilen zu lesen und zu hören.
Und nun sehen wir also einen Macron, der für Bodentruppen ist,
beziehungsweise sie nicht ausschließen will oder es einfach mal so in den Raum
stellt und dann sieht man ja auch, dass jemand wie Wolfgang Ischinger sagt,
ja das sei ein kühner Gedanke, aber in gewisser Weise auch nicht verkehrt.
Also da sehen wir, wie schnell etwas eskalieren kann und wir sehen auch diese
hohe Ambivalenz und ich würde das jetzt nicht als strategische Ambiguität adeln
wollen, sondern diese Verwirrtheit bei Macron.
Vielleicht auch weil der Druck im eigenen Land immer größer wird.
Bei ihm vollzieht sich ja selbst auch der Rechtsruck in der Politik,
bei seiner eigenen Politik und außen sowieso.
Und dass wir zum einen Macron haben, der sagt, wir als Europäer sollen nicht
uns den Amerikanern unterwerfen und brauchen eine eigene Linie mit China.
Und wenige Monate später sorgte er dann mit von der Leyen dafür,
dass man einen Protektionismus macht, damit chinesische E-Mobilität nicht so
einfach nach Europa kommt, womit er natürlich vor allem den deutschen Autobauern schaden würde.
Also wir sehen hier, dass wir es nicht mit einem Menschen zu tun haben,
der eine klare Strategie hat.
Also da kommt mir dann Scholz noch im Ganzen schlüssiger vor,
aber das ist alles großes Rätselraten und es ist so beängstigend,
dass die Gefahr so präsent ist.
Und dass sie zugleich so abwesend ist, also das finde ich schon so ungeheuerlich,
auch in dem, was Leute umzutreiben scheinen.
Und vielleicht hören wir mal dazu beispielhaft Claudia Major,
die also dazu befragt wird, Taurus und all das.
Präsident Macron hat mit der Aussage, dass er Bodentruppen nicht ausschließen
würde, natürlich die europäischen Partner verstört.
Letztlich erkennt er aber an, dass Krieg immer eine dynamische Angelegenheit
ist, wo die Antworten regelmäßig angepasst werden müssen.
Und es ist auch sinnvoll gegenüber einem Gegner wie Russland nicht immer zu
sagen, was man alles nicht machen möchte, sondern auch den Zweifel bestehen
zu lassen und diese strategische Ambiguität bestehen zu lassen und Russland
im Unklaren zu lassen, was die Europäer noch machen würden.
Das ist letztlich auch eine Stärke, wenn man nicht immer rote Linien zieht.
Die Absicht von Macron, jetzt in Europa Führung zu übernehmen und neue Fähigkeitskoalitionen
auf den Weg zu bringen, sind im Prinzip gut.
Noch besser wäre es gewesen, wenn sie europäisch abgestimmt werden.
Der Blick von außen, dass Europa nicht geeint ist, nicht mit einer Stimme spricht,
sich nicht einigt, der Kanzler den einen Tag das sagt und der französische Präsident
etwas anderes, ist von außen ein desaströser Anblick.
Und im Endeffekt nutzt das nur Russland.
Aber was meint sie jetzt damit, dass es dynamische Entwicklungen gibt und dann
muss man dies und das auch noch tun?
Ja, aber das ist ja gerade eine Eskalationsentwicklung.
Also wir haben mal angefangen über leichteres Geschütz zu sprechen,
sind dann bei den schweren Waffen gelandet, sind jetzt bei Taurus,
sind dann bei Bodentruppen und sagen aber immer noch, dass wir selbst nicht
in den Krieg involviert sind und dass es auch auf keinen Fall ein Stellvertreterkrieg
sein soll, wie dann ja dieselben Leute betonen.
Und das ist so erschreckend zu sehen, dass diese Dynamik so ihren Lauf nimmt
und dass es nur ganz wenige gibt, die dem widersprechen, die sagen,
nee, das muss eine rote Linie bleiben.
Und da kann man ja froh sein, dass offenbar Olaf Scholz das so sieht und wahrscheinlich
auch der amerikanische Präsident, der wird auch bald andere Sorgen bekommen wegen des Wahlkampfs.
Aber wir können, daran können wir sehr, sehr gut erkennen eigentlich,
wie man in einen Weltkrieg hineinschlittern kann.
Also ich finde, das ist so auf der Hand, dass wir eigentlich jetzt im letzten
Jahr um diese Zeit dachten, okay, das ist jetzt so eine neue Form der Eskalation,
da hatten wir diese ganze Panzerdebatte.
Aber nee, es gibt durchaus noch Steigerungen und darauf nur zu sagen,
naja Situationen sind dynamisch und da muss man dann auch immer flexibel drauf
reagieren, bedeutet ja,
dass man immer weiter sich involviert in das Ganze und zugleich auch erkennen
muss, dass es bislang keine nennenswerten strategischen Erfolge von Seiten des Westens gab.
Es gibt dazu eine Gegendenkschule, also zu Warnungen vor Eskalation und so weiter.
Die ist mir untergekommen im Podcast von Table Today. Das ist ja irgendwie so
eine neue, keine Ahnung, ich kenne nur deren Podcast.
Michael Bröker und Helene Bobrowski, die hat mit Gerhard Konrad gesprochen.
Der ist ein ehemaliger Leiter des BND-Leitungsstabs und hat sich,
so wie im Podcasttext steht, als Vermittler in Verhandlungen zur Geiselbefreiung
im Nahen Osten einen Namen gemacht.
Und er wurde eingeladen zu der Themensetzung, wie kriegt man jetzt Gaza befriedet?
Wie kriegt man die Eskalation von Israel und Hamas wieder runtergedampft?
Und zwar insbesondere mit der Forderung, die ja John Oliver auch,
nicht John Oliver, sondern wie heißt er, John Stewart, der jetzt wieder montags Daily Show macht.
Und er hat ja gesagt, wir brauchen jetzt ein MeToo, also nicht eine NATO,
sondern eine MeToo Middle East Treatment Organization.
Aber die Bedingung, um sich zu treffen, also alle in der Region Involvierten
sind, die Geiseln kommen zurück und die Bomber dem Ausführen auf.
So, wie kriegt man Geiseln zurück?
Und der Gerhard Konrad beschreibt hier mal, was Eskalation im besten Fall bedeuten kann. Brinkmanship.
Es bleibt durchaus eine reelle Chance, dass wir innerhalb der nächsten Wochen,
ich sag es mal so vage, zu einer...
Eine Teillösung oder gar eine Lösung des militärischen Konflikts kommen könnten.
Das hängt aber ganz entscheidend davon ab, wie kompromissbereit gerade auch Hamas ist.
Das muss man ganz klar sehen. Letzten Endes dann auch Israel.
Die Elemente liegen auf dem Tisch. Sie müssen austariert werden.
Und das wird allerdings nach leider Gottes auch regionalspezifischen Kriterien,
wird eben eine elende Feilscherei sein und Brinkmanship, wie man so schön sagt. Das heißt?
Brinkmanship heißt, jeder reizt im Grunde genommen das Risiko maximal aus.
Und Sie dürfen nicht vergessen, dazu gehören dann nicht nur die Spieler direkt
am Tisch, sondern dazu gehört auch das Umfeld, das heißt Hezbollah.
Dazu gehören Kräfte in Syrien, nicht Syrien als solches, aber Kräfte in Syrien.
Dazu gehören die Houthis in Jemen. Und dazu gehören auch diese Drohungen wie
einer Bodenoffensive in Rafah zum Beispiel? Natürlich, das ist ganz klar.
Und diese Drohung wird so glaubhaft wie möglich sozusagen vorbereitet,
damit es nicht eine Lehre oder nicht ein Bluff ist. Das gehört natürlich auch dazu.
Wenn vermeidbar, umso besser. Wenn nicht, dann wird das getan.
So, wenn wir jetzt mal hier Problemen und Lösungen aufgreifen und die Themen austauschen. Ja.
Hieß ja das ja, Macron sagt, wir könnten hier auch mit Soldaten hingehen.
Scholz würde sagen, Taurus, wir machen sie noch fertig, kommen im Mai.
So, dann würde jemand wie der Gerhard Conrad hier sagen, jetzt bahnt sich ein
Gespräch an. Ja. Aber vorher wird alles auf den Tisch gelegt.
Nur dazu gehört halt, dass sie das insgeheim vereinbaren und dann öffentlich
kommunizieren und durchhalten.
Und das sieht man gerade gar nicht. Und ich glaube, das ist eigentlich noch
ein viel größeres Problem.
Also es wird jetzt so langsam thematisiert, dass sich Frankreich und Deutschland
nicht verstehen. Wir haben das hier schon über Jahre besprochen, wo es da hakt.
Nur jetzt in einer sehr brenzligen Lage bricht dieser Konflikt auf und zerstört
sozusagen grundlegende strategische Überlegungen,
wie man mit Semantik, Ansprachen an die Öffentlichkeit und so weiter hier Sachen vorbereitet.
Besser kann man Putin eigentlich nicht in die Hände spielen,
weil er genau sieht, wenn er sich so uneinsetzt, dann funktioniert das nicht.
Also diese semantische Munitionslieferung geht einfach völlig leer.
Und das ist, glaube ich, eine super brenzlige Situation.
Ich stimme dem sehr zu, denn die Voraussetzung ist ja von dem,
was wir jetzt gerade für den Ostkonflikt gehört haben, dass beide Parteien dann
wissen, dass es einen Kompromiss geben muss.
Wenn ich aber erlebe, was vor allem in den Talkshows so reproduziert wird,
dann denkt man, man muss Putin besiegen.
Und das wird natürlich nicht der Fall sein. Er hat ja gerade hier Akteure aufgezählt,
die noch schlimmer sind als die Hamas.
Die alle da quasi dann einem Kompromiss zustimmen müssen angesichts einer besonderen
Eskalationsstufe und wir haben jetzt die ganze Zeit immer noch diesen Diskurs,
wir müssen Putin besiegen oder Putin muss gar nach Den Haag und das wird nicht
passieren und kann auch nicht passieren und ist damit auch eigentlich die Voraussetzung,
die man setzt für einen unendlichen Krieg.
Ich sehe, dass der nächste Clip Kiesewetter ist. Ja. Ich habe wahre Vermutungen,
was wir gleich hören werden.
Also wir hören nur mal rein. Der Clip ist mir eigentlich zu lang.
Ich will ihn gar nicht so lange zu Wort kommen lassen. Aber wir sollen mal schnell reinhören.
Was aber bedeutet, ich will es im Vorfeld noch sagen. Wenn jetzt jemand richtig
harte Linie fährt im Februar und das Brinkmanship funktioniert,
bedeutet das aber, dass derselbe Mann im Mai sagt, Ich weiß,
das Zugeständnis ist groß, aber zur Vermeidung des Krieges geben wir Putin diesen
und jenen Zugeständnis.
Also irgendwo durch die Blume muss das mitkommuniziert werden,
jetzt schon. Jetzt können wir darauf achten, ob wir das bei Kiesewetter hören.
Lassen Sie uns trotzdem noch mal kurz auf Ursula von der Leyen zurückkommen.
Die Begründung von Scholz soll offenbar gewesen sein, Frau von der Leyen sei ihm zu Putin kritisch.
Können Sie diese Begründung nachvollziehen?
Nun Scholz wird ja eine gewisse Putin-Nähe unterstellt und er entkräftet das auch nicht.
Und in jedem Fall ist Scholz jemand, der auch der deutschen Wirtschaft sagt,
Sie sollen ja ihre Verbindungen nach Russland halten, bald können sie wieder
ihr Geschäft normal betreiben.
Und Putin ist auch jemand, der sagt, die Krim hat eine symbolische Bedeutung für Putin.
Und deswegen möchte er nicht, dass die Krim mit sogenannten deutschen Waffen,
die ja dann ukrainische sind, befreit wird. Das heißt, er macht alles, um Putin zu gefallen.
Und dies stimmt mich sehr nachdenklich, weil Baerbock und Pistorius bei ihm
nicht durchdringen, wie auch viele im Bundestag bei ihm nicht durchdringen,
weil er eine eigene Politik, einen Sonderweg mit Russland geht.
Ja, die Putin-Idee von Olaf Scholz wird jetzt hier unterstellt. Das ist so grotesk.
Okay, im Ohr habe ich noch so einen anderen Kiesewetter-Clip jetzt aus dem Februar,
wo er sagt, wir müssen jetzt weit hinter den russischen Linien,
auch auf russischem Gebiet, Krieg machen,
bis hin zu auch die Staatsverwaltung direkt angreifen, wo ja Zivilisten arbeiten
und so weiter, wo es schon wieder fragwürdig ist und so.
Wo ich mir dachte, okay, da kommt man irgendwie schwer wieder raus,
Das kann man als Drohung in den Raum stellen, aber irgendwie,
ich will jetzt kein falsches Wort benutzen, aber...
Man muss deutlich sein, aber man muss auch zeigen, dass man nicht fanatisch ist. Ja.
Und das ist ein sehr schwieriger Weg offenbar für immer mehr.
Fällt sehr vielen Leuten sehr schwer. Aber kommen wir mal ganz kurz noch zu
dieser Debatte, was das alles kostet und wie bezahlt man das.
Und es ist ja doch sehr erstaunlich, dass wir zwar eine große Gruppe in der
Gesellschaft auch haben, die gegen weitere Waffenlieferungen ist oder zumindest
gegen Taurus-Lieferungen.
Wir haben aber auch viele Leute, die dafür sind.
Wir haben auch eine Mehrheit für die Dienstpflicht.
Wir haben die sogar bei jungen Leuten. Also das ist nur eine knappe Mehrheit,
aber da haben wir diese Mehrheit.
Wir haben, wenn es generell darum geht, muss Deutschland kriegstüchtiger werden,
also wir haben einige dieser Umfragen und die sind keineswegs so,
dass man sagen kann, naja 20 Prozent wollen Kriegstüchtigkeit und 80 Prozent nicht.
Sondern es ist schon so, dass man eine große Gruppe in der Bevölkerung hat,
also eine Mehrheit meistens sogar oder auch eine Zweidrittelmehrheit bisweilen,
je nach Alterskohorte, die dafür ist.
Und das finde ich so erstaunlich, dass wir gerade mit dieser Bundesregierung
erlebt haben, dass also so geringe Verbesserungen eigentlich nicht gehen.
Ja, der große Deutschland-Taktbahn wird um 40 Jahre verschoben.
Neun-Euro-Ticket können wir nicht mehr machen.
Kindergrundsicherung, ja, aber zwölf Milliarden weniger.
Hartz-IV heißt Bürgergeld, aber eigentlich jetzt noch vielleicht mit bald härteren
Sanktionen als zuvor. Und all diese Dinge, also wo man so keinen Schritt weiter
kommt, Lohnerhöhungen, ja, aber bitte auf die Lohnpreisspirale achten.
Also minimale Verbesserungen, aber eigentlich große Rückschritte plus Rezession.
Man kann festhalten, den meisten Menschen geht es in Deutschland nicht besser,
sondern eher etwas schlechter oder drastisch schlechter.
Die Heimatfront ist in einem schlechten Zustand.
Ist in einem schlechten Zustand, aber das Interessante ist ja.
Dass nicht in der Bevölkerung daraus genau dieser Gedanke sich ableitet,
den du da gerade wohl im Kopf hast, zu sagen, naja, also jetzt wollen wir erst
vielleicht mal gucken, dass eine Bahn fährt, das wäre für mich die Heimatfront,
um die wir uns kümmern müssen.
Nein, dass man sich offenbar sogar noch mehr Sparmaßnahmen auferlegen wird,
dass man sich selbst mehr bescheidet, weniger Geld in der Tasche hat,
weil man sagt, wir haben da einen Feind, der ist entweder Putin und oder China nimmt sich Taiwan.
Wo ich immer wieder betone, die meisten Leute wissen nicht, wo Taiwan ist.
Ist, das scheint zu reichen als Mini-Ideologie, da ist ein Feind,
dass man bereit ist zu sagen, na gut, geht halt auch nicht alles,
man muss auch mal für die Freiheit frieren oder oder.
Und das finde ich so erstaunlich, dass das ideologisch funktioniert.
Jetzt kann man sagen, na gut, seit zwei Jahren geht das nur in so eine Richtung die ganze Zeit medial.
Aber ich finde trotzdem, obwohl die Leute ganz klar Armut am eigenen Leibe laufend
erfahren und man sieht es, wenn man auf die Straße geht, im Supermarkt ist,
sonst irgendwo, man sieht dort,
wie Leute sehr, sehr rechnen müssen, nicht über den Monat kommen.
Und dass es trotzdem ein Gefühl dafür gibt zu sagen, ja bitte mehr Milliarden
für die Waffenstadt im Umkehrschluss zu sagen, könnten wir uns mal um den Kindergarten vor Ort kümmern.
Und das sieht man dann in kurzer Form auch in einem Auftritt von Clemens Fuest,
der war zu Gast bei Maischberger, also vom ISF.
Was ist das? IFO-Institut?
Clemens Hust ist IFO-Institut.
IFO-Institut, genau. Und da macht er dann die Opposition auf Kanonen oder Butter.
Ich glaube, wenn man mal zurückschaut, es gibt Untersuchungen darüber,
wie das denn in der Vergangenheit so war, wenn man mehr fürs Militär ausgeben musste.
Und das Ergebnis ist ganz klar, dann wurde eben weniger für andere Dinge ausgegeben.
Ich verstehe den Wunsch, ich verstehe, was Sie sagen, Frau Langmann,
bis Sie sich jetzt nicht hinstellen und sagen, ja, tut mir leid,
Leute, wir kürzen jetzt den Sozialstaat zusammen, aber das wird so sein.
Nein, also Kanonen und Butter, es wäre schön, wenn das ginge,
aber das ist Schlaraffenland, das geht nicht.
Sondern es ist Kanonen ohne Butter. Das heißt, wir werden Einbußen haben.
Verschuldung ist ja nur eine Verlagerung von Lasten in die Zukunft.
Es ist ja nicht ein Aus-der-Welt-Schaffen von Lasten.
Ich stimme Ihnen zu, Herr Lindner, je größer das Problem ist,
desto wichtiger ist es, dass wir mehr produzieren. Denn das ist eigentlich der einzige Weg heraus.
Wenn wir wollen, dass wir unseren Sozialstaat weiter finanzieren können,
den werden wir weiter finanzieren.
Aber er wird halt kleiner ausfallen oder andere Dinge werden kleiner ausfallen.
Und man muss halt weniger konsumieren, wenn Ressourcen verbraucht werden.
Ich glaube, man müsste auch in der Politik, ich verstehe, dass das schwer ist,
aber man müsste auch in der Politik offener darüber reden, dass die Welt sich verändert hat.
Bestimmte Dinge gehen nicht mehr ganz so wie vorher.
Trotzdem haben wir die Mittel, die Basics weiter zu finanzieren.
Die Basics sind dann nur noch so ein bisschen Rente, die absolute Existenzabsicherung.
Das ist wirklich interessant. Wir klammern das ja heute mit dem Thema Wohnen.
Wir zahlen in Deutschland 20 Milliarden Euro Wohngeld an die Vermieter.
Das ist der Sozialstaat. Das Geld geht ja nicht an die Mieter,
die geben es ja direkt weiter. Also die Mieter kann man direkt ausklammern.
Das ist Geld, das geht an die Vermieter. Das ist der Sozialstaat.
Würde ich sagen, den können wir da wegkürzen, sofort.
Also ich werde mittlerweile auch Populist gegen das Wohngeld,
weil das hilft nicht den Mietern, das hilft nur den Vermietern.
Wenn man einfach in einer Stadt flächendeckend sagt, 600 neue Anträge pro Woche
in Hamburg, nö, lehnen wir alle ab.
Sollen die Vermieter selber mal gucken, was hier jetzt mit den Turbulenzen auf dem Markt.
Klar, für die Mieter wird es unangenehm, aber am Ende müssen es die Vermieter
dann irgendwie in ihrer Kalkulation einplanen.
Ja, die können nicht mehr, die können dann nur noch halb so hohe Mieten nehmen.
Genau, das ist nur das Wohngeld, 20 Milliarden. Aufstocken Bürgergeld.
Wir haben ja besprochen, wie viele Leute, Max Schritz hat es ja aufgeschrieben, arbeiten.
Die sind also arm trotz Arbeit.
Dieses Aufstocken Bürgergeld, wo wir sagen, das ist ja Sozialstaat,
das kommt dem Arbeitnehmer zugute. Nein, das kommt der Kalkulation des Arbeitgebers zugute.
Er muss weniger Lohn zahlen.
So, ich weiß nicht genau, wie hoch der Eurobetrag ist, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen,
wenn wir diesen superreichen Dekadenzanteil im Sozialstaat rauskürzen,
kämen wir locker auf 3,5 Prozent,
wenn wir das Geld umwidmen, Ausgaben für Verteidigung.
Jetzt ist die Frage, an wen richten wir den Appell zur Solidarität?
An die Leute, die im Supermarkt dann keine Butter kriegen in diesem Bild oder
die Leute, die halt auf ihren siebten Urlaub im Jahr verzichten müssen,
die das schon gar nicht mehr unter Urlaub verbuchen, weil sie einfach reisen.
Das wird natürlich nicht passieren. Also die Kriege werden von armen Menschen
für reiche Leute gekämpft.
Auch an der Heimatfront eben.
Und auch an der Heimatfront, ja. Also dass man da noch das Letzte,
was man hat, auch noch hergibt, damit aufgerüstet werden kann.
Und diese Opposition, die hier aufgemacht wird, ist ja auch insofern falsch,
als hier so getan wird, als hätten wir eine Gesellschaft, die nur nach Bedürfnissen geht.
Also das ist ja eigentlich, in gewisser Weise malt ja Fuß so eine fast sozialistische
Gesellschaft aus, da guckt man, welche Bedürfnisse sind da und wenn die einen
priorisiert werden, dann fallen die anderen weg.
Wir wissen ja, Stichwort Bullshitjobs, es werden ganz, ganz viele Tätigkeiten
in Deutschland ausgeübt, die keine gesellschaftliche Relevanz haben,
die nur da sind, um da zu sein und sich selbst reproduzieren und da würde man
ja auch nicht sagen, ah ja, da muss man aber mal da ran,
alle werden dort abgezogen und in die Rüstung gesteckt, das findet ja so gar nicht statt.
Und hier wird aber die ganze Zeit über so eine Umverteilung dieser Weise geredet
und ja, es war in der Vergangenheit immer so, Fuß hat absolut recht,
dass man so vorgegangen ist und ich gehe auch davon aus, dass man wieder so vorgehen kann,
weil, wie eben geschildert, die Menschen ideologisch dazu bereit sind,
auf so etwas zu verzichten.
Und wenn man sich jetzt noch darüber mal im Klaren wird, was das eigentlich bedeutet.
Wo wir schon so viel Armut in Deutschland haben, ist, dass man am Ende den Leuten sagt,
ja, ihr seid richtig schlecht dran, ihr könntet, wenn ihr wollt,
aber noch eine Karriere bei der Bundeswehr machen, da wird man noch ganz gut
besoldet und dann könnt ihr die Vermieter in Zukunft an allen möglichen Fronten verteidigen.
Ja, genau. Man muss nur die Bilder einmal klarziehen. Und dann wird auch ein Argument raus.
Und das Erschütternde ist nun, dass ich ein Interview gefunden habe von Habeck bei NTV.
Gehalten hat er das, abgehalten hat er das bei der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz.
Er wird da interviewt von Nikolaus Blome.
Und da geht es auch um diese Fragen, ja, was kostet das denn so alles?
Die militärischen Kapazitäten deutlich hochfahren, europäisch integriert,
aber mehr Geld für die Rüstung.
Aber bedeutet der Satz, um noch einen Moment dabei zu bleiben,
dass Aufrüstung letztlich eine Art Kriegswirtschaft oder Wirtschaft für den
Krieg die Priorität 1 dieser Bundesregierung jetzt ist?
Die Priorität 1 bei der Welt, die wir im Moment haben, kann es nicht geben.
Aber sie ist eine wichtige und auch eine noch nicht komplett durchdeklinierte
Priorität, so würde ich es sagen.
Die deutsche Rüstungsindustrie ist stark. Sie war vor allem stark für den Export.
Wenn wir die Situation, in der wir jetzt sind, sagen wir mal mit den 60er Jahren
vergleichen, also der Phase, wo die konkrete Bedrohung eines Krieges in Europa
zum letzten Mal wirklich relevant war, dann produzieren wir nicht genug.
Die deutsche Rüstungsindustrie wiederum ist ja nicht nur Panzer herstellen oder
Fregatten bauen, sondern Cybersicherheit, Drohnen herstellen.
Der künstliche Intelligenzkomplex könnte dadurch nochmal eine ganz andere Fahrt
aufnehmen, aber das kostet Geld.
Darüber reden wir in Wahrheit. Es kostet Geld und wenn wir sagen,
ohne Sicherheit ist alles nichts, dann heißt es eben auch, das andere ist weniger wert.
Also hier werden wir auch schon darauf vorbereitet, dass man da,
Oder, ja, wir werden es vielleicht nicht kürzen, aber doch für das zumindest neu verschulden kann.
Jetzt wissen wir alle, ja, man kann sich neu verschulden, man kann Sondervermögen
machen, das ist auch gar kein Problem.
Aber es gibt ja doch etwas, wo das Kanonen- oder Butterargument eigentlich ganz
gut stimmt und das hat sich jetzt gerade hier angedeutet.
Wenn man jetzt sagt, man gibt 3,5 Prozent für die Rüstung aus,
dann ist das ja nicht einfach, dass man irgendwo Geld hinwirft und dann blüht
was, sondern man braucht Menschen.
Wir wissen, Fachkräftemangel ist hoch. Wir wissen zugleich, die Herausforderungen
irgendwie Schritt zu halten bei den KI-Entwicklungen, bei medizinischen Entwicklungen.
Wir könnten ganz viel über CRISPR, die Gen-Share und all das sprechen.
Also da braucht man wahnsinnig viele Leute. Man braucht unglaublich gute IT-Leute beispielsweise.
Wenn man jetzt aber eine solche Kriegswirtschaft installiert und braucht Menschen
dafür, dann wirbt man die den anderen ab.
Ja, also die kommen dann nicht, also statt KI-Leute Experten zu haben,
die dafür sorgen, dass möglicherweise dadurch bessere Impfungen möglich sind,
medizinische Technik, also all das, was gesellschaftlich notwendig wäre,
die das weiterentwickeln können, vielleicht in der Krebsforschung.
Wir können das jetzt alles so durchdeklinieren. Die Leute, die gebraucht werden,
die die ganzen Sachen zusammenschweißen und so, die vielleicht eher dafür gebraucht
würden, dass man damit die mobile Transformation hinbelangt,
die sind alle dann nicht da.
Die sind dann in der Kriegswirtschaft und die produzieren da etwas, das...
Im besten Falle nicht eingesetzt wird, aber auf keinen Fall irgendjemand nutzt.
Also man kann nicht sagen, naja gut, machen wir Dual Use draus,
dann fahre ich halt demnächst hier mit dem Panzer hin nach Frankfurt. Das ist nicht möglich.
Und das muss man sich, glaube ich, sehr klar vor Augen führen,
wenn wir dieses Kanonen-oder-Butter-Ding haben.
Die Gelder, das ist halt Orthodoxie bei Christian Lindner und so weiter und
dass man damit den Sozialstaat nochmal schön kürzen kann, was dann dazu führt,
dass die Reichen nochmal besseren Druck ausüben können auf die,
die ihre Arbeitskraft verkaufen müssen.
Aber das Kanonen- und Butter- oder Butter-Argument stimmt da tatsächlich,
wo wir davon sprechen, dass einfach ganz viele Leute für die Rüstungsindustrie gebraucht werden.
Wir sehen ja schon den Kanzler jetzt beim Spatenstich und so weiter.
Und wenn man sagt, man möchte aber eigentlich ganz in die Zukunft schreiten
und wir haben uns hier immer für Technologieoffenheit auch ausgesprochen,
haben gesagt, nee, das überlassen wir nicht der FDP.
Und ich bin jetzt noch nicht bereit zu sagen, wir müssen jetzt über Atomkraft
nochmal neu nachdenken, aber ich würde auch sagen, selbst auf diesem Forschungszweig
ist wahrscheinlich noch sehr viel möglich und man wird vielleicht in 30 Jahren
doch dankbar sein, wenn man da viel geforscht hat.
Wenn man aber sagt, nee, wir kümmern uns nur noch um Waffenproduktion,
Atomwaffen und so weiter, dann werden diese Forschungszweige erlahmen.
Höchstens wirft dann mal die Kriegswirtschaft das eine oder andere ab, wie das immer war.
Also militärische Innovationen haben dann plötzlich auch dazu geführt,
dass man irgendwelche neue medizinische Technik hatte.
Ja, aber das ist ja das große Paradox, dass man sagt, okay, diese zwei Prozent
aus dem laufenden gesamtwirtschaftlichen Betrieb geht in eine Sicherheitsinvestition,
denn wenn man die zwei Prozent wegspart, sind die Tore offen und dann gelobt gar nichts.
Nur es soll ja bei einer Drohmacht bleiben. Ja.
Was bedeutet, man baut die ganze Zeit die Lager voll mit Sachen,
die man dann konkret nicht braucht.
Dass aus der Grundlagenforschung irgendwas dann hängen bleibt.
Ein Satellitensystem, das nochmal die Ortung verbessert oder was auch immer.
Aber trotzdem, es stehen sehr viele Menschen an sehr vielen Fließbändern und bauen einfach Panzer.
Und wir brauchen eine Million Artilleriegeschosse. So, jedes Ding wiegt irgendwie 17 Kilo oder so.
Das ist Material, das muss dann ins Regal und da gibt es kein Dual Use.
Also dein Joke ist ja mit dem Panzer herzufahren, aber das ist wirklich der
einzige Fall, wo man sagt, okay, ein SUV kommt so nah irgendwie.
Aber bei dem ganzen anderen Kram, alles das, von dem wir jetzt sehen,
das ist in der Ukraine am dringendsten gebraucht.
Müssen wir einfach, Marc Schill
hat mal so einen ganz knappen Tweet dazu gemacht, das sind Konsumgüter.
Da braucht man sich nichts vorgaukeln, wenn der Staat die herstellt,
kostet das Geld und es ist dann einfach weg.
Das gibt es nicht zurück oder so. Man baut die Dinger nicht wieder auseinander
und gießt dann was anderes draus oder was auch immer, sondern das ist einfach weg.
Damit muss man sagen, ist Deutschland, von dem wir ja immer noch nicht genau verstehen, wo jetzt die.
Potenzialrechnung der Wirtschaft, wir sehen uns einfach nur am Limit überall
und trotzdem in der Rezession.
Und jetzt nochmal zu sagen, okay, und jetzt brauchen wir nochmal einen rein
konsumistischen, wir packen Lagerhallen voll mit Drohmachtstonnen,
Millionen Tonnen an Drohmacht,
das ist in der Rechnung gesehen Verschwendung.
Und ich will nur leicht andeuten, man könnte es sich auch einfacher machen und
sagen, wir eskalieren die Drohmacht so hoch, dass wir sagen,
eine 500 Kilo Atomwaffe reicht, statt 50 Millionen Tonnen Artilleriegeschosse.
Ja, aber offenbar gibt es dieses Bestreben, dass man sich in viele Konflikte einmischen will.
Wir sind ja jetzt auf den Meeren unterwegs, knallen aus Versehen nochmal eine
afrikanische Drohne ab, dort wohl solche Dinge geschehen.
Also man will schon auch permanente Interventionen.
Ich höre einige Hörer im Hintergrund und die sagen, ja sollen wir uns da raushalten?
Und ich würde sagen, nee, wenn man grundsätzlich anders wirtschaftet,
nämlich so, dass nicht auf einen Deutschen 50 Sklaven in der Welt kommen,
hätte man auch nicht, und das ist die Grundlage aller militärischen Auseinandersetzungen,
solche ökonomischen Verwerfungen dazu führen.
Ganz richtig. Das andere ist ein ganzes Bündel von Regeln und Verabredungen,
in denen sich Europa es bequem gemacht hat in den letzten Jahren.
Jeder Staat macht seine eigene nationale Rüstungsindustrie. Wir haben 27 Rüstungsindustrien.
Das kann nicht funktionieren.
Aber heißt es auch, Umschichten im deutschen Bundeshaushalt?
Wenn man sich die Volumina anguckt, über die wir reden, wird es mit Umschichtung kaum zu machen sein.
Das heißt neue Schulden über das Sondervermögen hinaus? Ich würde sagen,
darüber über alles muss man reden.
Aber wenn man sagt, ohne Sicherheit ist alles nichts, dann heißt das,
dass Sicherheit einen Preis hat.
Sicherheit kostet etwas. Sicherheit ist nicht umsonst zu bekommen.
Und die Volumina, über die wir im Moment politisch ringen und streiten,
sind Bruchteile von den Volumina, über die wir reden, wenn wir diesen Satz wirklich ernst meinen.
Ja, noch viel, viel mehr soll also ausgegeben werden und man denkt sich,
ja und das muss aber alles auch wieder umgesetzt werden, dieses Geld in Arbeit
und die muss jemand leisten.
Aber es ist eigentlich schade, dass er das Argument, was er hier drin steckt,
nicht einfach eskaliert, wenn er nämlich darauf reagiert, ja,
irgendwer fordert immer so ein 2% Ziel,
2% von der gesamtwirtschaftlichen Leistung, also nicht nur der Staatsaufwendung
oder wie auch immer, das sind ja 10%, 6-10%, da wo der Staat konkret involviert
ist, also wirklich viel,
dass man es dann den Leuten so leicht durchgehen lässt.
Achso, also du bist so radikal dabei und sagst, 10% des Staates sollte sich
nur ums Verteidigen kümmern, 2% der gesamtwirtschaftlichen Leistung in Deutschland.
Supereskalation bei gleichzeitiger totaler Tabuisierung, dass man das einfach
über einen Kredit finanziert. Also so wie Blome hier sagt.
Und das heißt dann Verschuldung. Da muss man ganz deutlich sagen,
ja, das heißt dann Verschuldung. Es kostet etwas. Ja.
So, wann wir die Kosten verrechnen, ist dann die Frage, ob jetzt oder irgendwann
in 100 Jahren oder so, wenn so eine Kreditlinie dann ausläuft,
die man bei der Zentralbank hat, ist ja auch ein völlig absurdes Konzept,
das man mal besprechen könnte in solchen Runden.
Aber das ist eigentlich interessant, dass da immer so eine Tabuisierung der
Schulden gemacht wird. Umso größer die Eskalation, wir müssen das bezahlen,
umso größer ist das Sabu.
Nein, es muss aus dem laufenden Betrieb. Das ist ja eigentlich absurd.
Dann habe ich doch noch was bei der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz gefunden und
zwar habe ich es eigentlich nur angeklickt, weil ich dachte, naja gut,
es ist wahrscheinlich wieder albern und war es dann überhaupt nicht,
weil ich plötzlich merkte, ah okay, es gibt die feministische Außenpolitik,
die in Anschlag gebracht wird von Baerbock, um irgendeine Intervention zu rechtfertigen,
aber eigentlich geht es da auch immer nur um Aufrüstung.
Und dann gibt es aber auch eine feministische Außenpolitik, wie sie vertreten
wird von Christina Luntz.
Sie hat ja ein Buch dazu geschrieben und ich weiß nicht, ob sie immer so spricht.
Ich kenne ihre Auftritte sonst nicht und ich weiß auch, dass sie da mit Baerbock
irgendwo auftritt oder dass die da ihre komischen Events machen,
wo ja auch viele Selfies geschossen werden.
Ich fand aber jetzt, was sich hier bei der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz sagt,
was sie unter feministischer Außenpolitik versteht, sehr interessant,
denn da geht es jetzt nicht darum zu gucken, wie viele Frauen können Karriere
machen im Außenministerium und da geht es auch nicht darum,
dass man Kanonen rosa anmalt, wie diese ganzen Parodien und Memes,
wir kennen es, immer wieder produziert werden.
Kurze Intervention, wir kennen, wie du sie jetzt reformulierst,
die feministische Außenpolitik nur aus denjenigen, die Kritik von außen üben,
so wie wir immer hören, dass der Ploss aus Hamburg sagt,
die Grünen wollen ja immer nur gendern, dabei hat man nie einen Grünen gehört,
der mal einen Antrag geschrieben hat, jetzt bitte nur gendern.
Ja.
Weil die feministische Außenpolitik war ja immer eine, die einfach sagte,
nur wenn die Frauen ins Bild rücken, kann man ein universalistisches Argument
machen und bislang rückten die Frauen zu wenig ins Bild.
Ja.
Also Rosa Panzer und so weiter war immer nur die Kritik von außen.
Genau, aber das Problem war ja, dass die, die sich jetzt die feministische Außenpolitik
ans Revers geheftet haben, also die wirklichen Politiker, die wiederum haben
das auch einfach nur so mit als Rhetorik noch mitgenommen.
Wir müssen jetzt für Taurus Lieferung sein, sagen aber zugleich auch noch,
wir sind woke und feministisch und dadurch hat natürlich diese feministische
Außenpolitik in ihrem eigenen Anliegen wahnsinnig verloren.
Sie ist zwar in aller Munde, aber sie wird gar nicht mehr für das gehalten,
was sie eigentlich ist und das ist nämlich dann sehr erstaunlich und damit kann
man nämlich auch nochmal sehr gut in die aktuelle Debatte hineingehen.
Feministische Außenpolitik ist der Versuch, traditionelle, konventionelle Außenpolitik,
Außensicherheitspolitik auf den Kopf zu stellen.
Also statt militärische Sicherheit und Nationalstaat und Militarisierung,
Aufrüstung und wirtschaftliche Interessen in das Zentrum von außensicherheitspolitischen
Handeln wird Menschenrechte, menschliche Sicherheit und der Versuch,
wirklich die Sicherheitsbedürfnisse aller Menschen auf der ganzen Welt zu beachten,
in den Mittelpunkt gestellt.
Im Prinzip, was du da gerade schon sagtest mit dem Lieferkettengesetz,
wenn wir mal nicht unsere 50 Sklaven hätten, dann müssten wir jetzt auch nicht
irgendwo in den Meeren rumschiffern.
Und wir werden ab jetzt häufiger auf dieses eine Argument von Rutger Breschmann
zu sprechen kommen, in »Im Grunde gut«.
Dass nämlich die Frage ist, wer setzt sich insbesondere in politischen Hierarchien,
also in Parteiapparaten eigentlich durch?
Wer erringt das Recht, ein Mandat im Parlament, also wer geht als Delegierter
irgendwo hin, wer wird Parteichef, wer wird irgendwie Fraktionsleiter und so weiter und so fort.
Und Rutger Brechmann sagt ja, im Grunde sind wir gut, aber irgendwas stimmt
mit dem Auswahlprozess nicht, weil sich diejenigen, die im sozialen Nahkampf
sehr rücksichtslos sind.
Sich besonders qualifizieren für die große Bühne, weil wenn man dann erstmal
einem Saal von 400 gegenüber sitzt und eine Parteitagsrede halten muss,
ist man besser ein bisschen narzisstisch,
schlägt über die Stränge und nimmt nicht allzu viel Rücksicht auf,
da sitzen noch 80 Leute, die mögen mich nicht oder so.
Es setzen sich also Leute durch, die nicht so richtig sozial sind. Die asozialen.
Die schamlos sind, das schreibt er ja auch.
Genau. Und wir haben ja sehr kritisiert, dass Rutger Brechmann,
obwohl er das Argument ja ganz am Anfang macht,
Churchill liest Psychologie der Massen und hat Angst davor, dass der deutsche
Luftangriff die Briten in so große Panik versetzt, dass jeder sich selbst der
Nächste ist und man da nur noch Kannibalismus unter den Briten hat.
Und er stellt danach fest, ach nee, es gab große Solidaritätswellen.
Und Brechmann sagt ganz am Anfang...
Er hat einfach, also Churchill als Staatschef, hat seine eigene Persönlichkeit
auf alle gemappt. Aber er ist eben einer dieser wenigen, die sich aus diesen
genannten Asozialitätsgründen durchgesetzt haben in einer politischen Hierarchie-Besetzungsfrage. Frage.
Und wir haben dann gefragt, warum gibt es das nur so als ganz kleinen Abschnitt
in so einem erfolgreichen Buch und dann auch gar nicht weiter thematisiert,
warum gibt es da keinen Grundbegriff für, so wie wir das PETA-Prinzip haben,
dass man so ein Alphatier-Mechanismus irgendwie nochmal definiert oder wie auch immer.
Und in der feministischen Außenpolitik
wird versucht, so eine grundlegende Mechanik fruchtbar zu machen.
Nämlich, nee, es sind immer nur, und dann verwechselt man so ein bisschen,
also sag ich jetzt mal, Männer, ich würde sagen, nee, so Alphatiere.
Außenpolitik wird von Alphatieren für eine Bevölkerung gemacht,
die virtuell ausgedacht ist von den Alphatieren die ihre eigene psychologische,
Konstitution auf die Bevölkerung übertragen und da gibt es ein Mismatch und
die feministische Außenpolitik versucht das jetzt wieder einzufangen,
indem sie sagt ne, die Bevölkerung steht aus ganz vielen Kindern, Frauen,
Gebrechlichen, wie auch immer es ist nicht nur der Alphatier,
der sich irgendwo durchgesetzt hat, der dann einfach glaubt,
alle sind wie er oder sowas sondern hier diesen blinden Fleck rauszuarbeiten,
ist eine Leistung der feministischen Außenpolitik und das brauchen wir eigentlich häufiger.
Und der Breschmann hat uns da wieder drin bekräftigt, dass wir da viel mehr
drüber nachdenken müssen, dass wir im Grunde gut sind, aber wenn wir uns organisieren müssen,
weil wir eben nicht nur in familiären Gruppen, Freundschaftsverbänden und so
weiter leben, sondern eine große Weltgesellschaft haben mit acht Milliarden Menschen,
da setzen sich die falschen Leute durch. und damit auch die falschen Denkmuster und davon ...
Darunter leiden dann alle und so weiter und so fort. Und die feministische Außenpolitik
müsste eigentlich unter diesem Gesichtspunkt nochmal rehabilitiert werden,
nachdem sie jetzt von Kämpfern angeblicher feministischer Außenpolitik wie Baerbock
so in den Dreck gezogen wurde.
Ja, ganz klar. Oder dass dann auch tatsächlich so manche posten,
Margaret Thatcher ist eine feministische Politikern gewesen.
Nein, natürlich nicht. Das ist das schamlose Alphatier, das sich durchsetzt
und beim Falklandkrieg natürlich nichts anderes kennt als schießen und nicht
sagt, wir müssen das mal holistisch betrachten und wie können wir das Leben
der Menschen besser machen. Wir hören sie mal weiter.
100 Milliarden Euro Sondervermögen aus der Taufe gehoben.
Menschen haben sich fundamental geändert, was ihre politischen Einstellungen
zu Waffenlieferungen angeht. Wir diskutieren ja den Sicherheitsbegriff eigentlich
aktuell eher wieder in die Richtung, die Sie vorhin angesprochen haben.
Also irgendwie militärisch, Waffen. Das geht ja gerade wieder so ein bisschen zurück zu dem Alten hin.
Inwiefern kann denn eine Außenpolitik 2024 in so einer krass aufgeladenen geopolitischen
Lage noch feministisch sein?
Ja, aktuell sehen wir weltweit von Außenpolitik, die von Regierungen gemacht
wird, ganz wenig feministische Elemente oder Elemente, die die Möglichkeit wirklich
haben, transformativ hinzuwirken auf nachhaltige Sicherheit und Frieden in der Welt.
Es ist ganz genau so, wie Sie sagen.
In Zeiten von weltweiten Krisen und Konflikten und in so sehr stressvollen Zeiten am Ende,
Gehen die Menschen im großen Teil, nicht alle, aber gehen die Menschen im großen
Teil irgendwie dahin zurück, was sie irgendwie kennen?
Zu denken, man könne sich für immer mit noch mehr Waffen irgendwie verteidigen
und damit Frieden schaffen, wenn wir doch wissen aus Forschung,
dass ein Mehr an Waffen und Militarisierung in der Welt immer zu einem Mehr
an Kriegen und Konflikten führen wird.
Das würde mir nämlich auch laufen, dass man sagt, nein, nein,
Aufrüstung ist alles immer nur Abschreckung und die Munition wird ja nicht geschossen,
darum geht es ja eigentlich.
Nein, man kann zwar immer den kalten Krieg hier anführen, dass es da nicht zu
der ultimativen Eskalation gekommen ist, aber auch da gab es ja Kriege.
Also wir hatten dann den Vietnamkrieg der Amerikaner, wir hatten den Krieg um
Afghanistan, der dann noch eine sehr lange Geschichte bis ins 21.
Jahrhundert haben wird.
Vieles weitere wäre aufzuzählen und das ist also ein Irrglaube,
dass man immer nur denkt, naja die rüsten sich so gegenseitig auf und dann fällt
aber nirgends ein Schuss, sondern
wir sehen ja gerade dann durch Stellvertreterkriege, was alles passiert.
Ja, du hast ja eben Margaret Thatcher angesprochen, also dieses Argument,
Demokratien führen keine Kriege gegen andere. Nein, stimmt nicht.
England hat gegen Argentinien Krieg geführt und das waren beides Demokratien.
So, das Einzige, wo man heute noch und zwar nur empirisch und alles darüber
hinaus ist ein Wunder, sagen kann, da hat Abschreibung funktioniert,
ist bei der Androhung von Atomwaffen.
So, deswegen würde ich auch nie einen Vorwurf Scholz gegenüber so einfach durchgehen
lassen, wie es immer gemacht wird. Er sagt, er lässt sich von Atomwaffen beeindrucken. Ja, natürlich.
Natürlich lässt er sich von Atomwaffen beeindrucken. Und deswegen haben wir
ja auch eine relativ wichtige Diskussion, wie wir das jetzt in Europa machen.
Denn Atomwaffen sind nun mal in der Welt und man, und das ist eben,
da muss sich dann jeder selber mal kurz prüfen.
Auf welcher Seite will man stehen? Teilnehmer, also Bürger des Landes,
das Atomwaffen hat oder das nicht hat.
Wir haben da eine sehr komfortable Lage. Wir sind keine Afrikaner,
die dem einfach ausgeliefert sind, sondern wir können darüber politisch befinden
und das wird da einfach ausgeblendet.
Wir hören nochmal, was Christina Lohns sagt.
Über die letzten zehn Jahre zwischen 2010 und 2020, also nicht ganz die letzten
zehn Jahre, hat sich die Zahl internationaler Kriege und Konflikten verdoppelt.
Die Zahl von Menschen, die fliehen mussten, hat sich auch verdoppelt von circa
40 auf 80 Millionen und inzwischen sind wir bei ungefähr 120 Millionen.
Wir stehen aktuell weltweit bei jährlichen Militärausgaben bei über 2 Trillionen US-Dollar.
Die Zahlen sind verrückt und gleichzeitig sind die Ausgaben für beispielsweise
Friedensmissionen der Vereinten Nationen bei ca.
0,4% dieser Ausgaben für Militarisierung. Also die Menschheit versucht seit
Jahrzehnten und seit Jahrhunderten immer wieder dasselbe, um endlich was Neues
zu erreichen, nämlich endlich Frieden, den es weltweit noch nicht gab.
Und das ergibt natürlich überhaupt gar keinen Sinn. Und feministische Außenpolitik
sagt im Grunde einfach nur, Leute,
wir versuchen jetzt ziemlich lange irgendwie mit diesen Zuballern von Waffen,
von Aufbauen von Feindbildern, von Gewalt, irgendwas zu erreichen,
was nachhaltig für Stabilität und Sicherheit schaffen sollte.
Und das klappt einfach nicht und wir versuchen es weiter und es wird wieder nicht klappen.
Ja, sehr richtig. Und hier muss man auch nochmal verstehen, dass der Feminismus
an sich ja ein ganzheitliches Konzept ist.
Der Feminismus ist ja nicht Klientelpolitik für Frauen und die Männer vergessen
wir, sondern eigentlich ist der feministische Ansatz auch einer,
der Männer mitmeint, um es so zu sagen.
Und die Herrscherinnen, die fallen tatsächlich raus und das ist ja schon bei
Simone de Beauvoir zu lesen in Le Deuxième Sex,
in dem sie sagt, dass es zwar in der Geschichte immer Herrscherpersönlichkeiten
weibliche gegeben hat, aber diese sind Herrscherpersönlichkeiten.
Und die spaltet sie quasi so ab von der Situation der Frau an sich und das ist
gut, um das nochmal so sich klar zu machen und jetzt haben wir hier schon einige Zahlen gehört,
wo viel Geld ausgegeben wird, Trillionen und wo dann nur noch so ein paar Groschen
hingeworfen werden und sie macht das jetzt hier nochmal sehr deutlich.
Und feministische Außenpolitik oder feministisch-transformative Ansätze,
die würden zum Beispiel hier bei einer Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz sagen,
wieso sprechen wir auch heute Morgen beim Podium mit dem griechischen Premierminister
und dem deutschen Finanzminister und anderen sprechen wir über das 2% Ziel wieder.
Aber wir sprechen nicht darüber, über andere finanzielle Ziele.
Das kann sein, die 0,7 für internationale Zusammenarbeit, 0,7 Prozent des GDP.
Es können aber auch die Ausgaben sein für die Klimatransformation.
Es können ganz andere Richtlinien sein für Politik, verbunden mit Ausgaben,
die wirklich dazu beitragen, dass wir eine sichere und stabile Welt schaffen.
Aber darüber reden wir ganz, ganz wenig.
Und der Fokus ist immer wieder auf die alten Muster.
Und ich glaube, es war Albert Einstein, der einmal sagte, you can't solve a
problem with the mindset with which you created it.
Und wir versuchen es immer, immer wieder als Gesellschaft.
Und das wird uns, wenn wir nur so weitermachen, werden wir nicht dahin kommen,
dass wir eine Welt schaffen, die wirklich nachhaltig sicher ist für alle Menschen.
Ja, sehr gut. Ich würde ja nämlich nicht Krieg und Frieden gegenüberstellen,
denn wenn wir jetzt sagen, okay, zwei Billionen pro Jahr bezahlen wir für Kriegsmaterial oder so,
dem steht ja dann das ganze Bruttoinlandsprodukt gegenüber,
das ja grundsätzlich für Frieden sorgt.
Nur diese Nachhaltigkeit, also dieser Einspruch, Einsteinspruch.
Dass man ein Mindset, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob das Zitat original ist,
wenn das Wort Mindset drin vorkommt beim Albert Einstein, aber gut.
Dass man hier so ein Nachhaltigkeitsding, wenn die FDP eine politische Entscheidung
trifft, ein Gesetz, muss sie sich fragen, was bedeutet das für die strukturellen
Gegebenheiten in zehn Jahren?
Daran haben wir es auf Dauer gestellt oder haben wir etwas einem Risiko ausgesetzt?
Und das ist ja nur, das kann man immer wieder mal anbringen.
Die FDP hat ja jetzt wirklich Europa zerstört.
Dieses German Vote, also wir kommen, nachdem eigentlich alle dachten,
es ist durch, nochmal mit einem Veto. Das machen jetzt ganz schön viele Länder.
Und die FDP sagt dann so, seht ihr, wir sind nicht die Einzigen.
Ihr wart die Ersten. Ihr wart die Pioniere, die das Gebäude eingerissen haben.
Und das muss man irgendwie sprechfähig machen.
So, dass man dafür Begriffe und was auch immer hat, um das zu thematisieren.
Also diesen Nachhaltigkeitsaspekt. Gut, wir bleiben beim Thema und gehen mal
spezifisch auf so eine Überlegung.
Wir haben ein Wort, das gehört zum Grundbegriff
unserer Gesellschafts- und Gesellschaftsführung, Nachkriegsordnung.
Also wir haben eine soziale Ordnung, die aus einem Krieg heraus passierte,
aber erst nach dem Krieg. Also ein Krieg musste beendet worden,
dann gibt es eine Nachkriegsordnung.
Der Zweite Weltkrieg endet und wir haben plötzlich eine Vereinte Nation mit
einem gewissen Aufgaben- und auch Kompetenzbereich.
Wir gründen so eine Kohle- und Stahlunion, statt dass Frankreich mal wieder das Ruhrgebiet abbaut.
Und so nach und nach wachsen so Institutionen, die bis heute 70,
80 und vielleicht hoffentlich 100 Jahre noch einfach als Nachkriegsordnung gelten.
Dann haben wir den Kalten Krieg, der beendet wird und wir haben wieder so eine
Art Nachkriegsordnung,
aber da ist ja irgendwie nur ein, wie soll man sagen, angedroht,
aber kein ausgelebter Krieg oder wie auch immer man sich das dann schönredet,
war die Nachkriegsordnung schon sehr viel schwächer, die...
Nach dem Kalten Krieg herausgearbeitet wurde.
Aber sie war jetzt nochmal Thema, als Tusk, der neue Premierminister in Polen,
in Deutschland war, um Scholz einen Antrittsbesuch zu machen.
Lieber Kanzler, lieber Olaf, lieber Freund, sagt Tusk und beide,
Scholz und Tusk, beschwören das,
was 1991 einmal als Motor für Europa entstanden war, das Weimarer Dreieck,
die Kooperation von Frankreich, Deutschland und Polen.
Ich glaube, dass eine gute Zusammenarbeit zwischen Polen, Frankreich und Deutschland
auch gut ist für Europa insgesamt.
Und deshalb werden wir aus diesem Format rausholen, was da rauszuholen ist.
Tusk guckt Scholz da an und sagt, wir sind ja beide sehr praktische Menschen.
Das Weimarer Dreieck sei nur dann sinnvoll, wenn es um mehr gehe als um reine Routine treffen.
Tusk will eine europäische Kooperation bei der militärischen Produktion.
Tusk will Polen am europäischen Raketenabwehrschirm beteiligen.
Und Tusk sagt, egal was dieser Donald Trump da erzähle, jedes NATO-Land müsse
jetzt mehr für Verteidigung ausgeben. Das sorgt beim Kanzler für die fast reflexhafte
Wiederholung eines Versprechens.
Deutschland wird in diesem Jahr 2% der Wirtschaftsleistung nach NATO-Kriterien
für die NATO-Zwecke ausgeben und wird es für alle Zeit tun. Für alle Zeit.
Was den russischen Angriffskrieg angeht, sagen beide, Deutschland und Polen
eine der Wunsch nach einem gerechten Frieden in der Ukraine.
Was Deutschland und Polen nicht eint, ist aber beispielsweise die polnische
Forderung nach Reparationen für die Schäden durch den deutschen Angriff im Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Aber auch da versöhnliche Töne von Tusk.
Man werde miteinander reden, ohne einander öffentlich zu verletzen.
Ende der Pressekonferenz.
So, 1991 bildet sich das Warschauer Dreieck, weil Deutschland und Frankreich
der Meinung sind, wir holen Polen jetzt dazu.
Immerhin wurde hier die Gewaltandrohung des Warschauer Paktes überwunden und
wenn Warschau jetzt Teil eines Warschauer Dreiecks sein kann,
dann kann man das ja in die Friedensordnung des Friedensprojekts Europäische
Union so integrieren, dass es von Bedeutung ist.
Und heute, 33 Jahre später, stellen wir fest, achso, da war irgendwas,
keine Ahnung, Warschauer Dreieck, hab ich noch nie gehört, kannst du das mal erklären?
So, also keiner hat daran angeknüpft.
Und nicht nur das, das ist jetzt wieder ein Warschauer Dreieck.
Wird jetzt weniger als Nachkriegsordnung verstanden, sondern Claudia Major im
8-Millionen-Milliarden-Podcast des Spiegel definiert es einfach um als so eine Vorkriegsordnung.
Jetzt kann man ja schon überlegen, eine Nachkriegsordnung hieß ja bisher immer,
wir nehmen so ganz viele zivile Kräfte und stärken die.
Und sagen, es gibt jetzt eine Welthandelsorganisation, Leute sollen mal friedlich
handeln und wir regeln das dann ein bisschen.
Eine Weltgesundheitsorganisation, Gesundsein wäre schon ganz gut und du musst
nicht erst in Kriegsversehrter werden, sondern wir sorgen uns einfach mal so
um dich und so weiter und so fort. Europäische Union.
Gemeinsames Wirtschaftswachstum, das Wirtschaftswunder, alles wird durchlebt.
Das sind eigentlich große zivile Projekte.
Im Vergleich dazu, was ist eine Vorkriegsordnung? Wir bereiten uns auf einen Krieg vor.
Also wir konzentrieren uns nur noch auf möglichst viele Waffenproduktionen,
möglichst viele erfolgreiche Diskussionen, Und dass wir ganz viel aus der Volkswirtschaft
rausangeln, um das dann in dieses rein konsumistische Kriegsmaterial,
Vorbereitungsprozesse zu verlagern und so weiter und so fort.
Und wie salopp und leichtfüßig das hier einfach praktiziert wird,
finde ich sehr erschreckend.
Ich fand es sehr begrüßenswert, dass die Außenminister des Weimarer Dreiecks,
Frankreich, Deutschland, Polen, das vor einigen Tagen gemacht haben.
Also politische Geschlossenheit in einsatzfähige Streitkräfte voll ausgestattet,
die realitätsnah üben zu investieren, in eine rüstungsindustrielle Basis zu
investieren, also kompetitive, innovative Industrie.
Das sind ja alle Sachen, die wir schon wissen seit Jahren. Aber dass man das
einfach nochmal ernster nimmt. Plus letzter Punkt.
Ja, eine Vorkriegsordnung machen die.
Also hier wird einfach dieses ganze, das Warschauer Dreieck,
eine große, expansive, europäisch verbindende Idee, wird hier einfach komplett
ausgehöhlt und es bleibt nur noch, ah ja, die machen jetzt gemeinsam Kriegsvorbereitung.
So, das ist geblieben nach 33 Jahren Warschauer Dreieck, wo man jetzt eigentlich
die Chance hat, okay, es ist gerade keine polnische Regierung,
die von uns Reparationszahlung fordert.
Also selbst die Nachkriegsordnung, die extrem zivil gestaltet wurde,
nochmal ausbeutet Richtung, eigentlich haben wir da noch einen Krieg abzuklären.
Und viele hatten Polen schon abgeschrieben. Also das ist ja jetzt nochmal ein
Moment, wo man sagen kann, oh, da haben wir wohl doch nochmal Glück gehabt oder
Europa, die EU bekommt nochmal eine Chance damit.
Mit Tusk und dass hier es nur darauf hinaus läuft.
Ich habe sehr viel darüber nachgedacht, jetzt in den letzten Wochen,
wo man ja dann Claudia Major siebenmal am Tag im Fernsehen sehen kann.
Was ist das eigentlich, warum auch die Politiker,
dass diese Experten und Journalisten und auch die Bevölkerung doch es irgendwie
so toll findet mit der Aufrüstung.
Also ich habe darüber nachgedacht und ich glaube, es ist ein bisschen wie bei
Corona, man hat mal Wirksamkeit, man hat mal einen handelnden Start.
Also ich bin ja jetzt, es war wieder ein Fiasko, ich war in Leipzig,
toller Auftritt, aber die Fahrt, ich will gar nicht drüber sprechen und du sitzt
dann da an dem Zug und alle haben aber resigniert, also alle auf dem Bahnsteig haben resigniert,
du blickst nur in Gesichter, alle haben resigniert. Niemand glaubt mehr irgendetwas.
Die Leute, die ich kenne, die Kinder haben, da weiß jeder, es wird an der Schule
immer schlimmer, es werden Unterrichtsausfälle sein.
Also alle haben da irgendwie sich mit abgefunden. Das Einzige,
wo sie einen handelnden Staat erleben, ist, wow, 100 neue Panzer geschaffen,
eine Million Schuss, hier wieder eine neue Fabrik eröffnet.
Wir haben ja Olaf Scholz jetzt auch beim Spatenstich gesehen.
Rheinmetall hat ganz Großes vor. All das hören wir, die Kurse gehen nach oben
Und die Politiker und da schließe ich auch Habeck und all diese Leute mit ein,
können jetzt tatsächlich mal Wirtschaftsminister sein,
sonst haben sie keinen Spielraum, hier haben sie den, die Bevölkerung findet
es auch toll, dass irgendetwas passiert und das genügt denen offenbar und das
ist so erschreckend zu sehen. Ja.
Während man sich ansonsten mit Gegenpositionen umschlägt, wie,
also die zwei Milliarden für die Kindergrundsicherung war aber jetzt das letzte
sozialpolitische Projekt der nächsten drei Jahre, ist bei dem Thema Waffe,
ja, schicken wir sie jetzt, kriegen wir sie jetzt, kaufen wir sie jetzt,
wo wird die Fabrik gebaut und so weiter und so fort.
Und jetzt haben wir dieses Warschauer Dreieck, das nun von ihr schon umgedeutet
wurde in eine Vorkriegsordnung.
Man hätte ja auch sagen können, nee, dass Tusk jetzt regiert, insbesondere als…,
Europäischer Politiker mit
nun sehr viel praktischer Erfahrung und Bekanntschaften in allen Ländern,
der ist ja nun als Ratspräsident wirklich rumgekommen, hätten ja einfach Scholz
und Macron eine gemeinsame große Einladungsgeste und dann von mir aus auch mit allem Pomp.
Wir feiern jetzt das zivile Projekt, der nächste Schritt nach Kruxordnung Polen
endlich wieder bei uns am Tisch.
Stattdessen davon gar nichts, sondern nur Streitereien zwischen Scholz und Macron
inklusive wir begegnen uns einfach nicht, wir ignorieren uns,
gehen uns aus dem Weg und Major ist deswegen der Weg frei,
um einfach den Tenor in der öffentlichen Debatte so zu setzen.
Plus letzter Punkt, wehrhafte oder wie der Verteidigungsminister sagen würde,
kriegstüchtige, nicht nur Bundeswehr, sondern auch Gesellschaft.
Also eine Gesellschaft, die die Notwendigkeit von Verteidigung versteht,
das unterstützt und auch Ideen, was man so als Gesamtverteidigung bezeichnet,
mitträgt. Wie schützen wir unsere kritischen Infrastrukturen?
Weiß jeder, wo ein Schutzbunker ist?
Kennen wir den Sirenenton? Wären wir bereit, in einem Krisenfall in Kauf zu
nehmen, dass die Autobahn gesperrt wird, weil da irgendwelche Transporte durch müssen?
Wir kennen all unsere Politiker und unsere Ministerien, die Pläne,
was zu tun ist, wenn wir einen Verteidigungsfall haben oder einen Spannungsfall haben.
Also das ist so ein Gesamtpaket, mit dem wir uns auseinandersetzen müssen.
Ganz ehrlich, ich weiß nicht, wie es Ihnen geht, aber ich weiß nicht,
wo in der Nähe meiner Wohnung Schutzbunker für die Nachbarschaft sind.
Und ich fürchte, ich kann auch nicht mehr die einzelnen Sirenentöne auseinanderhalten.
Ja, das wird ja nochmal sonor hinterher moderiert. Vorwürfe gemacht.
Sind denn alle wahnsinnig geworden?
Du weißt ja gar nicht, wie die Sirenen klingen.
Ne, weiß ich gar nicht. Wie klingen denn die Sirenen?
Ja, das ist wirklich.
Aber man findet es toll. Also ich meine, der Krieg hat ja selten Leuten geholfen
und trotzdem sind sie ja bereitwillig reingegangen in den Krieg.
Und wir können hier sehen, man hat so wenig Identitätsstiftnisse.
Ich muss es ein bisschen abstrakt formulieren, weil ich keinen Namen nennen
will, aber ich verfolge so geheim einige Jusos,
so bei Insta, Twitter und so, die absolut auf dem Kurs sind,
jetzt kriegstüchtig und Pistorius ist der tollste Mann der Welt und so weiter.
Und das sind so Leute, die auch dann zum Abenteuerurlaub fahren.
Sich dann noch sieben Tattoos stechen lassen und mal am Strand bei fünf Grad
Minus schlafen und dann mit den Haien tauchen und sowas.
Und da gibt es offenbar, wenn ich mir diese Posts so ansehe zum Krieg und was
sie sonst so machen in ihrer Freizeit, gibt es eine große Abwesenheit von Sinn
oder eine große Sinnsuche,
irgendwas Existenzielles erleben.
Ernst Jünger hat damals diesen Essay geschrieben, der Krieg als inneres Erlebnis,
hat dann Theweleit ausführlichst analysiert in den 70er Jahren und diese Sehnsucht
ist gerade so bei interessanterweise Jusos extrem da, dass man nochmal so irgendwas sinnstiftend ist.
Der liebe Gott, der ist vielleicht gar nicht da, die kirchlichen Institutionen
jedenfalls, die ziehen einen auch nicht an aus diversen Gründen,
sonst geht es auch nicht so richtig weiter.
Vielleicht sind auch die Beziehungsmodelle überholt, die bei meinen Eltern oder
Großeltern noch geklappt haben und dann sucht man da nochmal so eine neue Erfahrung.
Und das scheint etwas zu sein, dass man auch hier jetzt mit diesen,
ja wo kann man dann Sicherheit herstellen, Alarm, wie verhalten wir uns denn
da, dass man darüber nochmal so eine Gemeinschaft stiften kann,
also eine Gemeinschaft, die beruht auf Angst.
Angst, alle angenehmen Gemeinschaften sollten ja eigentlich nicht aus Angst
beruhen, also wir gehen ja heute Abend noch in die Oper, treffen da ganz wunderbare Leute,
gehen danach noch in die Bar, aber es ist keine Angstgemeinschaft,
wir treffen uns da, damit wir sicher sind vor den Kriminellen in Frankfurt oder so,
sondern wir treffen uns, weil wir einander mögen, interessant finden,
lustig finden und das ist eigentlich das, wie eine Gemeinschaft aufgebaut sein muss.
Ja, wir können ja rüber ins Bahnhofsviertel gehen.
Und mal gucken und dann gewährleisten wir uns gegenseitig Sicherheit.
Ja, du hast gesehen, im Bahnhofsviertel gibt es jetzt für die Mitarbeiter in
US-Konzernen extra Pläne, wie sie zu gehen haben.
Aber das war ein Scherz, oder? Die sollen alle durch die Dingsstraße gehen.
Die sollen durch gewisse Straßen nicht mehr gehen. Naja, wie dem auch sei.
Und also über Angst eine Gemeinschaft herzustellen, das ist hier das Ziel und
ich würde sagen, der Plan geht so langsam auf.
Also hier sind wir wieder bei Breschmanns Alphatier-Argument.
Ja.
Mark Zuckerberg baut sich einen Bunker. Er ist der Alpha-Prepper.
Und jetzt sollen wir auch alle zu Preppern werden, weil du weißt ja,
mit ein bisschen mehr Skills kannst du dich selbst der Welt erwehren,
wenn sie über dich hereinbricht.
Wir reden ja nachher über das Dating, wo ja Menschen immer wieder berichten,
dass sie sich am verletzlichsten fühlen, wenn sie so auf Resonanzsuche sind
und dann abgelehnt werden.
Und der eine, der einen ablehnt oder die eine ist dann gleich stellvertretend
für die ganze Welt und das Selbstbild ist im Arsch. Und das ist hier auf politischer Ebene.
Wir sind niemand, wenn wir uns nicht verteidigen können.
Wenn nicht alle im Taekwondo waren, mit einem Stock umgehen können und so weiter
und es wird dann so verkleidet in, wenn du Wissen darüber hast,
wie die Sirene funktioniert und man denkt sich so, könnte durchaus ein gutes Schulmaterial sein,
aber wir haben noch ganz schön viele andere wichtige Lehrinformationen,
die wir mal so vermitteln wollten in Schulen, die vielleicht funktionieren sollten,
damit sowas grundlegend funktioniert.
Und dann wieder das Heimatfront-Argument, wenn wir die Grundlegenden dafür gelegt
haben, ja, dann können wir auch nochmal den Zettel durchgehen,
was für die Sirenen draufsteht an Informationen,
aber nicht, wir sortieren erstmal alle zivilen Projekte raus,
Zwarscher Dreieck wird an den Rand geschoben, übrig bleibt die Checkliste,
welche Sirene bedeutet was, so, ja, das ist einfach bescheuert.
Und in diesem ganzen großen Kontext finde ich es crazy mittlerweile,
wie sich Strack-Zimmermann verhält.
Nicht nur, dass sie da ein Vote gegen die Ampelregierung macht,
wo man sich denkt, wie so machen das die anderen nicht auch?
Warum glaubt sie jetzt? Das ist so eine wichtige Frage, wo man sagt,
ich stimme nicht mit der Koalition.
Was ist, wenn die Grünen jetzt anfangen und sagen, naja, die richtige zivilisatorische
Bedrohung ist eigentlich der Klimawandel.
Und wir können diese unverantwortliche Politik hier nicht mitziehen.
Wir machen jetzt alle mal ein anderes Voting.
Also das ist doch, diese Art von Politikverständnis ist unfassbar.
Und ihr, wie soll man sagen, ich will jetzt nicht sagen ihr Gesellschaftsverständnis,
sondern ihr Verständnis dafür, wie die Debatte gerade läuft, ist auch unglaublich.
Sie macht hier einfach diesen Spruch, von dem ich sage, das ist doch wirklich
das falsche Vorzeichen.
Ich sage es mal so, ich verstehe, dass Menschen müde werden angesichts dieses
Krieges, zwei Jahre her, immer diese Bilder, immer darüber sprechen.
Es hat aber in Deutschland bisher noch keiner einen Nachteil davon,
dass wir der Ukraine helfen. Also es ist nicht so, dass irgendjemand etwas genommen wird.
Aber was uns genommen wird, wenn wir das nicht tun, das sage ich mal ganz pathetisch,
ist unser Frieden in Freiheit.
So, du stürzt ein ganzes Land in Zukunftsangst, jagst die Inflation auf 10%
hoch, machst eine Zinspolitik, die wirklich völlig neben der Spur ist,
wir kommen nachher beim Thema Wohnen drauf.
Das kürzt jetzt Gelder, weil man sagt, wir brauchen auch fürs Militär.
Nichts passt mehr. Und sie kommt, naja, da hat keiner einen Nachteil von.
Was meint sie denn? Hat sie jetzt im Hinterkopf noch so eine,
ja wartet mal ab, wenn Putin zulangt oder was?
Was das denn für Nachteile sind? Dann wisst ihr, was ein Nachteil ist.
Also das ist wirklich mittlerweile.
Die Dame kommt ja aus Düsseldorf, sie wird wahrscheinlich da die Köhe rauf und runter gehen und so.
Ja, da merkt man es wahrscheinlich nicht.
Hier ist ja noch alles super. Die Schaufenster bei Chanel sind immer noch voll.
Ja.
Wo ist das Problem?
Das ist alles nicht gut. Kommen wir also mal zu einem Thema,
das mir in diesem Monat besonders wichtig war.
Wir hören trocken in diesen Clip rein und ich sage euch, der ändert dann noch
relativ zügig sein Thema.
Wir sehen nicht, dass wir eine ordnungsgemäße Durchführung hier garantieren
können. Sie hören es vielleicht auch selber vor der Halle.
Es gab zum Teil auch aggressive Stimmungen und deswegen hatten wir uns dazu
entschlossen, den heute abzusagen.
Tja, mehr zum politischen Aschermittwoch, dem Abgesagten der Grünen von Biberach,
als auch den Haudrau-Veranstaltungen, die durchaus stattfanden, gleich.
Ebenso zur Frage, ob diese Veranstaltung noch in Zeiten wie diese überhaupt passt.
Zuvor aber geht es um die wirklich ernsten Dinge an diesem Tag.
Um die Verteidigung Europas, wie diese sicherer werden kann.
Durch mehr Hilfen für die Ukraine in ihrem Stellvertreterkrieg.
Durch mehr Geld, das die NATO-Staaten für Verteidigung ausgeben.
Und das geistert jetzt als Frage im Raum auch durch europäische Atomwaffen.
All das hat Donald Trump mit ausgelöst mit seiner Wahlkampfdrohung.
Er werde, sollte er wieder Präsident werden, keine Verbündeten mit verteidigen,
die selbst zu wenig täten fürs Militär.
So, wir haben also eine Hinwendung des Themas innerhalb dieser Moderation zum
Anfang des Deutschlandfunk. Das war der Tag am 14.
Mit, ah ja, die Atomwaffenfrage steht im Raum. Während wir am Anfang schon hören,
nee, der politische Aschermittwoch, also eine wirkliche Partyveranstaltung,
die an den Karneval anschließt, ist mittlerweile ein Bürgerkrieg geworden.
Wo man einfach, ach, hier kommt ein 100.000 Euro Auto mit einem Bundesminister
drin, ich schmeiß mal die Scheibe ein.
So, was finde ich völlig entgrenzte.
Ja, es ist nur eine Autoscheibe, aber das Setting bedeutet, okay,
wenn du dir das zutraust, dann sollten wir noch ein paar mehr Polizisten mal
durch Wohnungen schicken, um zu gucken, wer hat denn da jetzt noch Munition?
Das ist unglaublich.
Also es ist wirklich gruselig. Nun gut, aber Polizisten am Arsch am Mittwoch
mal ausgeklammert. Mir geht es um die Atomwaffen.
Und ich habe mich ja schon zu bekennen gegeben, geben als jeniger,
der einfach den flapsigen Spruch macht, mein Bizeps ist es nicht.
Putin wird mit Atomwaffen in Schach gehalten.
Und ich finde, auch wenn mir da irgendwie halbgare Argumentationen vorgeworfen
wird, wie auch immer, das Thema ist ja da, weil es gibt Atomwaffen.
Also allein, dass es Atomwaffen gibt, heißt, da müssen wir ernsthaft drüber
diskutieren und können nicht einfach ja gut, Stefan hat einen Spruch gemacht,
also mache ich auch einen oder
sowas, sondern nee, hier kann man ja mal ernsthaft drüber diskutieren.
Wer sollte in Deutschland diese Diskussion führen?
Ich würde sagen, der Verteidigungsminister, denn der ist einfach rein jobbeschreibungsmäßig am nächsten dran.
Und wir verfolgen jetzt mal, wie Pistorius, unser Kanzler der Herzen,
über dieses extrem wichtige Thema redet.
Unter so einer Maßgabe, dass wir immer relativ viel einpreisen,
was wir bisher schon diskutiert haben.
Trump, was bedeutet eigentlich Trump? Trump im Amt.
Ich kann mir kein Szenario vorstellen, in dem er nicht wiedergewählt wird.
Ich war ja damals sehr entschieden bei Joe Biden gewinnt das natürlich und er hat dann auch gewonnen.
Und jetzt sage ich, ich kann mir kein Szenario vorstellen, in dem der gebrechliche
Biden, der sich gerade von Netanyahu jede Unterstützung, die er braucht,
an der Heimatfront kurz und klein schießen lässt.
Was wir ja gestern bei Vorwahlen auch gesehen haben, dass die Leute zur Wahl
gehen und dann aber sagen, ich enthalte mich.
Ja, das ist.
Das ist wirklich crazy. Das ist. Im zweistelligen Prozentbereich.
Also das sind ganz deutliche Zeichen, dass hier.
Also dem fliegt jetzt der Nahostkonflikt um die Ohren.
Und muss das vielleicht ganz kurz erzählen, weil nicht alle wissen darum,
dass es also bei den US-Demokraten sehr viele gibt.
Es gibt auch Spitzenpolitiker, die die Linie von Biden im Nahostkonflikt ablehnen
und so weit gehen zu sagen, wir enthalten uns,
wenn also jetzt diese Vorwahlen stattfinden.
Und das sind Menschen, die zum Teil einen Nahost-Hintergrund haben, zum Teil aber nicht.
Also das ist sehr, sagen wir, divers zusammengesetzt. Und wenn sie darauf angesprochen
werden, ob sie nicht glauben,
dass das eine strategisch schlechte Sache sei, dass sie Biden damit so sehr
schwächen, dass sie Trump damit stärken, dann sagen sie, ja, dann ist das halt so.
Sie sind auch nicht für Trump, Sie wissen ja auch, wie Trump zum Nahostkonflikt
steht, der erscheint ja dann nicht als Friedensengel, wie wir wissen,
aber Sie sagen ja, das ist so ein Halbmal, was Biden da jetzt gerade tut,
deswegen machen wir das so.
Und das ist etwas, womit man jetzt vor drei Monaten noch gar nicht gerechnet
hat, dass sowas auch noch dazukommen kann jetzt zu Biden.
Genau, das Phänomen ist, dass ein Thema…,
Alle anderen Themen in der Kalkulation, wie man die eigene Wahlstimme vergibt, überwiegt.
So, und die New York Times hat ja im The Daily Podcast mit einer Frau gesprochen,
die einfach 1974, 75, als die ersten Siedlungsbewegungen losgingen und so weiter,
gesagt hat, nee, ich muss jetzt hier flüchten, das funktioniert so nicht.
Und die schöpfen dann große Hoffnungen mit Clinton in dieser Zeit und so weiter,
es gibt diese großen Abkommen. und es liegt alles in Trümmern und man ist so
in diesem Kalkül, ja, mit Trump wäre es auch nicht schlechter.
Wobei ich sagen würde, auch im Nahen Osten wäre es mit Trump noch sehr viel
schlechter, aber die sagen einfach, nee, das macht irgendwie,
ich kann das nicht mit gutem Gewissen machen.
Und zweitens, man muss verstehen, es ist hier keine Wählerwanderung nötig,
sondern allein, dass demokratische Wähler nicht zur Wahl gehen,
reicht völlig aus, um Donald Trump da ins Amt zu heben. Also so knapp ist es.
Es muss niemand zum zum Trump-Wähler werden, der es jetzt noch nicht ist.
Gut, also das alles eingepreist, dass es da schlimm steht, dass Trump gewählt
wird, dass wir wissen, wie sich Macron Deutschland gegenüber jetzt verhält,
wie wir ja so ein bisschen sagen,
verständlich, aufgrund dessen, was Macron die letzten Jahre klar auf den Tisch
gelegt hat, an Themen, die zu diskutieren sind.
Und jetzt unter dieser großen Gefahr, dass wir im November einfach mit nackten
Hosen, also runtergelassener Hose dastehen und sagen, achso,
Trump wurde wählt, krass.
Und wir sind eigentlich noch mehr überrascht als beim ersten Mal,
weil es diesmal auch sehr viel gefährlicher wird.
Ich meine, diesmal hat er nur, damals hat er nur einen Moslem-Ban gemacht und
ist aus dem Paris-Abkommen ausgetreten. Also das wird ja diesmal...
Das hat ja nicht viel verändert, dass er da aus dem Paris-Abkommen ausgetreten
ist und dann tritt man halt wieder ein.
Und wir hatten ja im Salon, ich glaube vor zwei Monaten, diesen Artikel aus
den Blättern, wie so eine Trump-Diktatur aussehen könnte. Also dass Trump natürlich
dabei ist, dann alles so zu restrukturieren, dass wir...
Vielleicht auch nicht nur diese eine Amtszeit Trump haben,
sondern dass er Möglichkeiten findet, das zu verlängern, dass er auch das Militär
und so weiter so umbauen wird, dass da immer weniger besonnene Köpfe wie ein
Mark Milley zu finden sind. All das wird da passieren.
Genau. Und dieser Text mit der Warnung kam von Robert Kagan,
also einer der Top Ten Strategen in der Bush-Administration.
Also sozusagen, der weiß, wovon er redet.
Gut, also Pistorius zum Thema, muss man sich hier auf irgendetwas vorbereiten?
Wir haben ja gerade gehört, wir sollen uns alle vorbereiten.
Wir müssen jetzt die Sirenen unterscheiden können und so weiter.
Pistorius, so muss man sich auf irgendwas vorbereiten?
Wir glauben an die NATO und auch an all das, was an Beistandsgarantien mit der NATO verbunden ist.
Das enthebt uns nicht der Aufgabe, immer wieder zu prüfen, ob wir richtig aufgestellt
sind und welche Entscheidungen wir für die Zukunft treffen müssen.
Diese Entscheidung diskutieren wir dann und teilen sie mit, wenn sie reif sind.
Also Hebestreit so, wir müssen ja gar nichts diskutieren, erst recht nicht öffentlich.
Geradezu gereizt reagiert auch Verteidigungsminister Boris Pistorius in Brüssel
auf die Frage, ob sich Deutschland nicht endlich einmal zum französischen Vorstoß verhalten müsse.
Ne, das müssen wir nicht, weil wir erst den amerikanischen Schutzschirm haben
und wir sollten ihn nicht von uns aus leichtfertig aufgeben oder infrage stellen,
dafür gibt es keinen Anlass.
Es gibt keinen Anlass, den Schutzschirm mit Amerika jetzt infrage zu stellen?
Ähm, und ja, das ist augenzudurch so ein bisschen. Und so geht's die ganze Zeit.
Pistorius will einfach nicht debattieren.
Unions-Fraktionsvize Johann Wadephul fordert den Kanzler dazu auf, für Klarheit zu sorgen.
Der Christdemokrat will wissen, ob auch Scholz über einen gemeinsamen europäischen
nuklearen Schutzschirm nachdenkt. Katharina Barley, die SPD-Spitzenkandidatin
für die Europawahl, hatte dazu angeregt, darüber zu diskutieren.
Ist das die Position der Bundesregierung, fragt Wadephul?
Die des Verteidigungsministers zumindest ist sie nicht.
Sozialdemokrat Boris Pistorius fährt seiner Parteifreundin Barley ziemlich in die Parade.
Ich halte nichts von aufgeregten Debatten zur Unzeit und erst recht nichts davon,
davon jedes Zitat aus dem amerikanischen Wahlkampf von jemandem,
der Kandidat werden will, auf die Goldwaage zu legen.
Und zu der Atomwaffendiskussion sage ich nur eins, das ist eine wirklich so
komplexe Diskussion, die man nicht mal eben lostreten sollte.
Also die Nukleardebatte brauchen wir jetzt aktuell wirklich als letztes.
Als hätte sich irgendein Bürgermeister in den USA zu Wort gemeldet.
Der ist ja noch nicht mal Kandidat. Ja, ja, ja.
Der will ja nur Kandidat werden. So, und Pistoles wird aber flankiert.
Und es ist ja auch völliger Unsinn, ich meine diese Debatte.
Braucht Europa eigene Atombomben oder muss man mit Frankreich ein besonderes
Abkommen haben, das ist ja nichts Neues, das ist ja,
seit Jahren immer wieder wird es aufgerufen und dann kommen genau diese Reaktionen
also wir wollen jetzt mal nicht, also das ist ein so komplexes Thema,
man fragt sich halt aber wann will man sich dann diesem komplexen Thema mal
stellen, naja man wird sich dem dann wohl stellen, also das ist die Strategie
wenn Trump es ist und Trump das rauszieht, dann wird man dann dann von jetzt
auf gleich irgendwas machen müssen, ja.
Ja, ich finde ja, wenn man Atomwaffen hat, muss man sie strategisch klug einsetzen.
Sie dienen nur zur Drohung,
Also das so dazu gesagt, was dann ist, nachdem man sie eingesetzt hat, ist was anderes.
Sie dienen nur zur Drohung und es macht überhaupt keinen Sinn, das runterzuspielen.
Ne, wir drohen jetzt nicht mit Atomwaffen. So, das ist doch bescheuert.
In Deutschland liegen ja Atomwaffen und die nukleare Teilhabe erlaubt es ja
auch, dass deutsche Piloten die ans Flugzeug schrauben und schon mal losfliegen,
auch wenn dann der konkrete Befehl und so weiter so ein bisschen unklar gelassen wird.
Nur, ich würde jetzt nicht mal nur einpreisen, dass Donald Trump gewählt wird
und damit perspektivisch so ein Atomwaffenschutzschirm über Deutschland ausfällt
und man dann, wenn irgendwas passiert,
die Franzosen oder die Briten fragt, ich finde das sowieso, das ist ja völlig verquere Diskussion,
Europa hat Atomwaffen, es sind NATO-Länder,
wenn Amerika da ausfällt, weil sie aus der NATO austreten, bleiben immer noch
Atommächte in der NATO zurück und wenn NATO-Gebiet angegriffen wird,
wird, steht auch im Raume Atomwaffen einsetzen. Von wo die dann losfliegen und so.
Das ist doch völlig, also da sagt er auch, das ist ein Megakomplexer und so.
Da würde ich sagen, ne, das ist nicht besonders megakomplex.
Das kann man alles mit Zettel und Stift im kleinen Gespräch unter Staatschefs
klären, wie die jetzt dann, wer hier wie geschützt wird.
Nur ich würde halt sagen, unter dem Aspekt, wozu dienen Atomwaffen,
gilt es jetzt nicht nur, sich darauf vorzubereiten, dass Donald Trump Präsident
wird, sondern auch, dass Russland Atomwaffen einsetzen.
So, und das wird ja hier erst recht völlig ausgeblendet.
Also ich würde sagen, nee, hier kann man mal so eine Diskussion,
und zwar allein, weil es Atomwaffen gibt und wir wissen, wie mächtig sie sind, alles einpreist.
Es muss ja von mir aus keine öffentliche Diskussion sein, aber ich will dann
auch allenfalls ein, dazu äußern wir uns nicht hören.
Und kein so ein, ach, Katharina Barley aus meiner Partei hat so einen Quatsch
erzählt, nee, die spinnt ja.
Also das zeigt nur wieder, dass einfach hier das Gefüge nicht stimmt.
Und dann kommt hinzu, wenn Robin Alexander die Boomer Gang ausflaggt, Mütze nicht.
Ist weltweit aktiv. Europa ist für die USA ein durchaus wichtiger Kontinent,
wenn sie nach Afrika blickt, wenn sie in den Nahen Osten blickt.
Und so einfach wird auch ein amerikanischer Präsident nicht strukturelle Bedingungen
für Weltmächte über den Haufen werfen.
Ja, oder doch. Oder doch einfach. Warum ist er sich da so sicher?
Ich verstehe sowas nicht.
Also es klingt logisch, was er sagt, aber da das nicht unbedingt die Kategorie
ist, nach der Weltpolitik gestaltet wird.
Ist das jetzt so eine Sache? Das kann man so sehen und das ist sicherlich sinnvoll
und dass Europa und Amerika in dieser Weise miteinander verbunden sind, wie sie es sind,
hat genau diese Gründe, die er da ausgeführt hat. Zugleich geht es aber auch anders.
Ja, also das Szenario, Trump gewinnt eine zweite Amtszeit direkt,
verspricht Putin, ja, ja, mein Plan ist aus der NATO auszusteigen,
Putin wartet das noch ab und greift dann die Ukraine an und weiß,
die Europäer stehen gerade mit nichts da.
Man würde ja auch nicht bei Putin sagen, das war vernünftig,
dass er die Ukraine angegriffen hat, ja.
Schlimmer noch, Putin hat es sogar gemacht, obwohl Trump nicht gewählt wurde,
die NATO Amerika nicht verloren hat und ein demokratischer Präsident im Amt
saß. Trotzdem hat Putin das gemacht.
Also ich würde mir bei der Frage, was passiert, wenn Trump gewählt wird,
gar nichts ausschließen von europäischer Seite.
So, mir übrigens mal gerade, wo du das nochmal jetzt angesprochen hast mit Putin,
hat das alles trotzdem gemacht.
Wir haben ja dieses Interview mit Tucker Carlson auch gehabt in diesem Monat.
Du hast es dir ja ganz angesehen.
Nee, ich hab's mir nicht ganz angesehen. Hans hat sich's ganz angesehen im Aufwachen-Podcast.
Und ich hab mir gedacht, okay, ich hab gelesen, 27 Minuten historischen Einstieg.
Man kann sich das im Detail verfolgen. Ich würde aber nachher bei,
wenn wir kurz über Nawalny sprechen, ein anderes Argument machen.
Ich würde nur mal einschieben wollen, man erfährt dort selbstverständlich jetzt
nicht etwas, das nochmal eine vollkommen neue Sicht auf die Dinge einem ermöglicht.
Was ich eher interessant fand, war, dass er diesen extrem langen historischen
Einstieg gewählt hat, weil man sich ja immer fragen muss, warum macht er das?
Also dahinter steckt eine Strategie. Jetzt kann ich sagen, er ist verrückt,
deswegen macht er das, den Eindruck machte er mir nicht.
Was es aber sein kann ist, dass er ja weiß,
welches Publikum er damit adressiert und er adressiert ja damit schon auch sehr
stark mit Tucker Carlson dann ein US-republikanisches Publikum,
generell ein rechtes Publikum und das haben wir ja schon jetzt lange beobachten können,
dass es zwar diesen kurzen TikTok-Populismus gibt, ja.
Ja, alle ich weide, geht viral mit irgendwas, aber zugleich gibt es ja auch
in dem Bereich Verschwörungstheorie das.
Lange Format, ja, dass man dort nochmal stundenlang erklärt,
warum Russland eigentlich so und
so ist und wie die Grenzen eigentlich verliehen und wie das nochmal war.
Also, dass man so alternative Fiktionen macht, die dann so ein Körnchen Wahrheit
enthalten können oder auch nicht.
Und das ist ja interessant, dass das so ein neuer Entertainment-Faktor geworden
ist, dass also man auch das kann man ja auch gut dann so nachvollziehen, was Bill Gates so macht,
ja und dann geht das immer weiter mit den Impfungen und noch eine Erklärung
und noch eine und man kann sich ja, wenn man so möchte,
kann man das jeden Abend konsumieren. Fanfiction.
Geht immer wieder weiter als Fanfiction und ich glaube, dass das so ein Angebot
ist, dass man sagt, ich führe das jetzt mal hier alles aus und gucke nochmal
in die alten Karten rein und Und ihr könnt das aber auch tun.
Und das ist so eine, wir bauen uns so eine alte, oder man sagt,
wir bauen uns so eine retromanische Welt auf.
Und das ist sehr stark davon geprägt. Was mich an der Diskussion um dieses Interview
so irritiert hat, war, dass man so tat,
weil Tucker Carlson Verschwörungstheorien und alles verbreitet,
man einfach sich darüber hinwegsetzen kann über das Interview,
wir brauchen das gar nicht, wir können es ignorieren oder irgendetwas.
Wo ich sage, nee, das ist doch dann als Dokument reicht das doch nicht.
Ich muss doch nur wissen, dass Tucker Carlson kein linker Investigativjournalist ist.
Das reicht doch eigentlich als Info, dass ich hier jetzt diese beiden da erlebe.
Und dann muss ich dann nicht nochmal hundertmal Warnungen und alles dazu gesagt bekommen,
sondern, also wenn man das nicht mehr so mitbekommt, dann ist man sowieso nicht
aufgeklärt genug, um an der Demokratie teilzunehmen, da müssen wir uns ganz
andere Sorgen machen und ich würde auch mal bitte davon abraten,
dass man immer bei so Leuten wie Tucker Carlson sagt,
der selbst ernannte Journalist, es wird niemand zum Journalismus ernannt, das ist.
Journalist ist kein Kein Ausbildungsberuf in dem Sinne, sondern man kann Redakteur
bei einer Zeitung werden, da macht man Volontariat.
Aber es gibt nicht irgendetwas, dass man sagt, so ab sofort dürfen sie operieren, wie bei einem Arzt.
Oder ab sofort haben sie das zweite Staatsexamen, jetzt können sie Richter werden.
Das gibt es aus guten Gründen beim Journalismus nicht.
Wenn wir das staatlich zertifizieren, du bist Journalist und du bist keiner,
dann haben wir quasi eine Zensur schon mit dabei.
Einprogrammiert in das Ganze. Das heißt, dieser Wahn immer von dem selbsternannten,
auch intellektuellen oder sowas hört man ja dann bei anderen Leuten,
wenn man irgendjemanden, ich mag mal der selbsternannte Intellektuelle,
jetzt zum Intellektuellen wird niemand ernannt, sondern das Publikum entscheidet
sich, jemanden als intellektuelle Instanz anzuerkennen oder nicht.
Genauso auch bei Journalisten, den einen findet man aus Gründen seriöser,
den anderen nicht und dann wird man das auch mit Fakten unterlegen können und ja,
es gibt einen Unterschied zwischen einem Spiegeljournalisten und Tucker Carlson,
definitiv, aber das ist die Frage,
die das Publikum und der aufgeklärte Bürger behandeln muss.
Deswegen ist das so ein Irrsinn zu sagen, ja selbst ernannt.
Ja, ich bin ja ehrlich gesagt, um hier mal interne Kritik öffentlich zu machen,
aber ich bin ja aus allen Wolken gefallen, als ich wirklich im Aufwachen-Podcast
den Joke machte, 17, 20, 25 Mal zu sagen, Tucker Carlson ist kein Journalist.
Bis alle im Chat genervt waren davon, dass ich sage, Tucker Carlson ist ja kein Journalist.
Und dann ergreift Hans das Wort und sagt, also Tucker Carlson ist ja kein Journalist.
Und ich dachte, ja genau, die Pointe ist damit gemacht. Es ist einfach jetzt ein Reichweitenspiel.
Wir haben gerade extrem viele Texte, Micky Beisenherz im Stern,
Lars Weißbrot in der Zeit, die alle mit dem gleichen Tenor kommen und die Überschriften
lauten so ungefähr das Ende von Social Media.
Und ich würde sagen, nee.
Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, diese beiden sind jetzt irgendwie im Sinne von,
aber sie sind etablierte Medienhäuser, in denen sie schreiben. Stern und Zeit.
Wenn dort ausgerufen wird, es ist das Ende von Social Media,
ist das diese letzte Aufbäumung, wo dann so Paradoxien greifen,
bevor die Sinuskurve kippt und man das Vorzeichen umdreht.
Und meine Einschätzung der Sachlage ist gerade, es ist jetzt das Ende,
also jetzt ist wirklich Redaktionsschluss.
Es hat sich noch ein bisschen länger geschleppt, als ich dachte, dass sie durchhalten.
Aber jetzt ist wirklich Redaktionsschluss. Den Leuten ist egal,
ob Taka Carlson ein Journalist ist.
Und ehrlicherweise den Journalisten selbst ist es egal.
Sie lagen uns Jahre jetzt im Ohr und meinten.
Putin ist doch nicht schwer zu verstehen. Habt ihr nicht die Rede von 2008 gehört,
die er da vor seinen Generälen gehalten hat?
Und man denkt so, nee, hab ich nicht gehört, ist die wichtig?
Ja, das ist die wichtigste Rede überhaupt.
Da lag doch vor zehn Jahren schon alles deutlich klar. da.
So, und jetzt kommen die Journalisten und sagen, ach, dieses zwei Stunden lange
Gespräch vor der Weltöffentlichkeit, das kannst du ignorieren.
Tagesschau.de kommentiert so, einfach ignorieren. Und ich denke,
nee, das passt jetzt alles nicht mehr.
Das ist nicht mehr, ihr verschmerzt gerade oder versucht es zu verarbeiten,
dass da so eine Deutungshoheit verloren geht.
Ich kann das sehr gut nachvollziehen, wenn man einen Tweet aufruft und unter
diesem Video steht, 200 Millionen Aufrufe, ist man eingeschüchtert.
Weil man genau weiß, wenn es gut läuft, liest mein Mein Kommentar dazu,
keine Ahnung, 17.000 Leute oder so. Diesmal kurz anklicken.
Das ist aber ein Text. Wie weit lesen die wirklich?
Reinerweise ist so ein Interview, da weiß man einfach, das muss man nicht selber
hören, sondern das wird in allen Podcasts breitgewalzt und so weiter.
Die Nachricht dringt durch.
So, und dann kann man sich ja überlegen, okay, Putin hat da jetzt 27 Minuten
sein Geschichtsbild dargelegt.
Muss man sich da jetzt rein nerden?
Also muss man dem jetzt zum Opfer fallen?
Oder, auf einem Podcast war ich dann ein bisschen sehr deutlich,
hab gesagt, Geschichte ist egal. Wir denken jetzt mal nach vorne,
so frei nach Alfred Adler.
Und ich will mal diesen einen Clip, man hört es nur so durch die Blume.
Aber The Daily hat eine russische Gesprächspartnerin, die mal interessant erzählt zu Nawalny.
Und wir hören einfach mal so zu, es ist jetzt Englisch, noch so ein bisschen
russischer Einschlag und so weiter.
Aber wir versuchen mal, den einen Punkt, von dem ich denke, das ist Nawalny
gefährlich geworden, rauszuhören.
Und er hat mir in einem seiner Schriften geschrieben, ich weiß,
dass ich in der Gefängnis sitzen werde, so lange Putin noch lebt. Er wusste das.
Es ist sehr schwierig, in jemand anderes' Kopf zu kommen.
Aber ich denke, er fühlte sich verletzt.
Um Putin oder jemand anderes schmerzen zu lassen.
Er hatte den Sinn der Mission, er war eine gute Waffe am Rennen.
Und er hatte alle Intentionen, diese Waffe zu gewinnen.
Und wenn du denkst, dass du getötet wirst oder dich startest zu schmerzen,
weißt du, er hat mir gesagt, stopp mit dem Verletzen, alles ist in Ordnung.
Es ist nur ein historischer Prozess. Russia is going through this historical
process and we are going along with it.
Everything is going to be okay. And even if everything is not going to be okay,
we can console ourselves.
We will get consolation in the fact of having lived honest lives, of being honest people.
So, ich reformuliere mal. Putin sitzt bei Tucker Carlson und stellt sich selber,
in die Protagonistenreihe der letzten 1000 Jahre russischer Gesellschaft und
Geschichte und sagt, ich ziehe doch nur die Linien wieder gerade,
Russland war immer groß,
dann kam irgendwie Jelzin, keine Ahnung, der Mauerfall und der ganze Kram und
ich bin dran, das wieder zu reparieren.
Und dem gegenüber, und da muss man sich mit diesen Details, die Putin da irgendwie
als Argumente dieser These nicht befassen.
Dem gegenüber steht Nawalny, der sagt, liebe Landsleute, habt keine Angst, haltet durch.
Unsere Angst ist sozusagen das einzige Asset, was sie haben.
Mir ist es selber peinlich, ängstlich zu sein und so weiter.
Ich gehe natürlich nach Russland. Und sein Argument ist, nicht Putin ist der
Protagonist, der die große historische Linie vorzieht, sondern Russland hat
eine große historische Linie und Putin ist der Ausnahmefall.
Und wir müssen jetzt Putin überdauern, überwintern und danach machen wir weiter
mit unserer großen russischen Geschichte. Und das wollte Putin nicht auf sich setzen lassen.
Deswegen diese astronomische Wut und auch, das ist auch die einzige Klammer,
die es mir verständlich macht, zu sagen,
okay, Putin sitzt irgendwie im Fernsehen, gibt sich so ganz hamtsam und macht
so ein, ja, ist doch nur die große Historie und wir wollen das nirgendwo einmischen,
ihr müsst einfach nur verstehen,
wir ziehen halt hier so eine völlig Selbstverständlichkeit, so eine historische
Selbstverständlichkeit ziehen wir einfach gerade und ja, da fallen dann so ein
paar Länder zum Opfer und so, pipapo, eigentlich bin ich ja gesprächsbereit.
So, und auf der anderen Seite, die Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz einfach in
die Luft zu sprengen damit.
Eröffnung, naja, ich setze das Thema, Nawalny ist tot. Vielleicht sogar unter
dieser Maßgabe, ich gucke mal noch bei den Deutschen, ich mache denen so ein
Angebot, kriege ich meinen Tiergartenmörder dafür, dass ihr Nawalny kriegt.
Die Deutschen zeigen so, ja, wir sind verhandlungsbereit und Putin,
ach ja, zack, ich zerschieße euch den ganzen Plan und stelle euch noch bloß
und so. All diese Sachen.
Und da, finde ich, ist dieses, was wir auch vorhin gehört haben von Hofreiter,
ja, Putin möchte ja noch das erleben, der ist kein Selbstmörder.
Ja, Putin hat gerade gesehen, er kämpft gegen Selbstmörder. Er kämpft gegen
Menschen, die so sehr davon überzeugt sind und das als Botschaft in die Welt
tragen, dass Putin der Ausnahmefall ist.
Sozusagen die Krankheit innerhalb der russischen Geschichte,
die man jetzt ausmerzen und heilen muss, von der man sich erholen muss.
Wir müssen es nur gemeinsam durchstehen und so. Also, dass da wirklich jemand jetzt gesagt hat,
ich opfere mich für diese russische Idee, das kann Putin nie wieder einfangen,
wenn man es jetzt so entsprechend darstellt, ja, für was ist Nawalny eigentlich
sehenden Auges gestorben.
So, und auf dieser Ebene haben wir es jetzt mit.
Was aber nicht bedeutet, dass Putin nicht auch dazu bereit wäre,
das gegen Zug auch zu tun.
Also er muss es nicht, weil er in einer mächtigeren Position ist,
aber er ist jemand, der vielleicht auch zu Opfern bereit wäre,
bei denen wir verblüfft wären.
Ja, aber es ist zum Glück noch nicht sein eigenes Leben, was bedeutet,
dadurch bleibt es bei Atomwaffen als Droh.
Ja, genau. So kann man hoffen.
Es wäre auch ein Tenet-Szenario denkbar.
Genau, man kann nicht grundsätzlich darauf bauen.
Also wir erinnern uns an Tenet, der Bösewicht hat so ein Puls-Dings am Arm und
sobald das anzeigt, null Pulsschläger, der Protagonist ist tot,
weil die ganze Welt zerstört.
So, ja, wer sagt uns, dass Putin da nicht irgendwelche Vorkehrungen getroffen hat?
Naja, das ist jedenfalls die Herausforderung, mit der sich, dass jetzt Trump
gewählt wird, ist ja sozusagen nur peripher von Bedeutung, dass wir dann sowas,
wie wir in Putin gerade erleben, schutzlos gegenüberstehen.
Also lassen wir uns noch ein bisschen schockieren hier davon,
wie sehr uns Gottkanzler, der bessere erste Staatsmann Pistorius,
eigentlich komplett in den Rücken fällt, was das angeht, hier im Gespräch mit Ingo Zamperoni.
Wie entsetzt waren sie, als sie die Worte von Donald Trump gehört haben,
wer nicht genügend zahle in der NATO, der könne nicht mit dem Schutz der USA
rechnen, im Gegenteil, mit dem solle Russland machen, was es wolle.
Naja, überrascht war ich jedenfalls nicht. Wir kennen solche Töne und wir müssen
sie einerseits zur Kenntnis nehmen, aber andererseits uns davon auch nicht beirren
lassen in dem, was wir in Europa zu tun haben.
Und was ist das, was wir in Europa zu tun haben?
Unsere Hausaufgaben, was unsere Verteidigung angeht, was wir in den letzten
zehn Jahren zum Teil schon hätten machen können und müssen, aber nicht gemacht haben.
Das ist nicht auf Augenhöhe.
Das sind also die Hausaufgaben. Wir machen unsere Hausaufgaben.
Die Hausaufgaben sind, sich mit Frankreich aussöhnen, Polen in unserem Reigen
zu begrüßen, eine große Feierstunde draus zu machen, die zivile Heimatfrontkräfte
zu stärken und so weiter und so fort.
Und stattdessen ist alles gar kein Problem und hier droht auch nichts.
Und wie er Trump konkret bezeichnet.
Das sind wichtige Signale, auch in Richtung unserer amerikanischen Alliierten in der NATO.
Das sind die Signale, auf das es jetzt ankommt, auf Gelassenheit,
die Dinge zu tun, die zu tun sind, aber sich nicht ins Boxhorn jagen lassen
von solchen Aussagen des möglicherweise künftigen republikanischen Präsidentschaftskandidaten.
Sind wir jetzt wieder im Jahr 2015, wo man sagt, der Reality-Star will Präsident werden?
Trump steht gerade nicht mit 16 anderen Republikanern auf der Bühne und die
Welt ist sich einig, der Idiot wird es nicht, sondern Trump ist der Einzige auf der Bühne.
Und sein Kontrahent ist, wenn überhaupt nur noch zwischenparteilich,
der ist der gebrechlichste Mann der Welt.
Also wovon redet er?
Das habe ich ja im Übrigen bis heute nicht verstanden, wie das sein kann,
dass Biden nicht von seinen eigenen Leuten, also wir wissen ja,
wie vermachtet diese Strukturen sind und all das, also dass man es offenbar
doch schaffen kann, wenn man einmal Präsident ist,
dass man dann alle, die eine zweite Regentschaft verhindern können,
dass man die alle hinter sich lässt.
Ist wahrscheinlich auch ohne auf die eigene Frau zu hören oder ich weiß es nicht,
weil doch jeder dem jetzt, also wenn man jetzt den US-Demokraten auch mal Patriotismus
unterstellt, dann dürfte ihnen ja klar sein, dass das keine gute Idee ist.
Wir wissen jetzt nicht, wie es ausgeht, aber es ist keine gute Idee,
mit Biden nochmal anzutreten und dass man da nicht versucht hat,
im Verbund irgendwas aufzubauen.
Wahrscheinlich nicht mit Kamala Harris zu farblos, aber eher mit Blinken.
Oder Gavin Newsom. Oder man zieht jemand aus dem Hut, wegen wer dann,
Michelle Obama macht man dann so einen großen, wer, wer ist.
Ja, die kann sich leider nicht durchringen.
Die ist.
Die ist Celebrity, aber sie will nicht.
Die hat keinen Bock, aber Gavin Newsom hat Bock.
Naja. Und wollte sich aber nicht ins Beicht. Also jedenfalls,
es wären ja Leute da gewesen, das Land ist groß, die demokratische Partei ist riesig.
Woran lag es, also das wird schon noch ein Rätsel sein, wie das funktionieren konnte, oder?
Ja, genau. Also jetzt, wo wir es kurz ansprechen. Liebe Hörer,
seid bitte ganz präzise, wenn ihr mit anderen Leuten darüber redet.
Es ist nicht das Alter das Problem. Es ist die Gebrechlichkeit.
Es ist die Gebrechlichkeit. Man sieht Leute im Fernsehen und hat einen physischen
Mitvollzug von dem, was man da sieht.
Also wenn jemand sehr hoch sinkt, kriegt man durchaus so ein bisschen Kieferdruck.
Wenn sich jemand ekelt, deswegen gucken wir, also ich gucke es nicht,
aber hier Dschungelcamp und so.
Die Leute wollen das sehen, weil sie sich so mit ekeln. Sie können es nicht
ganz abstreifen, aber sie wissen auch, es bleibt im Fernsehen.
Aber es gibt einen körperlichen Mitvollzug.
So, Hollywoodfilme, ja wenn man weiß, das hat ein Drehbuchautor geschrieben
und man ist trotzdem emotional angefasst davon.
Und das war ja bei Indiana Jones jetzt dem letzten Teil so interessant,
genau diesen Mitvollzug hatte man im Kino.
Die haben zwar mit AI und allem möglichem probiert, einen jungen Harrison Ford
zu machen, man sieht dann aber Harrison Ford und er macht so drei Schritte und
man sieht einen 80-jährigen drei Schritte tun,
dann springt er auf ein Pferd rauf und dann weiß ich, ja okay,
das hat man programmiert, weil er natürlich nicht darauf springen kann.
Und ich sehe aber in diesen drei Schritten, die er tut, naja,
ich gehe jetzt hier gerade mit dem schon etwas gebrechlichen Mann mit und der
ist natürlich noch zehnmal fitter als bei.
Genau. Und das kriegt man, also diesen Kampf gegen die…,
Im tiefsten menschlichen Intuitionen kriegt man nicht rausgewahlkampft.
Da steht ein gesprächlicher Mann auf der Bühne und man hat Mitleid,
man weiß, der sollte seine Zeit lieber anders verbringen. Der wird so nicht gewinnen.
Und was er dann auch sagt und alles vertauscht.
Es geht ja darum.
Wir haben es schon hundertmal gesagt, um Repräsentation und Repräsentation ist
Schauspiel und er kann nicht mehr ein gutes Schauspiel machen,
wie man auch für irgendeine Rolle,
man hat ja ein Spielalter, wenn man jetzt in einer Castingagentur Schauspiel
ist, hat man ein Spielalter und dann sieht man ja manchmal in so deutschen Teenie-Komödien,
dass dann 27-Jährige, 14-Jährige spielen und denken, das passt irgendwie nicht.
Was machen die da?
Ja und das Spielalter ist nicht das mehr, wo das mit einem Präsidenten geht.
Der kann den Vater eines Präsidenten gut spielen.
Ja und nichts, da ist kein Mittel gewachsen.
Du kannst nicht kommen wie, keine Ahnung wer das gesagt hat,
aber irgendwer kam so mit, ja Biden hat eine gute Blutbank, die jungen Leute halt im Stab oder so.
Sondern nein, also in Amerika ist wirklich alles auf diesen,
der amerikanische Präsident ist die Ersatzfigur für den, wir haben ihn uns erkämpft, unser König.
Es ist nicht mehr der britische, wir haben jetzt den amerikanischen.
Es läuft alles auf ihn zu.
Es ist einfach, aus dieser Sachlage kommt man einfach nicht raus.
Und das Einzige, was da im Weg steht, ist diese Vermachtung, wie du es genannt hast.
Der amerikanische Präsident kann darüber selbst entscheiden,
ob er nochmal antritt und die Partei wird einen Teufel tun, dagegen anzugehen,
weil das sind die Bruchlinien, auf die die Wähler reagieren.
Jetzt ist nur Biden gebrechlich. Wenn Biden abtritt, ist die ganze Partei gebrechlich.
Es gibt zum Beispiel für den nach der Convention, bei der Biden,
der als Präsidentschaftskandidat ausgerufen wird und dann passiert ihm was.
Gibt es in der amerikanischen Geschichte mit inzwischen hunderten Präsidenten kein ...
Vorbild. Das gab es noch nie. Also wir sind hier in völlig unbekannten Gebiet.
Also es ist wirklich, was das angeht, sehr schlimm. Wir müssen uns also darauf
vorbereiten, dass Trump gewählt wird.
Wir haben eigentlich Erfahrung damit, dass Trump gewählt wird.
Pistorius so, naja, ich versuch's mal hier mit 90er-Jahre- Vernunft.
Der ist völlig aus der Zeit gefallen.
Mir jagt das keinen besonderen Schrecken ein, ehrlich gesagt,
weil ich mir ziemlich sicher bin, dass die Mehrzahl der Verantwortlichen in
den Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika Amerika sehr genau wissen,
was sie an ihren transatlantischen Partnern in Europa haben,
was sie an der NATO haben und dort wissen viele, was es bedeutet,
die transatlantischen Bänder zu zerschneiden oder zu überdehnen.
Wer das tut, der gefährdet eigene geopolitische und strategische Interessen
und am Ende sägt er den Ast ab, auf dem er sitzt.
Also ich muss wirklich sagen, das sind Äußerungen, die man zur Kenntnis nehmen muss.
Wir müssen einfach bei uns bleiben und nicht wie das Kaninchen auf die Schlange starren.
So, jetzt nur mal kurz und ich glaube, man braucht hier gar keine großen Argumente.
Jeder versteht das. Man fühlt das eigentlich, wie Unrecht er hat.
Donald Trump ist noch nicht Präsident, noch nicht mal Kandidat des Zuständniskommers.
Er macht nur so einen Halbsatz auf einer Bühne und ganz Europa ist in Aufruhr.
Der deutsche Journalismus möchte mit Pistorius darüber reden. So wichtig ist das.
Was glauben wir denn, was passiert, wenn er das wirklich in der Präsidentenrolle macht?
Hilft uns dann nicht mehr ein Gespräch mit dem deutschen Verteidigungsminister,
sondern da muss dann echt gehandelt werden.
Und diese Idee von naja, es wird schon genug geben, die wissen,
was sie an den europäischen Freunden haben.
Ja, aber die Entscheidung wird nun mal top down getroffen. Wenn der amerikanische
Präsident aus der NATO austreten will, macht er eine Unterschrift und fertig ist.
Dass das danach organisatorische Turbulenzen hat, ja, das hat Trump noch nie
gestört, sowas. Dass man das ja auch noch organisieren muss und so.
Sondern dann heißt es erstmal, mal Puste gucken. Und das sind dann die Lücken,
in denen jemand wie Putin oder so denkt, oh hier sind Handlungsspielräume.
Welche weiß ich nicht? Ich teste mal. So wäre er jetzt auch getestet.
Also was er nicht meint, Putin wirft dann einfach mal eine Atombombe auf uns
ab, aber sagt, naja, da gibt's noch so ein paar andere Regionen,
die gehören ja seit 1737 zu Russland, die müssen wir jetzt auch nochmal zurückholen.
Also wir sollen ja alle zu Preppern gemacht werden.
Die Signalliste der Sirenen auswendig lernen, die Heimatfront muss gestärkt
werden, wir müssen alle an die Front und
auf alles verzichten und er als Verantwortlicher so, nö, ist irgendwas?
Nein, kann doch mal alles ganz ruhig und so. Und so geht es nach und nach.
Ich wiederhole mich gerne dazu. Auch hier ist Gelassenheit gefordert.
Es gibt jetzt keinen Grund, über den Atom, über den nuklearen Schutzschirm zu diskutieren.
Viele europäische NATO-Staaten haben sich dazu bekannt, auch zu dessen Fortführung.
Wir haben zur Gewährleistung unseres Anteils daran an der nuklearen Teilhabe
die F-35 bestellt als Nachfolge des Tornados.
Wir sind auf gutem Wege und es macht jetzt überhaupt keinen Sinn,
öffentliche Diskussionen darüber zu führen. Das ist letztlich nur Munition oder
Treibstoff für den amerikanischen Wahlkampf und nützt niemandem.
Er sagt immerhin, öffentliche Diskussionen gibt es dann.
Internen Diskussionen, man weiß es nicht. Zwischen den Zeilen mal,
zum Glück gibt es noch interne Kommunikation. Aber wir wissen,
wie die intern mit Frankreich und so weiter ablaufen.
Super bestimmt.
Zum Ende dieses Gesprächs hier, keine Ahnung, er denkt sich dann so,
okay, ein bisschen Alarmismus sollte jetzt schon sein, ich mache es mal möglichst diffus oder so.
Denken Sie, angesichts dieser aktuellen Lage nicht auch manchmal diese Zeiten
einer Aufrüstung und auch Abschreckungsspirale wie im tiefsten Kalten Krieg
eigentlich, die müssten noch längst vorbei sein oder war naiv, wer so dachte?
Ich weiß nicht, ob naiv war, wer so dachte. Ich glaube, wir haben alle gedacht,
dass diese Zeiten vorbei sind, haben darauf gehofft und haben darin gelebt.
Jetzt wachen wir auf, jetzt erleben wir, dass das nicht so ist.
Und zwar, und das muss man so deutlich sagen,
weil es einem Mann an der Spitze eines Staates wie Russland einfällt,
seine Grenzen zu verschieben, einen souveränen Staat anzugreifen und den Anspruch
zu erheben, er gehört zu seinem Territorium, gleichzeitig Ausführungen dazu machen,
dass er das alte Russland in den Grenzen der Sowjetunion wieder will.
Das sind Situationen, die hat niemand, jedenfalls viele nicht,
der kommen sehen und darauf müssen wir uns jetzt einstellen und ja,
ich wünschte mir auch, es gäbe keine Notwendigkeit für Deterrence und Defense,
also Abschreckung und Verteidigung, aber jetzt scheint es wieder so zu sein,
dass wir das dringend tun müssen, um uns zu schützen und die Art zu leben zu gewährleisten.
Also ich bin verwirrt. Müssen wir das jetzt dringend tun oder sollten wir jetzt
doch den Ball flach halten?
Er ist ja wirklich der bessere Scholz, dem er sagt, nee, nee,
nee, alles, gar kein Problem, das kriegen wir alles geregelt und so.
Und dann passiert irgendwas.
Ja, wie ich schon sagte, wie ich vor drei Jahren schon sagte,
ich bin drauf vorbereitet und ich kannte mich, das ist genau so.
Ja, ich habe das alles eingepreist.
Also wenn ihr sagt, wir sind aufgewacht, dann bedeutet das ja,
man hat zuvor geschlafen.
Ist er aufgewacht? Ich habe das eben so anders gehört, als er da und so.
Nun gut, Häuschen. Wir haben ihn ja häufiger thematisiert. Wenn Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz
ist, hören wir natürlich kurz zu. Zum einen Häuschen auf der Bühne.
Irgendwo hier soll sie sein. Hier, auch auf den Gängen, in den vielen Gesprächen
soll sie entstehen, wachsen.
Die Hoffnung, dass es doch eine bessere Welt geben kann. Auch wenn sie zurzeit aus den Fugen scheint.
Der Chef der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz beschreibt das in seiner Auftaktrede so.
Irgendwo ist immer ein Silberstreifen am Horizont. Wir wissen nur noch nicht wo.
Für diese Konferenz haben wir alle unsere Moderatoren gebeten,
in ihren Diskussionen nach diesem Silberstreifen zu suchen.
So, der Silberstreif. Ich finde das irgendwie interessant. Er ist ein Diplomat.
Befehle ich keine Armeen oder Sonstiges, er ist ein Diplomat.
So, und er führt jetzt hier insbesondere noch nach seiner Beamtenlaufbahn als
Diplomat so eine Konferenz, wo auch nur getalkt wird im Grunde.
Und jetzt ist ja die Frage, wenn so Typen wie der Gerhard da sagen, ja, Brinkmanship.
In dem Moment, wo alle Waffenstrotzen sich gegenüberstehen, geht der Diplomat
rein und sagt, ah ja, scheint gerade beste Voraussetzung für eine Verhandlung zu sein.
So und das dann zu machen, unabhängig davon, wer hier was hochkocht oder abkühlen
will, wie Pistorius oder wie auch immer, das finde ich eigentlich,
eigentlich sollte man jetzt mal so ein großes Föltorstück, das auch sehr beruhigend
wirken kann, die Stunde der Diplomaten, gerade mit dieser Paradoxie,
sie glauben überall sind Waffen gestreckt, ja genau,
aber genau deswegen ist ja, das kann man auch historisch aufzeigen,
Ein guter Zeitpunkt jetzt mal zu sagen, ja vielleicht liegt uns doch noch was an unserem Leben.
Irgendwie so in die Richtung. Und Heusgen wird dann auch gefragt im Gespräch
im Fernsehen, kurz nach der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz am 18.
Ich will gerade eine Sache noch dazu sagen, weil dann uns manchmal vorgeworfen
wird, dass wir sagen, naja, aber was soll ein Kompromiss sein?
Man kann doch keinen Kompromiss schließen mit dem und dem und dem.
Also ob das jetzt beim Nordkrieg ist oder bei Ukraine oder auch anderen Konfliktenkriegen,
die da sind oder bevorstehen.
Dazu ist zu sagen, schaut euch die Weltkarte an.
Markiert die Länder, in denen die Menschenrechte eingehalten werden,
die demokratisch sind, Pressefreiheit haben und all das.
Und dann kann man ja mal vergleichen, wie viele Länder dann unmarkiert bleiben.
Und dann kann ich sagen, ich wünsche mir das anders. Und der universalistische
Standpunkt, den haben wir im Prinzip jetzt eben gerade gehört von Christina
Luntz, wie man vielleicht dahin kommen kann.
Alles andere bedeutet aber tatsächlich, dass man mit dem, was gegeben ist,
in irgendeiner Weise umgehen muss.
Und das tut Deutschland, das tut die EU laufend mit ganz, ganz vielen Ländern.
Wie gesagt, wenn Indien auf dem Podium sitzt, ist das eine wunderbare vorbildliche Demokratie.
Da übertreibt man es dann wieder voll in diese Richtung, statt da auch mal ein
paar Punkte zu setzen, wo das nicht so gerade läuft.
Ja, also wir haben gerade eine russische Wirtschaft, die zum einen Kriegswirtschaft
ist und damit das BIP nach oben treibt, zum anderen aber auch tatsächlich sehr
erfolgreich exportieren kann,
mit China sehr viel besseren Handel betreibt, das war ja mal sehr abgekühlt
und im Übrigen diese ganze Söldnergeschichte, die wir da erleben,
aus den armen Regionen werden die Männer an der Front verheizt. Ja, das stimmt.
Zugleich aber verdienen diese Männer, die dort jetzt für Russland im Krieg sind.
Vier oder fünfmal so viel, als sie sonst verdienen würden.
Das heißt, das Geld geben sie auch gar nicht an den Front aus.
Das fließt zurück dort in diese armen Regionen.
Auch da gibt es damit so einen kleinen Aufschwung, wenn man so möchte.
Was ich damit sagen will, die Sachen sind so, wie sie jetzt sind.
Man kann eine Maximalforderung stellen und kann sich dann schadlos raushalten
und sagen, ja, ehe Putin nicht angeklagt ist, können wir nichts machen,
aber dann ist das wie gesagt der unendliche Krieg, den man setzen kann und dann
müsste man den auch noch mit ganz vielen anderen zugleich führen.
Eigentlich müsste man ihn intervenieren.
Ja, man müsste intervenieren, man müsste ihn dezidiert anzetteln und deswegen
kann es nur irgendwelche Kompromisse geben,
die natürlich gewisse rote Linien haben müssen, also man kann nicht,
ja, über alles hinwegsehen.
Während man es ein bisschen unklar hat, ob man jetzt mit Putin verhandelt oder
mit irgendwelchen Nachfolgerinnen oder wie auch immer, wie das dann geht.
Erinnere nochmal, wir haben es ja vorhin kurz thematisiert, gerade bei diesen
CDU-Haudegen wie Kiesewetter und so.
Die Leute, die jetzt agieren, die müssen dann auch bereit sein,
so Verhandlungsergebnisse nicht nur für sich zu akzeptieren,
sondern auch uns zu vermitteln. Ja.
Es wäre ganz wichtig, dass wir nicht erst ein politisches Personal austauschen
und dann, okay, die Nachfolgeregierung sagt dann, okay und so und beruft sich
irgendwie auf, ja, das war die Vorgängerregierung.
Das ist dann auch kein guter, versöhnlicher Weg, sondern alle,
die jetzt, auch von Major oder so, müsste man jetzt eigentlich mal so langsam,
können sie es zumindest vorbereiten, Frau Major?
Ich glaube, es wird ähnlich sein wie bei Corona. Dann haben irgendwann die Leute,
die sehr viel Alarmismus, auch zum Teil übertriebenen Alarmismus betrieben haben, geschwiegen.
Sie haben sich dann einfach rausgenommen.
Also es gab nur ganz wenige Experten, die gesagt haben, also Drosten war dann
darunter, Kekulé war darunter, aber so von den sehr populären und viel twitternden und so.
Also man wollte die Pandemie fast nicht mehr loslassen und als sie dann losgelassen
wurde von Seiten der Politik,
hat man nicht gesagt, ja das ist doch schön, dass wir durchgekommen sind oder
so, sondern man ist einfach so dann verstummt und ich glaube das wird auch dann bei vielen so sein.
Gut möglich. Also Heusgen wurde gefragt, wie hoch ist die Kriegsgefahr?
Ich weiß, dass Sie Diplomat sind, aber ganz ehrlich, war die Kriegsgefahr in
Europa schon mal so greifbar wie jetzt mit einem aggressiven Russland,
einem immer aggressiveren Russland und einem schwankenden Amerika?
Ich glaube, man kann hier nicht irgendwie was vormachen. Es ist, die Gefahr ist groß.
Ich hoffe nur, dass wir aufgrund der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz,
auf der Gespräche, die geführt worden sind, aufgrund der Atmosphäre,
die wir hatten, dass wir vielleicht jetzt diese Gefahr schon ein bisschen herabmildern können.
Eine Gefahr herabmildern. Er ist halt ein Diplomat. Man kann nur hoffen,
dass er dann in München seinen Zugang zu den Gängen, was ja dann die Fernsehkameras
nicht mehr sehen, wo sie immer sagen, da geht es eigentlich zur Sache und so.
Und er wird auch nochmal zu Atomwaffen gefragt.
Und in diese Diskussion über europäische Verteidigung mischt sich jetzt auch
noch die Frage über europäische Atomwaffen.
Sie haben gesagt, man müsse mit Frankreich über die französischen Atomwaffen reden.
Was wäre denn das Ziel solcher Gespräche, dass ein EU-Gipfel künftig entscheidet,
ob Frankreich Atomwaffen einsetzt?
Nein, wir müssen das Thema als solches einbeziehen.
Und wir sollten das Angebot Frankreichs annehmen, überhaupt darüber zu sprechen.
Also nicht das Angebot Frankreichs, sondern darüber zu sprechen.
Das können wir ja mal annehmen.
Einen anderen Weg auch verfolgen und das ist die Zusammenarbeit mit Großbritannien.
Großbritannien hat übrigens anders als Frankreich seine Atomwaffen ja eingebracht
in die NATO. Aber Herr Häuschen, mit welchem Ziel?
Dass wir die Atomwaffen mitfinanzieren, die französischen?
Nein, wir müssen, wofür stehen Atomwaffen?
Atomwaffen stehen dafür, was Europa im Kalten Krieg den Frieden gebracht hat.
Das ist ein Instrument der Abschreckung.
Ja, das fand ich jetzt auch sehr gut. Jetzt weiß ich auch wiederum,
wie wir den Clip zurechtgelegt haben.
Wie sie ihn unterbricht. Ja, sollen wir dann die französischen Waffen mitfinanzieren?
Was ja im Grunde, sollen wir dann 3,80 Euro überweisen?
Und er so, es geht hier um alles gerade.
Ist ja immer so ein bisschen, oh Gott, wie sind die denn drauf da im Journalismus?
Aber auf diese Journalismusfrage freue ich mich bei Pressekonferenzen noch.
Wie wollen sie die Atomwaffen finanzieren?
Können wir an der Kindergrundsicherung sparen?
Genau, wie gegenfinanzieren wir jetzt die Atomwaffen? Nun gut,
es bleibt, so hier im Deutschlandfunk zu hören, von dieser ganzen Diskussion,
nachdem Pistorius so, keine Ahnung, ich blende das alles aus,
einfach nur das Prinzip Hoffnung.
Am Ende bleibt wohl nur das Prinzip Hoffnung.
Die Hoffnung, dass ein Demokrat im Weißen Haus bleiben wird oder aber,
dass Donald Trump Europa doch nicht so fallen lassen wird, wie er es im Wahlkampf
gerade angekündigt hat.
Wie heiß wird die Suppe am Ende gegessen, die Donald Trump androht zu kochen,
wenn er Präsident werden sollte, Frank Capellan berichtete.
Also ich würde sagen, da wir ja in der politischen Planung sind,
nochmal das Plädoyer, alles einpreisen, was denkbar ist.
Dagegen spricht natürlich, wenn jetzt Pistolo sagt, nee, nee,
nee, die amerikanischen Freunde, das wird schon und so.
Jetzt Kamala Harris auf der Bühne.
Ich finde das ja ehrlicherweise unverantwortlich, was wir jetzt sehen.
Dass sie es macht, okay, aber wir wissen...
Da hängt halt ein Damoklesschwert drüber. So, deswegen kann man das nicht für
voll nehmen, wenn Leute aus dem Wahlkampf her und dann irgendwie so reden.
US-Vizepräsidentin Harris versucht bei ihrem Auftritt in München alle Zweifel
an der Verlässlichkeit ihres Landes zu zerstreuen.
Nach Donald Trumps Infragestellen der NATO-Beistandspflicht klingt ihre Aufforderung,
das internationale Regelwerk zu verteidigen, eher wie eine Mahnung an die eigene Bevölkerung.
Seien Sie sich sicher, das amerikanische Volk wird dafür einstehen und Amerika
wird die Führungsrolle weiter übernehmen.
Ja, das ist, weiß ich nicht, da hätte jetzt auch irgendjemand anders fragen können.
Ja, es ist einfach so. Jetzt gibt es aber einen, der preist es einfach mal ein.
Ich habe schon häufiger von meinem neuen, ich mache eigentlich mehr Witze darüber,
als ich es ernst meinte, aber ich meine es eigentlich jedes Mal ein bisschen
ernster, meinen neuen Lieblingspodcast.
Bernd Rürup im Gespräch mit Michael Hüther.
Im Handelsblatt Economic Challenges Podcast. Bernd Rürup, wir kennen ihn noch.
Als wir Hartz IV und so weiter geplant haben, gab es ja eine kleine Kaste,
die sich über Rentenangst einmal in die Milliardärsklasse geschossen hat.
Er hat das ja mit organisiert. Das gehört
ja alles dazu, die Rürup und die Riester-Rente und was es alles gab. ab.
So, das ist also jemand, wie soll man sagen, der kann auch mal akzellitaristisch.
Ach, wir haben ein demografisches Problem. Ich mach mal eine Milliarde draus,
mir doch egal, was passiert.
Soll sie doch in 20 Jahren feststellen, dass sie nicht genug Geld haben.
So ungefähr, ne? Das ist nicht zu funktionieren. So, und so akzellitaristisch und es...
Ach, du meinst akzellerationistisch.
Akzellerationistisch.
Also du weißt schon. Ja, Beschleunigung. Medall durchdrücken.
Problem erkannt, okay, Vollgas gegen die Wand.
Aber bei ihm, das ist so witzig, weil er durchblickt ja wahrscheinlich wirklich
auf, ich will jetzt kein Urteil fällen, aber er durchblickt nicht so wirklich,
in welchem Kontext er welche Sachen wie sagt, sondern er macht das aus einem Gefühl heraus.
Und unter der Maßgabe, unter wir das jetzt hier einbetten, die er nicht präsent
hat, hören wir jetzt, wie er darüber spricht.
Wenn also es sich durchsetzt, dass sich die geopolitischen Rahmenbedingungen
ändern und dass wir einen hohen Modernisier- und Wandlungsbedarf haben,
denke ich, wird es möglich sein, die Widerstände gegen eine Modernisierung auch
unserer Finanzpolitik eher zu überwinden als bei einer Weitersquere.
Insofern wäre möglicherweise, das ist doch jetzt ein großer Bogen,
eine Änderung des geopolitischen Umfelds als Folge der Trump-Wahl.
Es wäre spät, aber noch nicht zu spät, könnte dann doch zu einer entsprechenden
Modernisierung, also der Wirtschaftspolitik, der deutschen Wirtschaftspolitik
führen. Die muss meines Erachtens modernisiert werden.
Und da kann eben so ein Sieg von Trump doch ein heilsamer Beschleuniger werden.
Das ist, finde ich, erstmal ein sehr origineller Gedanke.
Darf man das einfach so sagen?
Ja doch, ich finde, genau so muss man darüber auch mal sprechen.
Finde ich auch.
Es ist ja so, wir haben diese Diese Angebote da von Macron,
wo man jetzt bei Macron derzeit wieder gar nicht weiß, wo er hin will,
aber wir müssen jetzt gar nicht über Macron philosophieren, aber wir können
ja ganz klar sagen, momentan ist also die europäische Wirtschaft sehr eng verknüpft
mit der US-amerikanischen.
Zugleich haben wir aber Exportnationen, besonders Deutschland,
die in Länder exportieren, zum Beispiel China, die eigentlich von Washington
nicht so erwünscht sind.
Und wir haben sehr viele Fürsprecher, gerade für die US-amerikanische Richtung,
Decoupling inklusive der Präsidentin Ursula von der Leyen.
Nein, America is back, sagte Ursula von der Leyen, als Biden zurückkam und Macron
fragte, er fragt sich nur, wie lang.
Und hier ist ja schon die Sache so gewesen, endlich können wir wieder weitermachen
wie zuvor. Das war ja die Idee, wir knüpfen nahtlos an in dem festen Glaube,
dass es immer so weitergehen wird.
Biden wird nochmal Präsident und danach kommt ein neuer Biden und alles wird immer so sein.
Und tatsächlich kann natürlich jetzt passieren, dass es, also wenn Trump gewählt
wird, dann wird das nicht so sein.
Ich wäre aber nicht so optimistisch, wenn man das in Anführungszeichen setzend
sagen darf, wie Rürup das ist.
Denn was ich mir vorstellen kann, und das haben wir ja eben in diesen Clips
gehört mit Habeck und Fust etc., dass wenn Trump gewählt wird,
man sagt, oh, wir brauchen jetzt Kriegswirtschaft,
jetzt richten wir alles darauf aus, wir sparen, wir tun und machen und wir machen
Sondervermögen für die Bundeswehr.
Aber dass dadurch man sagt, wir machen die große KI-Revolution jetzt hier und
wir machen dem Silicon Valley von Paris aus Konkurrenz oder so, das sehe ich nicht.
Sondern ich glaube, dass Trump disruptiv sein wird,
aber nicht in dem Sinne, dass wir da eine Erneuerung stattfinden,
sondern wir werden tatsächlich dann so eine Politik haben,
die die Bevölkerung auf harte Zeiten einstellt.
Und ich sehe da tatsächlich das nicht. Findest du aber charmant,
dass dieser Gedanke mal ausgesprochen wird?
Ja, ich finde umso charmanter, dass da eben kein, so wie wir jetzt schon zwei
Stunden Gespräch vorher stattfindet, sondern dass das so.
Ja, ich finde das an sich gut. Ich meine, Rürup wird keine Angst davor haben,
dass er geklippt wird und dann bei Twitter rumgereicht wird.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut, wenn man das mal so raushaut und ich würde
sagen, ja, unter so einem disruptiven Charakter kann man das sehen.
Verbuchen wir es unter Howding-Manier, dem wir sehr sympathisch gegenüberstehen.
Der Supreme Court pausiert jetzt erstmal ein Verfahren, nämlich hat Trump da
an einer Überrumpelung des Staates am 6.
Januar mitgewirkt, zugunsten einer
anderen Entscheidung, ist er eigentlich grundsätzlich immun gegen alles.
Das wurde ja bisher schon in verschiedenen Gerichten verhandelt,
demnächst im Supreme Court, irgendwann im Mai oder so.
Jetzt ist die Frage, was wird da konkret verhandelt? Die Immunität eines Präsidenten.
Und wir denken jetzt so, oh ja, ich habe ja auch gehört, wie damals die Immunität
von irgendeinem Abgeordneten aufgehoben wurde, um mal zu gucken und so weiter.
Keine Ahnung, was das bedeutet. Ich dachte, Immunität kommt aus dem Gesundheitswesen.
Da ist heraus, nein, ist ein ernsthaftes Problem.
Immunität muss mal diskutiert werden. Wir hören jetzt hier mal in eine Gerichtsverhandlung
rein, reportiert in The Daily.
Und wir versuchen jetzt mal, auch wenn wir nicht des Englischen mächtig sind,
vielleicht, wir übersetzen es danach in groben Zügen, Was genau?
Debattieren hier die Anwälte von Trump und die Anwälte des Weißen Hauses vor Gericht.
And what about this question of acting in an official capacity and whether that
confers immunity? What do the government's lawyers say about that?
The government's lawyer says that these two things are not mutually exclusive.
That you can be acting in an official capacity and you can be committing grave criminal wrongdoing.
The lawyer echoes the point from Judge Henderson.
I fully endorse or agree with the idea of the paradox of a president who,
on the one hand, having the article to take care responsibility.
And on the other hand, sort of seeing compliance with the law as optional.
That there's an element of paradox about this, that your job is to execute the
laws faithfully, and yet you are violating a criminal law, and you could be immune from that.
I mean, what kind of world are we living in if, as I understood my friend on
the other side to say here, a president orders his SEAL team to assassinate
a political rival and resigns, for example, before an impeachment?
Not a criminal Und dann kommt er zurück zu dem Beispiel der politischen Verstöße,
die via SEAL Team 6 bestätigt wurde und sagt, dass das nicht der Fall ist,
dass man von der Verwaltung,
von der Mörderung deiner politischen Rivalen immun ist, ohne dass der Kongress
die Vergewaltigung und die Vergewaltigung macht.
So, darf der amerikanische Präsident SEAL Team 6 beauftragen,
seinen Wahlkampfkontrahenten totzuschießen?
Und ist er dann immun gegen Strafverfolgung? Ja oder nein? Das verhandeln die da.
Demnächst vor dem Supreme Court. Wahnsinn.
Ja und wir haben zugleich den Nawalny-Fall, wo genau so etwas stattfindet.
Und mich erinnert es an das 17. Jahrhundert.
Ich habe das Stück vielleicht schon mal erwähnt. Das heißt Sinner von Pierre
Corneille und da fällt der Satz, die Staatsverbrechen, die der Krone gelten,
gelten, verzeiht der Himmel, wenn sie gelingen.
Also, wenn man damit zur Macht, wenn man damit zur Macht gelangt oder sie dadurch erhält,
dann ist es gerechtfertigt, dann ist es ein Ausdruck von Souveränität.
Aber da sind wir im 17. Jahrhundert, da könnte man diesen schönen Satz sagen,
da dachte ich, da wären wir schon weiter. Offenbar nicht.
So, jetzt könnte man ja anmerken, naja, Stefan, da ist ja vor Gericht verhandelt worden.
Und die eine Seite hat das ja nur zur Illustration, um auch ein bisschen zu schocken, so genannt.
Da würde ich sagen, stimmt zur Hälfte, weil das Immunitätsansinnen,
für das Trump ja gerade kämpft, ist ja tatsächlich,
ich mache einen Staatsstreich. Er ist zwar nicht gelungen, aber ich kann ja
weiter als Präsidentschaftskandidat andrehen und das darf mir dann nicht negativ
da ausgelegt werden, denn der Wähler soll entscheiden.
So, es ist also ganz konkret, bei dieser Kongressaktion am 6.
Januar, es sind auch Menschen gestorben und so, also da gab es ausreichend Drama und,
Tatsächlich vor Gericht verhandelt wird ja Demokratieverständnisse.
Die einen sagen, wir verteidigen die Demokratie gegen Trump und dann kommen
die Trump-Wähler und sagen, nee, die reißen ja den ganzen Staat runter,
wir sind die eigentlichen Demokraten.
Also beide kommen mit derselben Argumentation, wir sind die wahren Demokraten.
Ja, das ist ja auch in dem Stück von Shakespeare Coriolanus,
wo eigentlich so ein Volkstribunen sich dann selbst setzt als der homogene Ausdruck
des eigentlichen Volkswillens und das finden wir dann in verschiedenen Facetten
und das ist bei Trump ganz klar,
also man kann eigentlich Coriolanus sehr gut nochmal so mit der Schablone Trump lesen.
Ja, und es ist halt nicht nur bei Trump ganz klar, sondern auch,
und das kann sich jetzt jeder mal selber überprüfen, wie viel Angst hat man
davor, dass Trump gewählt wird?
Sieht man dann die amerikanische Demokratie in Gefahr und glaubt nicht mehr
daran, dass Trump wieder abgewählt werden könnte zu Lebzeiten?
So, was bedeutet, man hat noch eine Demokratie, aber der jetzt gerade laufende
Kampf um das höchste Amt in dieser Demokratie läuft unter der Maxime,
nicht mehr innerhalb der Demokratie folgenreich zu sein,
sondern beide Seiten unterstellen der anderen, ihr hebt die Demokratie aus.
Und hier wird ein ganz interessantes Bild bemüht in dieser Berichterstattung.
Dass die Zukunft beängstigend ist, aber für eine andere Grundlage als die Regierung sagt.
Wir sind in einer Situation, in der wir die Beurteilung des Hauptpolitischen
Opponenten haben, der in jedem Wahlkampf gewinnt und von der Regierung beurteilt
wird, die er verweigern will.
Das ist die beängstigende Zukunft. Das wird geplant, um Zyklen der Rekriminierung
zu eröffnen, die unsere Republik schenken werden.
It's interesting, there's these kind of two dueling visions of what the frightening
future that this case leads to actually is on either side.
It's the case of the dueling dystopias.
Hast du davon schon mal gehört? Nein.
Die sich dualierenden Dystopien. Er sagt das hier so locker hinweg.
Sie sagt, das sind ja dann dualierende Visionen. Und er sagt,
nein, es sind keine duellierenden Visionen, sondern sich duellierende Dystopien.
Und dann habe ich das mal gegoogelt, weil ich dachte, okay, das klingt so,
als hätten die hier wieder sowas Heimliches eingebaut. Dann stellt sich heraus,
ja, also das ist große Kulturgeschichte.
Diese Geschichte um Kathleen Aberdeen oder wie sie heißt, oder Kate Nees oder
wie auch immer, also hier Panem.
Katniss Aberdeen.
Hunger Games und so, genau. Susanna Collins sitzt in den 90ern in Amerika auf
ihrem Sofa und guckt Fernsehen.
Und es wechselt sich programmatisch ab, Reality TV und Irak-Kriegsberichterstattung.
Und sie fragt sich so, alles sehr interessant. an.
Auf der einen Seite sehe ich so individuelle Schicksale, wo es einfach nur so
ein Race to the Bottom ist und alle stehen daneben und denken sich so,
oh Gott, das ist ja nicht vorbildhaft, was wir hier sehen.
Und dann Irak-Kriegsberichterstattung und man sieht genau das Gleiche,
diesen Schicksalsstrudel nach unten, aber für ganze Bevölkerung.
Eine Million Tote und so.
Und dann entwickelt sie daraus diese Idee der Hunger Games.
Also Hunger Games, die Dekadenz der Hauptstadt ist ja das große Thema und dann
in dem zweiten Catching Fire, die Tyrannei von Panem.
Und in diesen, ich habe mir so mal einen Text rausgesucht, wo das so abgehandelt
wird, wie das zu interpretieren ist.
Diese ganze Geschichte läuft darauf hinaus, dass sie vor die Wahl gestellt wird,
also entweder begehst du jetzt hier einen ganz großen rituellen Selbstmord,
in dem einfach klar ist, du unterwirfst
dich der Tyrannei oder dein Herkunftsdistrikt wird platt gemacht.
Also sie hat nur zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder der eigene Tod oder Tod aller
Familien und Family und Friends, die sie so kennen.
Und es wird ja in dem Film genau so ausgebildet, das sind die zwei Alternativen.
So, und das sind dualierende Dystopien. Es gibt keinen dritten Wert mehr.
Man hat nur noch die Möglichkeit zwischen etwas kleineres, aber sehr nahgehendes
Drama oder eben dem großen Drama.
Und das ist einfach die ganze Herkunft. So, und dann hatten wir es auch schon
mal ein bisschen früher. Das kennen wir natürlich alle.
Die Welt ist irgendwie so im Aufbruch, eigentlich gerade Friedenszeit und so.
Und dann kommt plötzlich Brave New World und 1984 raus.
Und der Leser denkt sich so, er muss mich jetzt entscheiden zwischen einem der
beiden. Also gibt es nicht nochmal was fröhliches oder so?
Und diese dualierenden Dystopien werden in einem dieser Texte im New Yorker,
wo diese Golden Age of Dystopian Fiction,
also wo damals Aldous Huxley und so weiter diese Bücher kamen,
steht dann drin, das Duell der Dystopien ist nichts weiter als ein weiterer
Ort, der von der polarisierten Politik vergiftet wird.
Ein Stellvertreterkrieg der imaginären Welten.
Die Dystopie war einmal eine Fiktion des Widerstands. Sie ist eine Fiktion der
Unterwerfung geworden.
Die Fiktion eines misstrauischen, einsamen und mürrischen 21.
Jahrhunderts. Die Fiktion von Fake News und Infowars. Die Fiktion von Hilflosigkeit
und Hoffnungslosigkeit.
Sie kann sich keine bessere Zukunft vorstellen und fordert auch niemanden auf,
sich die Mühe zu machen, eine zu schaffen. Und ich denke mir,
okay, das trifft gerade ziemlich genau dieses, ja, wir müssen jetzt Waffen schicken
und dafür auf Butter verzichten.
Weil wenn wir auf die Butter nicht verzichten, sind wir die Nächsten.
Also wir haben nur noch zwei Alternativen. Wir müssen uns jetzt einer davon
unterwerfen. Das Schicksal hat Putin in der Hand und Perspektiv ist Trump.
Die bestimmen über alles und wir haben quasi gar keinen Ausweg mehr.
Und diese Ausweglosigkeit unter so einem, ja und cool, das ist so ein Wahljahr,
in dem irgendwie 40 Prozent der Weltbevölkerung mal wählen darf und so.
Aber das sind sozusagen, alle sind gefangen in so einem Duell in ihrem Dystopie-Gedanken.
Fand ich irgendwie sehr aufschlussreich dafür, dass das so als Halbsatz mal
eben in so einem Podcast da genannt wurde.
Nun betrachten wir ja bei Amerika ein Land,
das einen relativ hohen Wohlstand hat und klar gibt es da Armut und gibt es
da große Probleme im Gesundheitssystem und und und.
Aber ich sag mal, die Leute leben ja jetzt da so und für die meisten,
also 50, 60, 70 Prozent, ändert sich, egal wer regiert, erst einmal ökonomisch nichts.
Die bekommen nicht wesentlich mehr Geld. Man kann ja sogar gerade bei Biden
sehen, dass es mit ihm mehr voranging, als man eigentlich erwartet hatte.
Also man hat ja da die Inflation sehr schnell abgeschwächt.
Man hatte dann mit dieser neuen Industriepolitik viel mehr Beschäftigung geschaffen
als gedacht. Also den Leuten geht es etwas besser als zuvor.
Und jetzt, wenn ein Trump Präsident wird und dann diktatorische Handlungen vollzieht,
was dann bedeutet, dass die Presse eingeschränkt wird,
dass gewisse Richter abgesetzt und neue besetzt werden und all das,
dann kann man ja doch festhalten,
einen sehr großen Teil der US-Bevölkerung wird das zwar medial rezipieren,
aber deren konkretes Leben ändert sich ja nicht.
Also,
Minderheiten wird es sehr schlecht gehen. Bestimmten Minderheiten zumindest.
Das ist alles, also nicht, dass es jetzt so heißt wie, ja, wenn Trump kommt, verändert sich nichts.
Sondern was mich so interessiert, ist dieser Pax in Bello, also wie man eigentlich
dann in so einem Zustand des Krieges oder des Bürgerkrieges,
worauf das eigentlich hinaus laufen würde,
man trotzdem für sich so lebt.
Also die Leute Leute mähen den Rasen, gehen einkaufen, sitzen abends vor Netflix
oder gucken Football, Baseball, was auch immer.
Das heißt, das ist ja so dieses Erstaunliche, also dieses Beherrschtwerden ist
ja eines in so einem großen Nationalstaat, das man ja oft gar nicht merkt.
Also wir merken, wenn es dir einigermaßen gut geht, also wenn du so viel verdienst,
dass du nicht das Amt fragen musst, kann ich da und dort was machen,
dann musst du dich ja ausziehen vor denen und musst zeigen, was du hast und so weiter.
Aber wenn du so viel verdienst, dass du nichts so staatlich in Anspruch nehmen
musst, dann merkst du den Staat zwar, wenn du deinen Lohn bekommst,
dass da was abgezogen wurde, aber sonst ist der Staat ja abwesend.
Also ich habe Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz noch nie gesehen, glaube,
dass es ihn gibt, aber der regiert so, aber der kommt ja nicht bei mir vorbei.
Und das frage ich mich, wie sich das gestalten wird in den USA,
dass für viele Amerikaner das dann genauso als Normalität dann anerkannt wird,
wie das jetzt normal ist, dass Biden gerade Präsident ist.
Und das haben wir ja bei der ersten Amtszeit von Trump schon gemerkt.
Ja, wir konzentrieren uns auf das Kapitol oder auf diese riesigen Polizeiaktionen,
der militaristische Kampf gegen die Proteste, die George-Floyd-Proteste und all das.
Aber was wir ja nicht erkennen, ist, dass ganz viele …,
So weiterleben, wie sie leben und das ist ja das Katastrophale eigentlich daran.
Das ist ja nicht, dass das dazu führt, dass dann sehr bald eine politisierte
Gesellschaft da sein wird, die sich erheben wird gegen Trump,
sondern man wird erleben, dass sie das als neue Normalität gerade so akzeptieren,
da ihr Leben ziemlich unverändert weitergeht.
Das ist ja eine der größten Paradoxien, die ja damals schon beschrieben wurde.
Also wir haben Battleground States und in denen wiederum kommt es dann nur auf
so ein paar Wählerdemografiegruppen an.
Was ja dazu führt, dass die Vorwahlen, dass sie traditionell in Iowa zuerst
stattfinden, dass die Kandidaten sich die Zeit nehmen, in jeden der 99 Distrikte
von Iowa einmal vorstellig werden, auch wenn da nur 3000 Leute leben.
Weil sie wissen, davon hängt mein persönliches Schicksal ab,
komme ich in dieser Wahl weiter oder nicht.
Also entscheidet am Ende irgendjemand, dem es egal sein kann.
In Iowa lebt man halt, wie man in Iowa so lebt. Über die ganze Weltpolitik.
Millionen und Milliarden Menschen werden in der Mitleidenschaft gerissen von
dieser Entscheidung, die da aber eigentlich auch ausgeblendet werden kann.
Also die ist eigentlich für denjenigen, der sie trifft, jetzt nicht weltbewegend.
Diese 20 Millionen, wir wohnen in einem Trailerpark in Amerika,
aussortierten schon, die das auch wieder treffen wird, wenn da irgendwas passiert,
aber da die keine feste Adresse haben oder was auch immer, können die sowieso
nicht wählen und wie, so.
Wenn all die aussortiert und am Ende hast du so eine Wohlstandskaste,
die dann einfach befindet.
Wer hat mir denn besser gefallen im Fernsehen? Das ist ja nur noch ein Popularitätswettbewerb.
Ich denke aber jetzt, wo ich so darüber rede, in Berlin hatten wir das ja auch.
Du hast eine Eine Wiederholungswahl und die Wahlzettel dürfen nicht verändert
werden, weil es ist ja nur die Wiederholung einer schon stattgefundenen Wahl.
Was ja bedeutete, dass die AfD jemand auf dem Wahlzettel hatte,
der wegen terroristischer Unterstützungsvermutung in U-Haft sitzt.
Wo die AfD selber sagt, nee, die hat uns echt Probleme gemacht.
Sie hat da Leute im Bundestag eingeschleust über Besucher, die da plötzlich
die Politiker angegangen haben.
Sie hat irgendwie diese Lauterbach-Entführungsgeschichte so ein bisschen mit in der Hand gehabt.
Sie ist verbandelt mit diesen komischen Rechtsreichsbürgern, die da und so weiter.
Ich weiß gar nicht genau, wo sie alles mit drin hängt. Aber die AfD sagt selbst, wählt die nicht.
Sie hat aber tausend Stimmen mehr bekommen als bei der letzten Wahl.
Das heißt, sehr viele Menschen gehen einfach zum Wahllokal, sind wütend über irgendwas.
Irgendwann gab es einen Trigger, sie wählen jetzt AfD. Und darüber hinaus blenden sie alles aus.
Folgenreichtum, wer ist der Kandidat? Es findet einfach alles überhaupt nicht statt.
Es schlägt sich nicht nieder. Und da denke ich mir immer, wie viele Kämpfe habe
ich geführt, weil ich immer diesen Niklas-Luhmann-Satz wiederhole.
Man geht motivlos in die Wahlkabine.
Man gibt so ein Stimmungssignal ab. Man weiß selber nicht genau,
was bedeutet das jetzt, wenn ich Friedrich Merz als Kanzler haben will.
Man hat halt so eine Idee von, ja, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ist ein guter Rhetoriker oder sowas.
Und dann entfaltet sich aber irgendwas strukturell.
Und das hat man aber nicht im Blick. Und jetzt in Berlin hat man aber gesehen,
ja, die Leute gehen, was das angeht, motivlos.
Es sind nicht die Motive, sondern es sind die Stimmungen, irgendwelche Trigger,
die man vielleicht therapeutisch nochmal nachvollziehen könnte, aber wenn überhaupt.
Aber es ist einfach, es findet halt statt. Und Erfolgreichstum demokratisch
wird da nicht richtig eingepresst.
Und das haben wir jetzt quasi auf allen Ebenen. Also wenn jetzt immer diese
große Freude ist, 40 oder 60 Prozent der Welt wählen jetzt einmal gleichzeitig
in einem Jahr, weil in Amerika EU-Wahlen und in Indien oder so Wahlen sind,
Muss man sich echt fragen, ja und?
Was bedeutet das genau? Es ist noch nicht per se,
Einfach eine gute Sache, sondern man muss sich nochmal genau vergewissern, warum eigentlich?
Naja, das sind ja auch diese Stimmungsbekundungen jetzt, dass alle sagen,
der Kanzler der Herzen ist Pistorius.
Das ist ja aus einer reinen Stimmung, die mal irgendwo entstanden ist.
Aber ja, dann ist das jetzt offenbar so.
Wenn man jetzt das medial anders konzertieren würde mit den Taurus-Lieferungen
und Scholz ist der standhafteste Mann von Deutschland und Europa,
dann würden alle sagen, ja Scholz ist unser König.
Nur hat man jetzt irgendwie sich gedacht, es ist sinnvoll, jeden Tag Marie-Agnes
Strack-Zimmermann zu interviewen.
Ja, und die sorgt dann dafür, dass die Stimmung eher gegen Scholz geht.
Also das ist reine Stimmung.
Es geht runter und drüber. Kommen wir zu einem Thema, das uns alle betrifft.
Dating. Dating.
Der das KI-Unternehmen DeepMind mitbegründete und er hat dann auch in führender
Funktion bei Google, also bei Alphabet gearbeitet.
Dieses Buch wird empfohlen von Bill Gates,
von Yuval Noah Harari, von sehr vielen und wir glauben auch,
dass das nochmal wichtig ist, so fundamentaler diese AI-Debatte zu führen und
denken, dass dieses Buch ein sehr guter Anlass dafür ist.
Vielleicht ist er echt der wichtigste Typ überhaupt. DeepMind wurde von Google gekauft.
Google hat dann so, ich habe da auch so Podcast-Ausschnitte wieder gehört,
wo das nochmal ganz deutlich wurde, wie DeepMind damals schon sagte,
wir machen das nicht ohne Ethik.
Wir brauchen Ethikrat, wir müssen das hier thematisieren und so weiter und so fort.
Und Google hat ja immer davor zurückgeschreckt, Sachen dann zu veröffentlichen.
Die haben dann sehr viel, wie sparst du besser deinen Strom,
wir werten dein Verhalten aus, um zu rauszuholen und so weiter.
Also all solche Sachen sind in Android irgendwie drin, aber sie haben sich nie
so richtig getraut, das zu veröffentlichen.
Der eine Typ, der dann mal meinte, ich glaube, diese Maschine redet mit mir
und so weiter, die haben sie gleich gefeuert und gesagt, nein,
kein Problem, alles gut und so. Und dann kam.
GPT über OpenAI und Google konnte es nicht mehr zurückhalten,
hat einmal noch alles durchgetrimmt und war in windendes Eile jetzt mit Gemini
und so eigentlich auf Augenhöhe mit OpenAI.
Nach leichten Anlaufschwierigkeiten, aber jetzt sind sie da wirklich,
sagt eigentlich keiner mehr, das ist ja irgendwie nachstehen und so.
Es ist nur noch die Frage, wie man das Produkt selbst an den Markt bringt und
wir haben ja jetzt auch gesehen, wie...
Die Zahlen sind ja so Wahnsinn. Also wir haben den ganzen deutschen Automobilsektor,
um mal aus unserer Richtung zu kommen.
Und dann haben wir daneben Tesla, das größer ist von der Marktkapitalisierung.
Und dann haben wir einzelne Firmen, die nur Chips herstellen und die an einem
Tag mehr Börsenkapitalwert erlangen, an Zuwachs alleine als Tesla-Wert ist.
Mit dem NVIDIA. Und das ist so grotesk. Das kann man sich nicht mehr vorstellen.
Und ich glaube, DeepMind und so, die Leute, die haben das vor 10,
15 Jahren so ausgelöst einfach.
Als 20-jährige Judenspunde, die da irgendwie so Ideen hatten.
Also das Buch zu lesen, wird, glaube ich, sehr eindrücklich für uns.
Und wer sich noch dafür interessiert, weil wir schon ein paar Mal jetzt Rutger
Bregmann erwähnt haben, darüber haben wir im vergangenen Salon gesprochen.
Und im vergangenen Salon haben wir auch unser August-Event dann angekündigt
und auch gezeigt, wie man da an Karten kommt.
Das werden wir im nächsten Salon auch wieder tun, aber wer das da schon mal
nachhören möchte, kann das tun und wir haben auch bekannt gegeben,
dass wir im Juni mal vor einem Salon einen Tag vorher in die Oper gehen.
Wer jetzt keine Tickets für den Salon hat, aber trotzdem sagt,
ah ja, aber in der Oper wäre ich ja sowieso mal gerne dabei,
kann das dann im letzten Salon nachhören und diesen August-Termin,
das sagen wir natürlich noch mal alles an, wo wir da sind im August und wie
man da an Karten kommen kann.
Das wird ja dann ein sehr großes Event werden.
Da freuen wir uns drauf. Stefan sagt noch ganz schnell, wie kommt man in den Salon?
Man geht auf neue20er.de und folgt dem goldenen Button, entscheidet sich für
Steady, macht sich einen Account, bezahlt und dann hat man ein RSS-Feed.
Man kann ihn hören wie jeden anderen Podcast.
Da gibt es Kapitelmarken drin, da ist ein,
individuelles Cover für jede Ausgabe drin, wo das Buch zu sehen ist und so.
Oder man klickt bei Apple einfach, wenn man eh über Apple Podcasts hört,
aber dann kostet es einen Euro mehr.
Alle schlagen jetzt die Apple-Preise auf die Apple-Dings mit drauf.
Also Netflix oder das YouTube-Ding, was eigentlich 12 Euro kostet,
kostet bei Apple einfach 17 Euro. Ah ja.
Und so. Und Facebook hat jetzt auch schon gesagt, also wenn ihr hier irgendwie
Werbekampagnen bucht und das bequem über das iPhone machen wollt,
wir legen euch den Preis da drauf. Wenn ihr es über den Browser macht, nicht.
So legen wir auch diesen Euro einfach drauf, den Apple da kassiert.
Also sind es 3,50 Euro statt 2,50 Euro.
Oder man hat schon einen Patreon-Account, da kann man noch zu Patreon gehen,
aber Patreon gefällt mir noch nicht so gut, weil da ist nicht so viel Möglichkeit,
Kapitelmarken oder so auch mal zu platzieren.
Die sind in der Datei drin, aber man hat jetzt, wie auch immer.
Also wenn jemand schon einen Patreon-Account hat, wir präferieren da wie immer Steady.
Ja, wir empfehlen Steady und das ist der einzige Weg, also den Salon zu abonnieren,
diesen Podcast zu unterstützen und da würden wir uns sehr freuen.
Vielleicht wollen ja auch manche unterstützen, aber den Salon nicht hören. Auch das ist möglich.
Einfach aber dann nur, indem man ein Abo abschließt. Eine andere Möglichkeit gibt es nicht.
Vielen Dank für die, die das schon gemacht haben und wir sehen uns ja auch dann in,
dem kommenden Monat oder der jetzt dann schon begonnen hat, im März sehen wir
uns ja dann auch, dann gibt es ja ein Live-Salon und alle, die jetzt keine Karten
bekommen haben, keine Sorge, der wird dann auch am nächsten Tag als Salon hörbar sein.
Man verpasst also nichts und damit lohnt sich dann der Salon doppelt für diesen Monat.
Dating.
Wann hattest du dein letztes Date, Wolfgang?
Tja, das sind jetzt die großen Fragen. Zumindest nicht über eine Dating-App,
das kann ich jedenfalls sagen.
Und es geht um Dating-Apps hier ganz stark, will ich unterstreichen,
denn Dating ohne Dating-App ist schwierig geworden,
beziehungsweise könnte es aber dazu kommen, dass das Daten ohne App wieder attraktiver wird.
Denn es wird schon von einer Post-Tinder-Dekade gesprochen, was daran liegt,
dass die Download-Zahlen rückläufig sind.
Also man kann sich denken, wann sie nochmal ordentlich nach oben gegangen sind.
Das war 2020, als wir im Lockdown saßen.
Da war das dann für viele die Möglichkeit, überhaupt mit Leuten in Kontakt zu
treten. Man hat dann auch sich online verabredet und hat so ein bisschen mal
ausgetestet, wie der andere so tickt.
Und dann hat das abgenommen 21, 22, 23, also wir reden ja immer noch von über
30 Millionen Downloads, ja, aber es werden immer so 1, 2, 3 Millionen weniger.
Es begann Tinder mit 2012 und da hat man gleich dann im ersten Jahr schon so
17 Millionen Downloads gehabt, aber jetzt scheint sich da irgendetwas zu drehen.
Wir hören jetzt mal in verschiedene Podcasts rein, in TikToks zum Beispiel jetzt hier.
Infinite Tabs heißt die Userin, die hat ein Video gemacht, wie sie Dating sieht
und war damit sehr erfolgreich.
Also man kann sich vorstellen, das ist ein großes Thema, gerade bei TikTok.
Dating-Erfahrungen werden geschildert, aber auch so generelle Betrachtungen
werden angestellt darüber, wie diese Apps eigentlich funktionieren und was an
ihnen vielleicht nicht so gut ist.
... Theorie darüber, warum Dating-Apps nie schlechter waren als sie jetzt sind.
Ich erkläre es mit einer kurzen Geschichte, wie wir hierher gekommen sind.
Lassen wir uns zurückfliegen zu den frühen 2010ern. Tinder ist dieses revolutionäre
neue App, das sich als dieses verrückte neue Weg, um Leute zu treffen,
mit deinem Telefon verwendet. Wie viele von euch, war ich nicht alt genug,
um es zu nutzen, weil ich in der Hochschule war, aber wir wussten es alle.
Ich meine, wie Kendall Jenner es promotierte.
Also für einen Zeitpunkt sah es völlig legit aus. Aber über die Zeit hat es
eine Reputation für CD-Daten entwickelt und primär für Menschen,
die nur Booty-Kollegen machen wollten.
So a few years later, in direct response to Tinder's gross vibes,
Bumble launched, creating a space where women made the first move and ostensibly
solving the problem for anyone who wanted a place to go if they wanted to find a relationship.
And that worked for a lot of people. I met my first boyfriend on Bumble in 2017.
But like Tinder, it eventually got overrun by people who just wanted to bang
and its reputation declined.
Again, in direct response to this was the emergence of Hinge.
Which, despite, fun fact, being originally designed to match you with mutual
friends of people you are on Facebook, was rebranded as the dating app designed to be deleted.
Ja, vielen werden die Namen bekannt sein, also Tinder und dann kam Bumble und
jetzt ist es Hinge und das ist diese App, die verspricht, das ist die App,
die du wieder löschen wirst.
Das heißt also, da findest du dann die Liebe fürs Leben oder zumindest für eine lange Zeit.
Du kennst ja noch mehr Dating-Plattformen, weil du mal erzählt hast,
es gibt eine Plattform, die extra sich an Erwachsene richtet, die schon Kinder haben.
Ja, und die habe ich genau drei, vier Stunden benutzt, bis es gematcht hat und
seitdem bin ich ja wieder glücklich vergeben.
Die heißt Even und die war auch zu dem Zeitpunkt so neu, keine Ahnung,
ich habe dann ein paar Wochen später im Fernsehen gelesen,
Irgend so eine Dating-Show gesehen auf Deutsch, bei der sich Kinder Millennials
trafen, um ihre Boomer-Eltern zu verkuppeln.
Also die Boomer hatten Dates und die Millennial-Kinder saßen hinter dem Fernseher
dahinter und haben das live kommentiert, wie ihre Eltern sich da gerade verhalten und so.
Und diese Sendung wurde auch von der Even-App präsentiert, was ja bedeutet,
okay, Fernsehwerbung ist wirklich teuer.
Also da scheint jemand mit Kapital dahinter zu sein. Nein, Bumble ist ja bisher
die einzige Dating-App, die sich so ein bisschen abseits des,
da gibt es so ein Konglomerat, damals Match.com und wie auch immer und Tinder,
das gehört ja alles zusammen.
Das ist alles Match auch.
Genau, außer Bumble. Bumble ist eben eigen und Even gehört bestimmt da auch
irgendwo dazu, keine Ahnung.
Ja und das ist ja interessant, dass du das sagst, du hast da jetzt ganz wenige Stunden verbracht.
Sofort wieder gelöscht. Ich war im Grunde so ein.
Tapps folgendes.
But ever since Hinge, no other app has come on the market that's a genuine competitor.
Ja, leuchtet ein. Also man muss ja eigentlich die Leute bei der Stange halten,
wie das bei Facebook oder Twitter auch ist.
Man verdient daran, dass Leute viel Zeit dort verbringen.
Also nicht nur drei Stunden dort sind, alles schon erledigt haben und dann das Ding wieder löschen.
Sondern man möchte eigentlich eine Gesellschaft, die permanent datet und permanent
nach der Liebe sucht, alle möglichen Daten dort angibt,
in Chats alles reinschreibt, denn diese Daten kann man dann auch wieder auswerten,
verkaufen und so weiter.
Nun ist aber so, meine Dating-Erfahrung, die also was die Apps angeht und so
weiter, jetzt schon wieder sehr lange zurückliegt.
Ich hätte ungerne die Apps gelöscht im Sinne von, jetzt brauche ich sie ja nicht
mehr. Weil sie sagt ja, das ist dann alles verseucht von Leuten,
die nur noch so einen Hookup suchen.
Und genau das ist ja nicht meine Suche.
Trotzdem finde ich, haben ja diese Dating-Apps noch den Vorteil,
dass man grundsätzlich Menschen kennenlernt.
Ich habe zum Beispiel meine Logopädin über Tinder kennengelernt.
Und jetzt bin ich alle zwei Wochen bei ihr und wir machen Stimmtraining und
sie massiert mir den Nacken. und ich versuche, so einen kleinen Reflux in den
Griff zu kriegen und der ganze Kram.
Also es ist sozusagen dadurch, dass sie selbst Erfahrung hat mit so Bühnendarstellern
und wie kriegt man die eigentlich mal darauf getrimmt, dass man auf einer Bühne
anders spricht als so normal und so weiter und so fort.
Also es war sozusagen auch ein Match, das nicht zustande gekommen wäre,
wenn es nicht unter oh, ich bin Single und keine Ahnung, will der Menschen kennenlernen.
Deswegen diese um da, ich habe keine Erfahrung mit Bumble, aber soweit ich bei
Bumble das verstehe, ist nicht nur ein Feature, dass man sagt, ich,
suche und die Frau macht aber die erste Ansprache nach einem Matching,
also die Frau schreibt die erste Nachricht, erst danach können Männer reagieren,
sondern dass man das Profil da sehr einfach, nicht einfach nur runterstufen
kann von was suche ich eigentlich,
sondern man kann das ganze Profil prinzipiell auf ich suche Freundschaft umstellen
und dann wird auch, werden Männern auch Männer und Frauen auch Frauen angezeigt und so weiter.
Also es ist wirklich ein prinzipielles es umschalten, weil dieses Menschen kennenlernen,
obwohl sich keine sozialen Wege im echten Leben kreuzen, also echtes Leben mal
vom virtuellen unterschieden, finde ich eigentlich kein schlechtes Prinzip und
unter dieser Maßgabe Reputationsmaschine.
Adressierbarkeit und Nachvollzug von Lebenswandeln, auch wenn man nicht selber
immer, wie geht's in dir heute, sondern einfach nur, weil es ein Newsfeed ist, ist ja Instagram,
eine App, die so langsam Amazon-Status erreicht, im Sinne von,
es ist eine wesentliche Einrichtung für die Infrastruktur der Gesellschaft.
Ohne Instagram sind ganz schön viele sozialen Ordnungen nicht mehr möglich.
So, und dass sich aus einer Dating-App das noch nicht entwickelt hat,
sondern dass sich Instagram aus der anderen Richtung in diese Richtung bewegt.
Finde ich erstaunlich.
In die Richtung Dating. Ja, Richtung Dating und Richtung grundsätzlicher...
Beziehungsweise es gibt ja einige Apps, einige Dating-Apps, die verknüpft sind mit Instagram.
Das heißt, du kannst dein Insta-Profil dort hinterlegen, dass man dann nicht
nur das eine Profilfoto oder die zwei Profilfotos sieht, sondern man sieht dann
auch nochmal den Menschen im persönlichen Umfeld.
Aber True Barrymore war kürzlich in einer Talkshow und erzählte von ihren Dating-
Erfahrungen und sie datet an sich gerne und sagte, Es wäre jetzt bei diesen
Dating-Apps so, dass die Männer so, so wenig von sich preisgeben,
dass sie dann immer hoffnungsfroh auf das Insta-Profil, auf die Verlinkung klickt,
aber alle seien ja inzwischen privat und dann könne sie da auch wieder nichts sehen.
Und das halte ich für einen ganz großen und ich frage mich auch,
warum Instagram das nicht macht.
Instagram sortiert dir ja, du kannst ja so kleinere Kreise diese Story nur an
meinen inneren Kreis und so weiter zeigen.
Warum es keine Public, mein Account ist prinzipiell privat,
aber die zehn Highlights von mir, also die Sachen, die ich danach auswähle für
irgendeine Dating-Profil-App oder so, die Reisefotos, dein Instagram,
dass man so einen leichten Nachvollzug, ohne dass es zu deutlich wird,
warum es nicht so eine Semi-Public-Timeline gibt, obwohl es trotzdem prinzipiell
auf Privat eingestellt ist. Ja.
So wie bei Mastodon, dass ich einfach in dem Moment, wo ich schreibe,
sage ich, ist es öffentlich, nur für Freunde oder und so weiter.
Das wundert mich bei Instagram, weil das ist eigentlich noch so dieser letzte
Schritt, der Instagram wirklich zum lebendigen Adressbuch für die ganze Welt
macht. Wo man einfach nachschaut, geht es dem gut?
Was macht er denn? Hast du ein Instagram? Ja, dann folge ich dir schon mal und
so weiter. Das sind noch so Rätsel irgendwie.
Wir hören mal weiter. Wir können aber vielleicht schon mal festhalten,
also der Aufstieg von Instagram oder dass wir da jetzt von einer kritischen Infrastruktur reden,
wie die Gesellschaft braucht, hat vielleicht auch zur Folge,
dass es den Dating-Apps derart schlecht geht.
Denn wir können das auch ausdrücken in einem Börsenwert.
Diese Matchgroup, zu der noch ganz viele weitere Apps gehören, die Dating-App,
das Dating-App-Unternehmen schlechthin ist, das war zu Pandemiezeiten,
war der Aktienpreis bei etwa 130 Dollar.
Der ist jetzt noch bei etwa 30 Dollar. Also extrem in den Keller gegangen.
Trotzdem, kleine Anmerkung, du hast jetzt kritische Infrastruktur gesagt,
ich habe wesentliche Einrichtungen gesagt. Das sind ja zwei ganz große Unterschiede.
Auf die kritische Infrastruktur können wir nicht verzichten.
Und wir wollen auch, dass sie staatlich geschützt ist.
Eine wesentliche Einrichtung im Sinne des Kartellrechts, wo diese Formulierung
so drinsteht, ist ja eine Brücke über einen Tal,
bei dem es keinen Sinn macht, noch eine zweite Brücke als Konkurrenz daneben
zu bauen, sondern wenn man über das Tal will, obwohl man es nicht muss, nimmt man diesen Weg.
Da sehe ich Instagram, wie Amazon ja auch. Ja. Also, wenn es ausfällt,
klar, dann müssen wir halt alle zu Galeria Kaufhof oder vor Ort oder wie auch immer gehen.
Also es darf ruhig ausfallen und niemand stirbt. Aber wenn man es nutzen möchte,
macht es manchmal keinen Sinn, zu viel Konkurrenz zu haben.
Weil dann weiß man nicht, wo ist denn jetzt mein Anknüpfungspunkt,
sondern dieser Log-In-Effekt, den hat Instagram ja eigentlich schon ganz gut drin.
So, man weiß, Instagram ist eigentlich der Place to go und der Rest ist dann so beiwärts.
In a group of men who were exactly my type. A.k.a. Hinge just pushing guys who
went to Ivy's and worked in corporate America.
But these days, Hinge puts those people behind a paywall. Because it doesn't
actually want to be the app that you delete. That's a horrible business strategy.
So it's going to make it a lot more difficult for you to get off the app.
And that's where the Rose system comes in.
Where it identifies the people you would most want to match with,
tempts you with their existence, but puts them behind a paywall so you have
to spend more money to even talk to them.
Because selling your data isn't enough. It wants you to spend as much money
as possible to find people you would actually like. Which, in my opinion,
doesn't even end up working,
Das.
Ist das Geschäftsmodell dieser ganzen Dating-Apps, dass es zwar einen Gratiszugang
gibt, aber man doch nicht allzu viel damit machen kann. Entweder wird begrenzt,
wie viele Profile man anklicken kann, wie viele Nachrichten man verschicken kann.
Aber, und das ist ja auch interessant, dass sie hier die Vermutung äußert,
dass also die App wusste, welcher Typ ihr gefällt und dass man deshalb sagt, die,
die sie attraktiv findet, die verlegen wir mal lieber hinter die Paywall,
dass sie dafür zahlen muss.
Und da gibt es ja Paywall-Modelle, die sehr weit in die Höhe gehen.
Wir werden da gleich noch Zahlen hören.
Es ist also ein sehr großes Geschäft mit der Einsamkeit, beziehungsweise ja
mit der Frage auch, wie viel Geld bist du bereit auszugeben,
um an jemanden zu kommen.
Das kann ja entweder Liebe fürs Leben oder Sex sein. Nein.
Und ich fühlte mich gleich an Michel Houellebecq, erinnert an sein erstes Buch
Ausweitung der Kampfzone.
Das ist schon fast 30 Jahre alt. Und da äußerte er die These,
dass wir in Zukunft in einer Gesellschaft leben werden, in der nur noch die
Leute, die Geld haben, Sex haben können.
Und in gewisser Weise sehen wir diese Entwicklung hier bei den Dating-Apps.
Jordan Peterson betont das ja auch immer wieder. Es gibt keinen kostenlosen
Sex. Irgendwo kostet es immer.
Und je nachdem haben die einen mehr oder andere Ressourcen, um da halt rein zu investieren.
Aber man kommt nicht drum rum. Ich will trotzdem nochmal, weil du jetzt Einsamkeit
gesagt hast, Dating, wie soll ich sagen,
Esther Perel, die von mir geschätzte, wir haben sie auch schon häufiger gespielt,
Paar-Therapeutin, die ja so einen eigenen Podcast macht, Wer schuld wie Beginn,
hat kürzlich mit Karis Wischer und Scott Galloway ein Therapiegespräch geführt
über deren berufliche Beziehung.
Sie ist eine lesbische Frau und er ist ein Alphatier-Mann, der aber mit so ein
paar Unsicherheitskompensationen da einfach sich auf die Bühne gespielt hat.
Und Issa Perel beginnt den Podcast, indem sie kurz bevor sie die beiden im Gespräch
hat, sagt, ich bin eine Paartherapeutin, aber ich habe den Begriff des Paares entgrenzt.
Auch Menschen, die auf der Arbeit zu zweit zusammenarbeiten und wie in so einem
Podcast, bei denen mit Werbeverträgen hier und so, so eine Schicksalsgemeinschaft.
Das sind ein paar, können also nicht einfach nur in so Satzung klären,
wie sie miteinander arbeiten, sondern müssen da so ein paar Beziehungsfragen klären.
So, und da dachte ich so, ja, das ist eigentlich interessant,
denn man kann auf der Suche nach einer Liebesbeziehung sein.
Obwohl man sich eigentlich gar nicht einsam fühlt, weil man den ganzen Tag zu
tun hat mit irgendwelchen anderen Paarbeziehungen, die man so hat.
Auch Freundschaften, Familie und so weiter. Eigentlich fehlt einem nichts.
Es ist jedenfalls nicht die Einsamkeit, die einen treibt, sondern dann noch
so dieses letzte Gefühl der Ähnlichkeit oder wie auch immer.
Genauso gut kann man in einer super stabilen, festen Partnerschaft sein,
Die von Kindern überladen und die Aufgaben türmen sich und man denkt sich so,
ich hätte gerne noch so eine andere Beziehung.
So, warum gibt es dafür keine Dating-App? Ich habe jetzt Bumble genannt,
wo so Freundschaften ausgeflaggt werden, wo es nochmal ganz konkret darum geht,
ich habe Donnerstag 18 bis 20 Uhr Zeit und Mark Zuckerberg hat mir immer versprochen,
dass ich im Internet abseits meines Milieus, in dem ich mich konkret befinde,
eine Schicksalsgemeinschaft finde, mit der ich mein Nerdy-Kram austoben kann.
Wo ist denn diese Möglichkeit?
So, und da finde ich, also wenn jetzt die Paartherapeuten den Paarbegriff entgrenzen,
können auch mal die Dating-Apps das Matching, unter welchen Gesichtspunkten
wird ja eigentlich Match gesucht,
so ein bisschen entgrenzen, aber bisher gibt es da nur Liebe für immer oder
Freundschaft, so bei Bumble,
aber so darüber hinaus gibt es irgendwie noch kein großes.
Naja, woran mag das liegen? Das liegt zum einen daran, dass das Geschäftsmodell
nun mal dieses ist und zum anderen liegt es daran, dass diese Apps ja nur mit
ästhetischen Reizen arbeiten.
Also du kannst ja nur Leute.
Die aber ausverschbar werden, finde ich. Es haben alle ihre kleinen Spleens,
die sie da vermarkten können.
Ja, natürlich. Das mag ja sein. Nur du entscheidest ja, also wenn wir jetzt
davon reden, Freundschaft oder Menschen mit gemeinsamen Interessen,
die ein gewisses Zeitfenster die Woche miteinander teilen.
Da spielen ja ästhetische Fragen eine untergeordnete oder gar keine Rolle.
Kommst du den Bildern relativ nicht weiter.
Beim Dating, ja da sagt man ja nicht, oh ja, ist 1,80, wird genau richtig sein,
interessiert sich bestimmt auch für Streichquartette, sondern das sind ja ganz
andere Fragen, die sich da stellen.
Und hier geht es ja nur um eine äußerliche Attraktivität und äußerlich wirklich
auch nur auf ein Foto reduziert. Also Attraktivität im Sinne von, wie tritt man auf?
All das spielt ja auch eine Rolle eigentlich, gehört zur Attraktivität dazu.
Also hier ist es nur auf das Bild.
Wir waren ja in der Zauberflöte, Tamino singt dieses Bild und es ist bezaubernd
schön, mehr nicht. Mehr gibt es nicht.
Also es gibt, ich habe mich gerade erinnert, eine App, die heißt Meet5.
Die kommt hier so aus dem Rhein-Main-Gebiet. Und da tummeln sich so die Boomer.
Wie heißt die?
Meet5.
Und da muss man gleich fünf treffen? Nein.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen das Prinzip, weil man flackt eine Veranstaltung
aus, zu der man nicht gerne hin würde, aber will nicht alleine hingehen.
Und dann ist aber der komplette Veranstaltungskalender der Stadt oder so.
Aber es ist keine Orgie?
Nee, es ist eben nicht sexuell orientiert, sondern man trifft sich dann,
um genau das zu machen. Also Wandern ist natürlich das Einfachste,
aber es gibt irgendwelche Museenbesuche oder so und da fragen wir,
will jemand mit in die Schirn?
Ja, ja, ja.
Das ist jetzt Hip-Hop. Also geht man dann dahin. So verabredet sich halt zu fünft oder mehr.
Ja. Wir hören jetzt mal Wall Street
Journal. Die haben mal ihre Hörer so gefragt, was die zu Dating sagen.
Being a woman in Los Angeles, I filtered for Zodiac signs. It feels so mindless. It's choice overload.
One of the things that I really like about the apps is kind of the options it gives you.
Options in a sense of kind of looking outside your social circles.
And I also filtered for some lifestyle factors.
I didn't want to be with someone who smoked, since I'm allergic to smoke.
Was ich nicht mag an Dating-Apps ist, dass ich glaube, dass es mich macht,
mehr schallig zu machen, als ich es in Person machen würde.
Eine andere Sache, die ich wirklich nicht mag an den Apps ist,
dass die Anzüge gut sind, aber die Anzüge sind seltsam.
Was wir erleben bei den Dating-Apps ist, dass eigentlich nur die Welt,
wie wir sie vorfinden, nochmal nachgebaut wird.
Also die ganz tollen, da muss man Geld für ausgeben, da kommt man hinter die
Paywall, da muss man in die teuren Diskotheken gehen, in die teuren Restaurants gehen.
Also so wird das ja alles dort gearbeitet und dann gibt es ja so einen großen
Gleichmacher, das ist nämlich die ungerechte Natur.
Die verteilt irgendwelche Attribute, die als schön empfunden werden,
völlig ungleich und ungerecht, wenn man so möchte, aber dadurch sind dem alle so ausgesetzt.
Also da hilft auch das dickste Portemonnaie nicht, wenn du am Ende nur die Möglichkeit
hast, ein Bild von dir zu zeigen.
Also du kannst natürlich dann auf diesem Bild gewisse Insignien mit ausstellen
und sagen, seht her, ich habe Geld, ich kann damit irgendetwas anderes kompensieren.
Aber zunächst einmal ist also diese ästhetische Komponente, die als allererstes
da ist, etwas, was in gewisser Weise einen Gleichmacher produziert.
Also das ist so wie mit Richard Gere, American Gigolo, der einfach so gut aussieht,
eigentlich kein Geld in der Tasche hat, aber als American Gigolo findet er dann
dort Zugang zu den reichsten Frauen.
Und das ist natürlich hier auf dieser Ebene auch sehr gut möglich.
Aber wir hören uns mal an, was das dann alles so kosten kann.
The more people pay attention to you, the more you pay. Most people on dating apps don't pay.
But about a third of users say they have.
Prices on the apps range from a few dollars a month to a couple hundred for
apps that market themselves as being more exclusive, like Raya and The League.
Also mehrere hundert Euro ist man
bereit auszugeben. Es ist vielleicht ein bisschen wie mit dem Apple Shop.
Ich glaube, da gibt es auch solche Berechnungen, dass im Prinzip 10% der Leute
fast den größten Gewinn alles ausgeben.
Also es gibt Leute, die geben Tausende dort aus. Und es gibt jemand,
der kauft einmal was für drei Euro im Monat dort.
Und so scheint es auch dort zu sein. Wir hören mal weiter.
Ja,
ich denke, wir sind da. Es gab ein großes Forschungsstudium von Pew,
das zeigt, dass die Anzahl der Amerikaner, die Dating-App-User benutzen,
in drei Jahren nicht größer ist.
Das ist eine wirklich schreckliche Statistik für die Dating-Industrie.
Es gab einen Zeitpunkt, sogar nur zwei, drei Jahre ago, 2019,
in dem Tinder 43% Revenue-Groß war. Und was ist es jetzt? Zerr.
Und man versucht jetzt durch immer höhere Abo-Preise dann wieder Geld reinzuholen.
Die haben dann den CFO von der Match Group interviewt und das ist doch sehr
interessant, was er da sagt.
Von einer großen Plattform wie Tinder ist, wie ich in der Gruppe stehen kann.
Und indem du etwas bezahlst, hast du die Möglichkeit, in der Gruppe zu stehen,
was wert ist, wenn du Erfolg haben willst.
Und wir bieten dir diese Möglichkeit, um eine bessere Chance zu haben, diesen Erfolg zu haben.
Kannst du dir jemals garantieren, dass jemand Liebe finden wird,
wenn er mehr Geld spart? Nein, und das ist eine Unterschiede zwischen einem
Uber oder Amazon und einer Dating-Plattform.
Wenn du auf Uber gehst, hast du eine 99%-Chance.
Also ich habe auch darüber nachgedacht. Eigentlich ist es crazy,
wie viele dann doch sagen, dass sie sich über Dating-Apps kennengelernt haben.
Denn die Wahrscheinlichkeit, ich habe es ja schon häufiger mal thematisiert,
es ist aus allen Richtungen immer wieder, man kann sich nicht vorstellen,
wie groß die Gesellschaft tatsächlich ist.
Wir haben das mal bei TikTok durchgerechnet. Also wenn man 90 Minuten,
was die Deutschen ja machen, TikTok am Tag nutzt und ein Video geht 5 Sekunden
oder so, dann ist man ja bei 1000 Videos.
Die muss man ja erstmal, wenn man jetzt in Profilen denkt, die man nach rechts
und links swipet, Also tausend ist ganz schön viel.
So, das ist ja so, als würde man in Frankfurt über die Zeil gehen und es kommen
ja dann samstags wirklich tausend Leute entgegen.
So, das ist schon mal eine recht große Grundgesamtheit, die im Vergleich zur
ganzen Stadt doch verschwindend gering ist.
Aber man hat erstmal eine Grundgesamtheit.
Und dann innerhalb der, jetzt habe ich gerade Zeit zu swipen,
muss ja die Gegenseite auch gerade resonant irgendwie jetzt nicht im Urlaub
und dann ist sie tagelang nicht da oder wie auch immer oder so.
Diese Swipes verfliegen ja dann auch wieder. Also dieses Matching ist so unwahrscheinlich.
Das ist mir jetzt wieder aufgefallen.
Wir gucken abends manchmal diese First Dates Sendung.
Das ist bei Vox, ja. Ich wollte erst schon Clips mitbringen,
dann dachte ich, du kennst das, aber da können wir so drüber sprechen.
Mir war die Sendung völlig unbekannt. Die läuft aber seit sechs Jahren.
Das ist so wie das perfekte Dinner, so ein Dauerbrenner ist,
so ist das da auch. Sehr günstig produziert, man ist da in einem Restaurant.
Es gibt da den Concierge oder Chef des Restaurants, der steht dann so da beim Empfang.
Und dann kommt jemand an, kommt eine Frau und sagt, ja, hallo.
Ja, und wie muss dann dein Typ aussehen? Und dann sagt die irgendwie,
ja, er sollte auf jeden Fall einen Bart haben und er muss lustig sein und so weiter.
Dann nimmt sie Platz und dann kommt der nächste, kommt dann ein Mann an,
den man dann für sie ausgesucht hat, manchmal passt es, manchmal passt das dann
nicht und dann erleben die so ein Abendessen, das ist also dann in gekürzter
Form wie beim perfekten Dinner auch.
Ich glaube, die haben so 90 Minuten dort, damit ausreichend Material anfällt,
um acht Minuten daraus zu senden.
Ja, richtig.
So ungefähr.
Und dann merkt man so, ah ja, die kommen nicht zusammen oder er flirtet sie
an und sie zeigt ihm die kalte Schulter.
Und das ist so erfolgreich, dass es schon wieder, ich glaube,
der heißt Cedric oder so, es gibt bei YouTube ein Format, das nur diese Sendung zum Thema hat.
Also der macht jeden Tag Reaction-Videos nur zu dieser Sendung und erreicht
damit 100.000, 200.000 Leute.
Das Interessante ist jetzt, also es ist so, wie du beschreibst, es ist eine...
Ein Fernsehstudio, das also aussieht wie ein Restaurant und es wird einmal komplett
die Restaurantsituation nachgespielt.
Die Leute kommen als ganz normale Leute rein, Kameras sind ein bisschen versteckt
und sie müssen ihr Essen auch bezahlen und es ist nochmal das Highlight dann
jeder Auflösung, wer lädt wen ein und so.
Nur man sitzt so da und dann irgendwann fällt einem auf, krass,
es kommen doch relativ selten Paare dabei rum.
Also ich sage mal, drei Paare pro Sendung. Und man muss schon so zehn Sendungen
gucken, damit mal so ein, zwei Paare hängenbleiben.
Und nicht nur, sie haben sich dann doch aus den Augen verloren oder wie auch
immer. Also es ist wirklich selten.
Das war wie bei Herzblatt früher. Das war ja die ARD-Sendung da mit Rudi Carell.
Genau.
Und da sind die auch immer mit dem Herzblatt-Hubschrauber in ein schönes Wochenende.
Aber das wird ja noch gestaltet von vorne bis hinten. Da wird ja nicht moderiert und nichts.
Da steht ja nur passiv die Kamera dabei Und außer, dass man begrüßt wird beim
Reinkommen, was willst du für einen Drink haben, also eine Gesprächssituation,
bis das Match da ist und so, also der Datingpartner.
So, und die interessante Beobachterposition ist jetzt, ich sitze da und sehe
Menschen in der Hoffnung, erstmal, dass es interessant ist, aber natürlich auch
immer so ein bisschen matchen die mal.
Verlieben die sich. Genau.
Ich sitze aber gleichzeitig als Zuschauer davor und frage mich die ganze Zeit,
matchen die eigentlich mit mir?
Also ich schätze ja die ganze Zeit ein, finde ich das Paar eigentlich interessant oder nicht?
Und es ist ganz verrückt, dass eigentlich 98% der Paare für mich als Zuschauer
total uninteressant sind. Die kommen da rein, die spielen ihr Muster durch.
Die zweite Frage nach dem Name ist, was hast du für Hobbys?
Was machst du beruflich? Der ganze Kram. Und wenn es so losgeht,
denkt man ja schon, okay, das verläuft im Sande. Die wissen jetzt schon,
okay, 90 Minuten essen, warum nicht und so. Wir bringen das jetzt so durch.
Und wenn man das so schaut, stellt man wieder fest, okay, es gibt nicht nur
das Matching in der Sendung, sondern auch Matching, die mit mir.
Würde ich jetzt gerne bei denen am Tisch sitzen oder wie auch immer.
Und das ist genauso selten, wie die sich dort matchen.
Also das Matching selbst ist so unwahrscheinlich, so selten,
dass man sich eigentlich fragen muss, müssen die nicht die ganzen Dating-Apps
nochmal grundauf neu konzipieren, weil der Ansatz, den man jetzt macht,
der funktioniert einfach nicht.
Wir kriegen gleich Vorschläge. Es ist aber schon mal sehr gut,
dass du diese Sendung aufrufst, weil ich genau das Gefühl auch hatte,
was wäre, wenn ich da am Tisch sitzen würde?
Noch gar nicht mit irgendeinem Dating vorhaben, sondern einfach nur, ich müsste dabei sein.
Und ich denke, um Gottes Willen, was soll ich da reden? Gut,
ich könnte dann den Alleinunterhalter machen und würde nochmal alles aus dem
Hut zaubern. Und das ist so selten. Und das ist ja schlimm.
Leute sich einfach mal zutrauen, lustig zu sein. Es gab jetzt ein Pärchen,
von dem ich denke, das würde ich mir gerne nochmal angucken,
weil das einfach so ein ganz spielerischer Umgang, wo du gleich gesehen hast,
Ist egal, was er für Hobbys hat. Es ist egal, was sie beruflich macht.
Es ist einfach, das funktioniert so. Aber das ist so selten.
Also in deren Sicht ist diese Sendung, sie ist sehr charmant gestaltet.
Ja. Aber sie lässt einen doch sehr, sehr, sehr ratlos zurück.
Ja.
Was jetzt die Dating-Frage angeht.
Sie stellt das nicht zur Schau. Es gibt ja diese ganz schlimmen Dating-Veranstaltungen,
Naked Attraction, wo die dann sich erst nackt sehen und später kommt erst das Gesicht dazu.
Also wie das, glaube ich, jetzt dann wohl bei Bumble inzwischen sich gestaltet
hat. Also das gibt es natürlich auch.
Aber das ist eigentlich eine Sendung, die da nicht in dieser Art voyeuristisch ist.
Und ich glaube, man muss auch nochmal so deutlich machen, also wir werden jetzt
nachher über Einsamkeit oder so sprechen.
Ich würde aber auch nochmal so hinzufügen wollen,
dass natürlich aufgrund dieser Dating-Apps und auch deren Marktmacht und auch
aufgrund von sehr vielen Narrativen,
die so da sind, haben wir so eine gesellschaftliche Sicht darauf,
dass Leute, die allein sind, dass denen grundsätzlich was fehlt.
Und da würde ich dem deutlich widersprechen.
Also es mag Leute geben, die allein sind und denen fehlt was und die sollten dann daran was ändern.
Aber es ist nicht so, dass man, also man ist nicht das Kugelwesen,
dass da die andere Hälfte nur noch nicht gefunden ist unbedingt.
Aber vor allen Dingen sollte man sich vielleicht doch dafür hüten,
allzu viel Geld auszugeben.
Wir hören jetzt nochmal diesen CFO, glaube ich, ist das dann,
also wir hören jetzt mal von diesen highly motivated daters.
Untertitelung des ZDF für funk, 2017,
So they're looking at basically charging people who already pay more.
And I'm talking like $500 a month, which is just like to me an absurd number.
It's like the elite class. It's like first class.
Yeah. So I talked to this pricing expert, just trying to figure out like who
in God's name would pay that much to use Tinder, which is like,
you know, kind of known as like a hookup app.
And he was saying that like basically there's a certain number of people in
the world who like would pay for anything just for the status.
Die Amex-Kreditkarte, die ich nicht habe, über die ich mich trotzdem informiert
habe, aus Recherchegründen.
Gibt dir Zugang zu allen Flughafen- und DB-Lounges, Ermäßigung bei allen möglichen
Kram, die du so kaufst, Reiseversicherung und alles Mögliche.
Aber schon dann so eine teure wahrscheinlich.
Naja, die deckt sehr viel ab. Es gibt, sie hat jetzt die Platinum genannt,
die hat nur einen Standardpreis und das sind 60 Euro im Monat. 60, nicht 600.
Für eine Dating-App, die mir 500 Euro abzockt, verlange ich,
jeden Samstag steht mir die DB-Lounge oder die Flughafen-Lounge von der Lufthansa
oder irgendwas was offen, irgendwas, wo man richtig hingehen kann,
wo man weiß, da sind jetzt ganz viele, die wissen auch, dass das ist,
man trägt so ein Erkennungszeichen oder wie auch immer.
Also dafür müssten wirklich Räume erschlossen werden und man ist dann vor Ort.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das im Angebot ist.
Nee, das glaube ich auch nicht. Man findet dort die attraktivsten oder irgendwelche Prominenten.
Man sieht die, die halt total verwahrlost und ich brauche jetzt mal das Geld
deswegen und so weiter, die in der Lage sind, das zu bezahlen.
Ja, aber dieser ökonomische Status beim beim Daten, der scheint ja ganz, ganz wichtig zu sein.
Also das ist jetzt, also dieses Modell funktioniert ja folgendermaßen. Es wird,
1% oder 0,5% wird es geben, die so verrückt sind und 500 Dollar ausgeben und
sie auch ausgeben können und die machen das.
Und dadurch haben die natürlich wahnsinnig gewonnen, wenn man das so sieht.
Aber generell, dass der ökonomische Status so gleich schon dadurch abgefragt
wird, das scheint etwas zu sein, warum ja Leute extrem viel Geld ausgeben,
um in irgendwelche Clubs reinzukommen.
Das war doch, diese Fußballer in München, die sind dann immer in dieses P1 gegangen
und dann waren die Frauen da, weil sie wussten, dort können sie den finden und
das ist dann ein Investment.
Also wenn man den Millionär geangelt hat, dann haben sie auch die 500 Euro gelohnt.
Das nennt man ein Return on Investment, weil wenn du 500 Euro im Monat übrig
hast, fährst du bestimmt auch ein Auto, das dich 2000 Euro Leasing kostet.
Wahrscheinlich.
So, das bedeutet, mit dem Auto bist du aber die ganze Zeit irgendwo.
Das ist ja diese tolle Korrelation, die ja in Deutschland ganz wunderbar funktioniert.
Du hast eine riesige flächendeckende Vereinsamung, sodass dieser eine Erfurter
Einsamkeitsbeauftragte von dieser einen Genossenschaft,
ich hatte diesen Clip bei Twitter, ich reformuliere jetzt nur,
gefragt wird vom Deutschlandfunk, was sind denn so ihre Erfahrungen?
Und er sagt in dem allerersten Satz, mich rufen Leute an, die so einsam sind,
dass sie Angst haben, die Sprache zu verlieren.
Das ist der Ausgangspunkt, der korreliert ganz hart mit Armut.
Sobald du Geld hast, verbringst du deine Zeit nicht zu Hause,
sondern du bist überall.
Du erschließt dir so eine ganze Stadt, du hängst in den Bars rum,
du gehst Golf spielen und so weiter und so fort.
Du hast, wenn du dazu noch irgendwie in unternehmerischer Verantwortung bist,
ein Abendtermin nach dem anderen, wo die ganze Zeit Matching,
Ausprobieren, Kennenlernen, Netzwerking stattfindet und so weiter.
Wenn du da ein Dating-Problem entwickelst, in der Riege, dass es dir 500 Euro
wert ist, für eine Dating-Plattform auszugeben, findest du, glaube ich, nicht die Leute da.
Die du kennenlernen willst, sondern dann stimmt irgendwas mit dir nicht und
mit den anderen aber auch. Ja, das würde ich auch unterstreichen. Leute irgendwie.
Ich habe ja schon mal darüber nachgedacht, ob diese ganzen Restriktionen am
Arbeitsplatz, dass also man am Arbeitsplatz nicht flirten darf,
sich keine Paare bilden soll, wie das in den USA ganz, ganz stark ist.
Aber das spielt ja diesen Dating-Apps in die Hände. Also du kannst ja genau
dann, was du jetzt gerade beschrieben hast, nicht herstellen,
weil das alles geschäftlich ist und das Das darf auf keinen Fall auf eine andere
Ebene führen und deswegen brauchst du dann die Dating-App und auch noch die teure,
um dann, obwohl du schon den ganzen Tag nur mit Juristen es zu tun hattest und
da hättest du jemanden kennenlernen, musst du jetzt nochmal 500 Euro ausgeben,
um auch wieder Juristen auf der Plattform zu finden.
Ja, das wiederum ist gerade einer der größten, müsste eigentlich auch mal ein
eigenes Thema hier sein, einer der größten Shifts in der sozialen Welt überhaupt,
dass nach dieser Homeoffice-Welle, die ja nicht wieder abäppte,
wir haben ja heute noch einen Straßenverkehr, der immer noch gedimmter ist im
Vergleich zu vor Corona und so, dass die Unternehmen,
selbst wenn sie ganz mutig sind, maximal drei Tage die Woche Arbeiten vor Ort
wieder einfordern, weil sie wissen, zurück zu fünf Tagen kommen wir nie.
Und die Argumentation und da wird es wirklich brenzlig mittlerweile.
Bislang war es so, wir haben beklagt, dass Unternehmen alles nur noch nach Stechuhr machen.
Dass Amazon die Leute, jeder Schritt, der da gemacht wird und so wird ausgewertet,
jede Pause, alles wird verboten, alles ist restriktiv.
Jetzt, über die Branchen hinweg, stellen die Unternehmen fest,
kommt mal zurück ins Büro. Warum?
Gespräche in der Küche, Nachwehen von Meetings, irgendwelche Pausengestaltung
und so weiter. Die stellen sich auch gerade ganz viele Matching-Fragen.
Nicht ein Unternehmen hat in irgendeinem Punkt, von dem ich jetzt mitbekommen
habe, wenn man das so nachliest, irgendwas von, ja, dann kannst du besser arbeiten,
besser schneller tippen oder wie auch immer.
Es geht nur um diese Softie-Seiten, die bisher immer verlacht wurden,
wo es immer hieß, ach, diese Gewerkschaftsthemen und so, das ist doch alles lächerlich.
So, und jetzt stellen die Unternehmen fest, das ist die eigentliche Produktivität.
Dieses spontane, zufällige Matching, ausprobieren irgendwas,
soziale Landkarte gestalten, aber bloß nicht arbeiten. Arbeiten können die weiter im Homeoffice.
Die sollen ins Büro kommen, um da mal wieder und so weiter die Funken sprühen zu lassen.
So und das ist ganz nah an diesem Thema, was hier verhandelt wird.
Du hast jetzt schon Optimierungsvorschläge gemacht.
Wie müssten Dating-Apps sein? Es gibt schon Innovationen. Wir hören hier mal uns eine an.
It lets users upload their first conversation for free. Then it charges $5 to
analyze additional chats.
According to its founder, within a week of launching, 30,000 people gave the
app access to their iMessage history.
So, um das zu erklären, ich habe mir die Seite auch da angesehen.
Du lädst dann diesen Chat da komplett hoch und dann werten die den aus und dann
glaubt man daraufhin, ein Persönlichkeitsprofil zu erstellen.
Wir hatten hier mal diesen 16 Personality Test, der der sowohl beim Dating als
auch beim Recruiting von Arbeitskräften eine Rolle spielt.
Und nach einem ähnlichen Schema läuft das dort auch.
Also meine Freundin und ich, wir haben uns die WhatsApp-Chats,
die wir hatten, die lassen sich ja sehr leicht exportieren für solche Analysen.
Auch exportieren lassen und sie hatte mich dann überrascht mit, das in Bücher zu binden.
Und das sind 20 Bände?
Das sind zwei etwas umfangreichere Bände geworden.
Also viel. Ungefähr so wie die Alten Republik, nur halt nicht so eng gesetzt.
Das wäre schon interessant, das mal an so eine AI-App zu geben,
damit die einem irgendwas sagt dazu.
Und hast du es deinem Verlag schon angeboten?
Nein, das ist natürlich, wir haben darüber gescherzt, dass wir das natürlich
nur als Buch machen, das eine Auflage hat, aber halt 10.000 Euro kostet.
Also wer wissen will, wie Stefan Schulz ein Matching hinkriegt,
könnte das dann da nachlesen für den locker flockigen Preis von 10.000 Euro.
Das hat, glaube ich, doch Wolf von Traschek mal gemacht.
Er hat einen Roman geschrieben und hat den für 50.000 Euro, glaube ich.
Ja, weil du das erwähnt hattest, kam ich drauf und da haben wir so ein bisschen darüber umgeschatzt.
Ja.
Und ist natürlich nicht zu kaufen für 10.000 Euro. Ihr müsst Müsst eigene Angebote machen.
Hast du gut gegen Nordwind gelesen?
Ja, ja, ja. Weißt du warum? Weil mir das ein Tinder-Match damals empfohlen hatte, das zu lesen.
Ja. Hab ich gelesen. Nun haben wir es ja damit mit einem Autor zu tun,
der die Intention hat, jetzt so einen Roman zu schreiben.
Aber hier gab es jetzt keine Intention, ein Buch draus zu machen.
Richtig.
Insofern ist das das interessantere Buch. Also ich würde es fast kaufen.
Ja, ganz genau. Ganz genau. Es ist sozusagen gleich mit dem Stehen.
Es ist nicht ein Autor, der sich beides, und es passt dann schon am Ende,
sondern es ist tatsächlich, es stehen ja auch die Daten noch drin.
Also man kann richtig sehen, auch wie lange war denn Pause zwischen einzelnen Texten und so.
Ja und dass es nicht darauf hinaus ist.
Also der Preis ist jetzt auf eine Million gestiegen übrigens.
Also ich finde es richtig gut, weil man hat ja im inneren Auge,
hat man einen Leser, wenn man ein Buch schreibt.
Oder man sagt, das will ich unbedingt mal gesagt haben, aber man weiß schon,
das ist für die Öffentlichkeit. Und jedes ist nur für das Gegenüber.
Und wenn man aber diesen Text zu lesen bekäme, das wäre interessant,
wie dann so ein Schreiben ist.
Oder ob man da vielleicht doch erkennt, da ist schon was intendiert,
gibt es noch einen größeren anderen, den man da auch mit adressiert oder so.
Da gehen wir Literaturwissenschaftler dann wieder ran.
Das ist besser als True Crime.
Ja, also jetzt hast du uns richtig, naja. Wir gehen mal weiter.
Was kann man noch machen jetzt in Zukunft?
So, Users can take either a downloaded WhatsApp file or connect it to their
iCloud and then pick a contact name.
And the AI analyzes the entire conversation.
I mean, that could be long and it could include a lot of things.
What about maybe audio files or pictures that you've sent? Yeah.
According to the founder, Alex Weizmann, the analysis is text only.
So the only thing that enters their servers and subsequently gets removed from
their servers is the text in each of the conversations.
From there, a very sassy AI readout comes out and you'll get on a scale of 1
to 100% your compatibility with your ex.
And then broken down into categories rated 1 to 10.
And it will rate your attachment styles and how they align your communication,
sexiness and then like highlights and lowlights of the relationship,
which is realistically just the conversation.
Man glaubt, man könnte die Liebe in der Art berechenbar machen.
Also das kann man in dem Fall selber machen. Wir haben jetzt hier das nächste
große Jahrhundertproblem.
Problem, damals, Google ist ja noch letztes Jahr 198 gegründet,
egal was man im Internet benutzt, es gibt nur zwei Search-Indexes.
Den von Google und den von Microsoft.
Ja gut, und den von DuckDuckGo, aber der spielt jetzt keine Rolle.
Das ist hier auch. Man kann einfach selber für 20 Euro im Monat sich Gemini
oder GPT buchen und dann kann man den einfach beauftragen, machen wir eine Psychoanalyse dazu.
Hier vermarktet einfach einer einen Wrapper oder einen GPT, wie wir heute sagen,
weil da stehen ja nur ein paar sozusagen Paradigma-Prompts drin.
Steht auch auf der Homepage so, dass es ein GPT ist.
Naja, siehste. Also dann ist es ein Geschäftsmodell, das jetzt gerade mal gut
funktioniert für drei Wochen Fernsehberichterstattung und 10.000 Kunden, die das buchen.
Aber das ist die große Gefahr. Wer das AI-Race jetzt gewinnt,
der wird alles inklusive sowas verkaufen.
Und ich bin mal gespannt, wie Apple damit umgeht, weil die grinsen ja immer
schon so, wenn sie auf AI angesprochen werden.
Nur da erwarte ich ja irgendwie, dass das wirklich mittendrin ist.
Also die Notiz-App, die Mail-App, die Kalender-App und so weiter,
die haben Zugriff auf alles.
Versprechen dann das große Privacy-Versprechen, so wie immer und sagen dir dann
noch, frag einfach nach deiner psychischen Gesundheit.
Ich bin mal sehr gespannt. Und wir haben ja von Alena Büx gehört.
Die therapeutischen Apps fand sie ja sehr gut. Die als Dialogpartner,
die ja aus irgendwelchen kleinen Krisen helfen.
Also in der Hinsicht, das Geschäftsmodell von ihm ist Schrott,
aber ich glaube, das ist ein Riesending demnächst, dass man da so anfängt,
sein Profil sich selbst gewahr zu machen und so.
Gerade bei der Frage, woran ist es gescheitert?
Das treibt ja alle um in der Lage.
Ja, aber zu glauben, man könne das so nachvollziehen, das ist ja tatsächlich
so ein literaturwissenschaftliches Vorgehen, das man dann auf sein ganzes Leben
anwenden will und will seine Persönlichkeit daraus kristallisieren und auch noch Attraktivitäten.
Ja, aber du hast ja eben kritisiert, dass da Einsamkeit vermarktet wird.
Hier geht es ja nicht nur um Einsamkeit, sondern die absolute Hilflosigkeit
wird ja hier zu Geld gemacht.
Und in deren Sicht ist das natürlich, für die Leute, die buchen das dann einfach.
Dass man glaubt, auch noch dabei Hilfe zu haben.
Also dass man noch jemanden braucht, also noch eine Assistenzfunktion braucht,
die einem dann sagt, ja, ihr findet euch attraktiv.
Also wenn es ja etwas gibt, was man sofort weiß, dann ob man jemanden attraktiv findet.
Vielleicht stellt sich manches schon mal später ein durch ein längeres Gespräch
oder so oder lässt dann auch wieder nach.
Aber diese Sachen muss ich ja nicht nochmal mir von einer App erzählen lassen.
Das sagst du so, in deinem, mein Alltag läuft smooth dahin und so weiter.
Du hast ja gerade keine Lebenskrise und sowas.
Ja, ja.
Leute sind anders drauf, wenn sie anderes erleben.
Und mal weiter.
Das erlaubt jedem, dass sie die Gespräche nicht halten und dass sie nur Texte
aus diesen Gesprächen analysieren.
Und vermutlich sind deine sensiblen Bilder und Audio-Noten komplett überwacht von der AI.
Ja, das kommt dann auch noch. Da kann man also dann noch Bilder einspielen.
Also da wird noch vieles kommen.
Eine andere Sache ist ein Dating-Coach, eine App, eine Dating-App,
die noch so einen Coach anbietet.
Denn es ist ja so, man hat sich geschrieben, man denkt jetzt an eine Verabredung
und sagt sich jetzt, soll man ins Restaurant gehen oder lieber in die Kneipe oder spazieren?
Und das kann man auch für sich auf keinen Fall alleine beantworten. Da braucht man Hilfe.
Ja, genau.
He said a lot of apps out there that are saying they've already integrated AI
tools, but they're not being clear about how is realistically just a more advanced algorithm.
Ja, also wenn du richtig scheitern willst, dann verkopfe dein Dating,
indem du noch eine AI zur Hilfe nimmst.
Ja, es geht noch weiter.
Das ist wirklich. Natürlich.
Du brauchst dann nicht mehr selbst tippen.
Und das ist ja das, was wir in Hör haben, dass wir dort einen Mann haben,
der ist einsam, der hat die künstliche Intelligenz, die Stimme von Scarlett
Johansson und dann stellt sich nachher heraus, Arti datet tausend Männer,
das ist ja nur eine KI und hier kannst du aber jetzt als Mensch sagen,
es gibt ja so viele, ich kann ja nicht die ganze Zeit mit denen Bücher vollschreiben,
wie Stefan das gemacht hat, weil ich ja noch gerade zehn verschiedene Optionen habe,
ich lasse das mal die KI übernehmen, bis sich da irgendwas Konkretes einstellt
und dann komme ich nochmal selbst dazu.
Ja, umso mehr Kalküle man reinbaut, umso weniger Platz ist für Gefühl und ohne
Gefühl ist überhaupt keine Orientierung da, sondern dann wird knallhart abgerechnet
und im Strich zähle ich, was hat mir der Chat gebracht.
Das ist der falsche Weg und diese Verkopfung, klar, bietet sich total an,
mithilfe von KI noch irgendwie die Chats flirtiger zu machen,
aber ich glaube von dieser Humorkapazität,
also ich traue AI extrem viel zu, aber Flirtintelligenz never.
Ja, glaube ich auch nicht.
Weil da kommt Richard David Brechts, die körperliche Komponente fehlt.
Man kriegt es nicht über welche Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung und mit welcher Zufall.
Auch immer, das kriegt man nicht simuliert, sondern da muss es einfach.
Das ist dann, die sitzen dann immer da in First Dates.
Am Ende diese Frage vor der Kamera und wollt ihr ein zweites Date?
Und dann ist in 50 Prozent der Fällen wird gesagt, nee, der Funk gesprang nicht über.
Mhm.
Was soll das heißen? Der Funke sprang nicht über. Das ist einfach,
die Leute wissen selber nicht Bescheid und die AI wird in vielen Fällen klüger
sein als der Mensch, aber in diesem, was ist, wäre dein Funke gewesen,
wird sie den Menschen niemals überrumpeln, übertrumpfen oder sonst irgendwie.
Entweder man fühlt es oder nicht. Und wir werden auch noch in 30 Jahren Christopher
Nolan Filme sehen und sagen, den hat ein Mensch gemacht.
So, das ist einfach, da sind die großen prinzipiellen Unterschiede.
Sound far-fetched? Well, let's find out. Our family and tech columnist Julie
Jargon is here and she's been testing it out.
So Julie, to start off, can you just tell us how this service from SciMatch works?
Yeah, so when you sign up for the app, you almost immediately scan your face.
So it does that real time so that you can't trick it by uploading a picture
of a celebrity or a filtered photo. Once it scans your face,
then you can create your profile.
And then you can immediately start looking for profiles of other people.
And if you come across someone that you're interested in, you can click on them.
And the app will show you your compatibility index, which is given as a percentage.
So it'll say you're a 70% match or a 50% match.
And if you feel comfortable with those odds, then you can reach out to that
person and message them on the app.
Warum wollen die Leute das nicht mehr selbst entscheiden? Denn ich erinnere
mich an ein Interview mit Frank Schirrmacher, da war er bei Beckmann zu Gast
und da sprach er über die Digitalisierung und was die so alles mit sich bringt,
wie der Mensch beherrscht wird dadurch.
Und er machte damals so klar, ja wir sollten mal wieder mehr auch so etwas wie
die menschliche Intuition nach vorne stellen und das ist ja das,
was wir beim Daten die ganze Zeit tun oder auch generell, wenn wir mit Menschen
zusammen sind, wir agieren intuitiv und da brauche ich nichts dazwischen zu schalten.
Ja, wenn man das so hört, denkt man eh, ja das wird so die nächste Publikationsphase
für Podcaster werden, die aus der Bitcoin pro Finan-Tech irgendwas Bubble dann
sagen, wir reden jetzt mal über Stating.
Und dann kommt dieses Psy-Op-mäßige irgendwie und so weiter.
Gibt unendlich, wie ich habe das jetzt nicht mitgebracht, ich habe gesehen,
weil man jetzt diese Gesichtsscans hat und auch überlegt, wie muss ein Gesicht
aussehen, gibt es jetzt schon ganz viele Tutorials, wie du so ein Dating-Gesicht
bekommst mit einer Dating-Frisur, also was wirklich funktioniert.
Ich habe zum Beispiel auch gelernt, es gibt das Heart-Shaped-Face.
Weißt du, was das ist?
Wahrscheinlich hier deine Jawline und so.
So ein herzförmiges Gesicht und damit wird dann gearbeitet, also da wurde als
Beispiel, wenn man es googelt, gleich einem Reese Witherspoon gezeigt,
die hat ein heart-shaped Face. Wir hören nochmal weiter.
Es gibt eine Wissenschaft darüber, wie verschiedene Faszialfeaturen und Formen
die Persönlichkeiten der Menschen ausdrücken können.
Sie versuchen also, sie gegen ein Datensatz von anderen Fotos zu vergleichen,
die sie kennen, die mit bestimmten Persönlichkeiten zusammenhängen,
damit sie für Sie eine kompatible Ausgabe finden können.
Also zum Beispiel, welche Art von Gesichtsschichten gehen mit welcher Art von Gesichtsschicht?
So, one thing that's been studied is heart-shaped faces, which are apparently
considered to be creative and people with heart-shaped faces have a fiery temperament.
And I don't know if there's a whole lot of science behind this,
but apparently people with heart-shaped faces are often attracted to people
with more square-shaped faces.
Ding Dong, das 19. Jahrhundert ist zurück, Freud macht eine Sitzung.
Das ist nicht Freud, das ist Physiognomie-Lehrer.
Damit hat Freud auch angefangen, Vermessung des Kopfes.
Dann ist er ja noch ein bisschen weitergegangen.
Aber es war auch Freud, der mit diesem Quatsch da war.
Naja, aber Freud ist nicht jetzt wirklich für seine Physiognomielehre bekannt.
Alle entschuldigen immer so Freud.
Nein, Freud ist schon sehr wichtig, weil er die Psychoanalyse ja von all diesem
Mythischen weggezogen hat.
Vielleicht gibt es ja hier noch eine psychoanalytische Wende in drei Jahren
oder so, die dann einsetzt.
Ja.
Wenn er mal Moden durchgeprübelt.
Nee, das Ding bei der richtigen falschen Psychoanalyse ist ja nicht,
dass man so eine Lösung serviert bekommt und man sagt, so findest du jetzt den
perfekten Partner oder so etwas,
sondern man soll ja eher erkennen, dass der Widerspruch in unserem Begehren
selbst liegt und solche Sachen, ja.
Also das ist ja nichts, was einen eigentlich nur zurückführt auf die Erfolgsbahn,
auch wenn heute Therapien, Psychotherapien oft so geformt sind,
aber bei Freud, bei dieser Psychoanalyse geht es ja um sehr sehr Grundsätzliches
und hier das ist ja so ein ganz reductionistisches Bild.
Ja, Menschen ticken so, dann müssen wir die nur so miteinander verbinden.
Also eigentlich werden hier Menschen ja schon wie Computer betrachtet und da
müssen wir jetzt mal sehen, wie programmieren wir das entsprechend.
Wir hören nochmal ganz kurz von dem Slate-Podcast etwas zur Aktie von Match Group.
Attitude towards dating apps has never been worse, but I do think everyone's still on them.
That's true. Okay, Lakshmi, what about you? It's in many ways,
it's just sort of history repeating itself.
And I say that to offer some solace to people.
Like the whole ecosystem of dating kind of changed with the introduction of Tinder.
And once Tinder joined the dating pool, everybody else had to mimic what they did.
Die Frustration ist groß,
die Sorgen offenbar auch, wenn man sich ansieht, wann Eheschließungen stattfinden. Hier mal Zahlen.
2002 war eine Frau durchschnittlich 28,8 Jahre alt bei ihrer ersten Eheschließung.
Nun 20 Jahre später ist sie 32,6 Jahre alt.
Bei den Männern war es 2002 so, dass sie 31,8 Jahre alt waren im Schnitt und
jetzt 20 Jahre später 35,1 Jahre.
Ja, innerhalb der letzten 50 Jahre ist das Alter um 50 Prozent gestiegen.
Aus diesem Anfang 20er in den Mitte 30er Bereich.
Also es ist wirklich eine substanzielle Veränderung, die, klar man lebt länger
und so, aber biografisch dann doch, weil bis die Kinder dann und so weiter und
dann hat man dieses Bild, dass die Eltern und die Kinder gleichzeitig Windeln brauchen.
Ja.
Als Rushhour des Lebens.
Ja, ein sehr schönes Bild. Aber es ist ja doch so,
dass es eine, also es gibt einen großen Markt für Dating-Apps und all das und
jetzt gibt es zugleich diese enorme Frustration und man kann sich vorstellen, woran das auch liegt.
Das liegt daran, wie diese Apps programmiert sind.
Das liegt aber auch an sehr unterschiedlichen Erwartungen, also dass diese Apps
für die einen dazu da sind,
Sex-Dates zu realisieren, für die anderen doch eher die langfristige Beziehung
im Mittelpunkt steht, aber nicht so ganz klar ist immer, wer jetzt gerade was will.
Also klar gibt es Optionen bei manchen Apps, wo man anzeigen kann,
suche Sex und dann darf sich am Ende auch keiner beschweren,
dass es nicht die Liebe fürs Leben geworden ist.
Aber ich glaube, da bleibt auch sehr vieles im Ungewissen, wie ja generell beim
Dating vieles im Ungewissen bleibt.
Und hinzu kommen dann ja noch diese ganzen anderen Phänomene von Ghosting und, und, und. Ja.
Also die Leute scheinen relativ unglücklich über das Dating zu sein.
Zugleich ist Dating das, wie jetzt hier so eine amerikanische Statistik zeigt von Forbes Health,
das, wo am meisten Leute sich kennenlernen, also über Dating-Apps und dann kommen erst Konzerte,
dann kommt erst die Arbeit oder Social Media oder das Fitnessstudio.
Das heißt, die Dating-App ist immer noch das, was am wichtigsten ist,
damit sich überhaupt Leute kennenlernen.
Aber das Leid ist groß darum und wird vielfach thematisiert.
Hier bei Slate wird auch mal ein Unterschied gemacht, wie denn diese Dating-Apps
uns verändert haben im analogen Leben.
By your friends, your co-workers. That sort of shaped your world of dating.
And then if you didn't like that, then you went to a dating app.
Your dating identity was formed offline and then online became a tool.
What happened with Tinder is that was when they went after, as Kate said,
college students and people under the age of 30.
So that meant that all of a sudden, the composition of the dating pool was completely different.
It was free. It was on your phone. So it's not even that the dating.
Sehr gute Beobachtung.
Ja, also wir sehen dann nicht mehr Menschen auf uns zukommen,
sondern eigentlich schon Dating-Profile.
Wir hören mal weiter über die Frustration.
Little thought of like, well, they're good, but like,
Theoretically there could still be someone better out there and I can just pull
up my phone and look at limitless options right now.
And so I think there's this paradox of choice that people are frozen in.
I think it's cheapened a little bit or just devalued just what it means to match
with someone and go on a date with someone.
Gelegenheit macht Diebe. Das ist ja eigentlich ungeheuerlich,
wenn man sich das vorstellt, wenn man das mal schaut jetzt. Man wäre in vordigitalen
Zeiten und man lebt jetzt vielleicht nicht in der verrücktesten Stadt der Welt,
sondern irgendwo da, wo man so in Deutschland lebt.
Und dort hat man ein festes Umfeld, dort gibt es auch relativ wenig neue Begegnungen dann.
Wir haben vielleicht irgendwelche Feste, Oktoberfest oder so und dort kann man
dann wieder neue Gesichter sehen.
Und da ist dann potenziell auch die Gefahr da, eine alte Beziehung oder eine
gerade laufende Beziehung zu verlassen für etwas Neues. Aber sonst ist das nicht gegeben.
Jetzt ist also das nur noch ein Klick entfernt und man kann den Radius immer
stärker erweitern. Also ich hatte so eine Geschichte hier von jemand,
der dann plötzlich so 3000 Kilometer weiter weg schaute.
Was ist eigentlich da? Und das hat dann auch funktioniert.
Also solche Geschichten gibt es natürlich auch schon mal, aber man hat einen
ganz anderen Radius. Und das ist ja erstmal was, wir hatten das irgendwann mal
im Live-Salon angesprochen, was auch eine unglaubliche Durchmischung ermöglicht.
Also ich bin ja sehr, ich will das hier ausdrücklich sagen, also bei der Kritik
hier an diesen Dating-Apps im Sinne von dieser Pay-Modelle und dieser süchtig
machenden Gamifizierung,
die da einprogrammiert wird, möchte ich auch hier ganz klar sagen, dass ich sehr dafür bin,
dass ein Radius erweitert werden kann.
Ja es gibt diese Frustration, die dann mit dieser unglaublichen Wahl zusammenhängt,
aber zugleich glaube ich ist das auch eine Möglichkeit für Leute mit speziellen
Interessen andere Leute zu finden.
Du hast es eben jetzt schon im Bereich der Freundschaft angedeutet,
dass man natürlich, wenn man jetzt nicht irgendwie sagt, mein Hobby ist Fußball
und im Biergarten sitzen, dass es vielleicht schwierig sein wird,
jemanden zu finden, das kann über eine Dating-App besser sein.
Ich glaube aber auch wirklich im Sinne von Durchmischung ist das gut.
Also ich muss immer an die Identitären dabei denken, wenn die immer sagen,
wir haben noch so 10 bis 20 Jahre Zeit in Deutschland und da würde ich sagen,
nee, da müssen wir dagegen arbeiten,
wir müssen das enthomogenisieren durch Mischung, durch Mischung,
durch Mischung, dann haben die Identitären gar nichts mehr, worauf sie zurückgreifen können.
Eins der ganz großen Themen ist ja auch, wie geht man damit um,
wo man bis heute immer auf die Scheidungsurkunde schreibt, ist gescheitert oder…,
Keine Ahnung, man macht so ein First-Date-Match im Fernsehen und dann,
ja, der Funk ist nicht übergesprungen. Okay, dann sehen wir uns nie wieder.
So, wie man damit eigentlich umgeht, dass es so halbgare Matches gibt.
Also man will doch noch so ein bisschen Zeit zu verbringen, aber nicht so die
ganze Zeit. Also man ist nicht so all in.
Nein, ich habe jetzt, als ich für das Buch darüber schrieb, bin ich selber so
ein bisschen aus allen Wolken gefallen, wenn man es sich nur mal auf zwei Seiten so aufschreibt.
Die Kernfamilie, also das von uns Geschätzte und hier immer noch häufig Angestrebte,
zwei Menschen finden sich, verbringen ihr ganzes Leben miteinander und das Ding
trägt sich von selbst, weil sie sich lieben.
So, dann kommt immer schon, nee, es heißt irgendwie, Arbeit gehört dazu,
Kinder machen Arbeit, es ist Erziehungsarbeit, wie auch immer,
Care, Work und so, und dann kommt schon diese Komponente rein.
Und dann wird es aufgebrochen durch, keine Ahnung, Esther Perel sagt dann irgendwie,
ja, Monogamie ist ein ganz starkes Ding, aber es ist serielle Monogamie.
Also es ist nicht mehr, bis dass der Tod uns scheidet, sondern bis einer keine Lust mehr hat.
So, und das größte Problem, was wir noch haben, ist eine Entdramatisierung solcher.
Trennungs, Auslaufenden, Ghostings, ich bin frustriert und so weiter und so
fort, weil das Modell, was hier gerade im Mittelpunkt steht,
die Kernfamilie, die sich allen Aufgaben stellt und das Paar stirbt gemeinsam,
ist so artifiziell wie eine Dating-App.
Es wurde damals die Dampfmaschine erfunden und die Dampfmaschine erforderte
die Erfindung der Kernfamilie.
Als die Menschen Kohle verbrannt haben und die erste quasi Anschub-Industrialisierung
stattfand, gab es noch keine Kernfamilie.
Die kam erst im Erdölzeitalter. Die ist also jetzt 200 Jahre alt oder so.
Vorher haben die Menschen nicht so gelebt.
Und ich schreibe dann so ein bisschen flapsig rein, die Autoren haben diesen
Menschen die Liebe erfunden und die Architekten haben halt die Schlafzimmer gebaut.
Und wir denken irgendwie, ja, das ist so, genau so ist es, das ist die Natur
der Sache, das ist Gott gegeben, so leben Menschen.
Und dann stellt man so fest, nee, so leben Menschen eigentlich nicht.
Die Kernfamilie war die Schwester der Dampfmaschine. Das geht Hand in Hand,
das ist eine Ko-Evolution. Man kann nicht das eine ohne das andere.
Nur wir stolpern ja jetzt aus dieser Industrialisierung raus.
Dieses Matching, okay, wir brauchen den Arbeiter, der steht im Zentrum der Welt
und der muss halt irgendwie versorgt werden, also hat er einen Arbeitgeber und
eine Frau, die ihn liebt und so weiter und nur den einen Teil machen wir finanziell,
das sind alles ganz artifizielle Sachen.
Und wenn man dann immer hört, dass ja der Berliner Datingmarkt so drunter und
drüber geht, weil, keine Ahnung, da verlässt sich niemand mehr auf irgendwen,
keiner ist mehr beziehungsfähig und so weiter, würde ich hart fragen.
Ist das schlecht? Sind die auf der falschen Spur oder sind die einfach schon in der Zukunft?
Die sind auf jeden Fall nicht besonders glücklich darin.
Genau, wenn sie leiden, worunter leiden sie wirklich? Unter dem Verhalten der
anderen oder an ihren eigenen Erwartungen und Vorstellungen?
Und dann kann man sich ja fragen, wie kann da ein grundsätzliches neues Matching stattfinden?
Nur will ich erstmal zu Bedenken geben, dass ich gemeinsame Schlafzimmer keine
gute Idee finde, aber zweitens.
Immer weniger übrigens. Das ist eine gute und gesunde Idee.
Aber was für mich wichtiger ist, ist, glaube ich, alles was du gesagt hast,
ist vollkommen richtig.
Es gibt nur ein einziges Problem dabei. Dabei, gerade bei einer Eheschließung,
ist es so, dass man ja nicht, oder generell, wenn man sich entscheidet,
wirklich zusammen zu sein,
dann ist das nicht mit einem Ende in Sicht.
Also man macht das nicht, wie man sagt.
Mit einem geplanten Ende in Sicht.
Ja, na, ich würde schon sagen, dass dieser Ewigkeitsanspruch,
ob das jetzt Industrialisierung, bürgerliche Gesellschaft, sonst irgendetwas
ist, dass es ewig wird, sich zu verewigen, zu zweit.
Und das ist etwas, was absolut drin ist und das ist nicht nur gesellschaftlich aufgezwungen,
sondern ich glaube, das liegt in der Logik der Sache, dass man sich in einem
Moment, in dem man sich klar ist, wir sind alles füreinander,
wir können an nichts mehr anderes denken, wir schreiben zwei Bücher voll mit
Chats, wie kann das sein?
In dieser Situation will man eigentlich zum Augenblicke sagen,
verweile doch, du bist so schön und will diesen verewigen.
Und das ist auch die Idee von Ehe jenseits jetzt institutioneller Geschichten.
Und da glaube ich, kommt man nicht weiter mit etwas Seriellem.
Das zeigt sich ja schon daran, dass allein die Vorstellung für Leute schwierig
wird zu sagen, wir machen einen Ehevertrag, weil der schließt ja das Ende zumindest nicht aus.
Ja. Der Ehevertrag ist ja eine
artifizielle Angelegenheit in einer artifiziellen Angelegenheit. Denn …,
Es gibt ja eh einen Ehevertrag, auch wenn nicht eine Seite sich nochmal bevorteilt der anderen gegenüber.
Sondern alleine, also die Ehe
erlaubt dir so viele gesellschaftlich eingeräumte Vorteile und so weiter.
Angefangen bei den Steuern und bei allen anderen Sachen, die so ein bisschen einfacher sind.
Das ist eh alles geregelt und man weiß, diese Vorteile gibt es nur so lange, wie es hält.
Deswegen wird ja eigentlich eine Gefühlssache gehoben auf so eine formale, wo dann klar ist,
naja, das Matching aus formaler Abmachung und Gefühlswelt kann auseinanderlaufen,
also es droht dann sowieso die ganze Zeit,
weshalb ja dann Udo Jürgens auch singt, Liebe ohne Leiden, ja,
also wenn selbst auf der Gefühlsebene das Leiden schon da ist,
dass das Formale so wegdriftet und man dann irgendwie feststellt,
Man hat so gemeinsame Aufgaben, vielleicht hat man ein gemeinsames Unternehmen,
ein gemeinsames was auch immer oder Kinder und so. Das sind ja so verschiedene
Sachen, die einen binden.
Und das Gefühltige läuft aber immer parallel. Und das Neue ist ja …,
keiner.
So kann ich einen Job beginnen und sagen, ja, so für die nächsten fünf Jahre
kann ich mir vorstellen, in der Unternehmensberatung zu sein.
Aber ich sage ja nicht, für die nächsten fünf Jahre können wir es miteinander aushalten.
Ja, der gefühlige Teil kann ein Eigenleben entwickeln.
Eigentlich hat die Natur Vorkehrungen getreffen, also Immunsysteme passen sich
an, Verhaltensweisen koordinieren sich über Selbstständige aneinander.
Man lebt eigentlich auch in so einer gemeinsamen Biosphäre fast.
So, und trotzdem hat das Gefühlsleben ein Eigenleben, weil sich kulturell,
Erwartungen eingespielt haben, die jetzt so einen Katalysator erfahren.
Schon bevor es überhaupt losgeht, das Matching, erfährst du schon, es gibt noch andere.
Esther Perel sagt jetzt einfach seriell, also Monogamie hintereinander.
Was wir durch diese Apps aber erleben und es geht ja beim Dating los,
datest du gerade mehrere, ist ja eigentlich die Parallelisierung von diesen Sachen.
Und da würde ich jetzt wieder sagen, alle sind mittlerweile so weit aufgeklärt,
dass sie sagen, die Ehe allein, die Partnerschaft kann es nicht ich auffange,
mein Mann, meine Frau haben noch andere Bedürfnisse, die gehen da zum Sport
ohne mich, die machen diese,
Filmstudien ohne mich, was auch immer.
Aber das ist ja immer so gewesen.
Das ist nicht immer so gewesen, das musste auch erkämpft werden.
Zum Beispiel, dass die Frau jenseits des Haushalts solche Freiräume hat,
sich in der sozialen Sphäre zu bewegen, ohne dass der Mann nochmal,
er erlaube ich dir und so. Sondern nein, das ist die Vorliebe der Frau.
Und dann geht sie zu was auch immer. Das sind erkämpfte Sachen in einem ansonsten
auch Auch und mit erkämpft meine ich artifiziellen, hergestellten Prinzip.
Nur sprechen wir hier von einer Freizeitaktivität und das ist ja nochmal was
anderes, wie zu sagen und ich habe noch nebenher jemanden oder noch nebenher zwei.
Da sind wir ja dann plötzlich in einem ganz anderen Bereich und ja.
Das kommt auch immer häufiger. Diese Diskussion über offene Beziehungen und
so weiter, die Leute propagieren es mittlerweile, damit du in deiner Ehe glücklich
bist, erlaube dir den Freiraum auch körperlich.
Das ist mittlerweile, gerade in Großstädten.
Und so weiter. Da ist das so krachend gescheitert und hat solche Tragödien produziert.
Da waren alle Scheidungen, die ich so mitbekommen habe, wesentlich angenehmer.
Da bin ich auch gespannt, wie das weitergeht, aber es gibt mittlerweile,
die Grundbegriffe werden schon etabliert, die Ankerperson im Zuge vieler Beziehungen,
die man hat und so weiter und so fort.
Also ich sehe deine Kritik. Ich will nur sagen, empirisch findet man es heute,
also so wie das Heiratsalter um 50 Prozent angestiegen ist, ist auch der Wunsch
nach Alternativen von so Kernfamilie, Ehe, zu zweit und so weiter,
ist auch um 50 Prozent gestiegen.
Es gibt hier so eine Entgrenzung, so ein Abdriften.
Wenn die Semantik da ist, ist auch irgendwo die strukturelle Entsprechung dafür,
auch wenn du jetzt sagst, ich kenne da relativ wenig.
Ich würde sagen, es ist ganz schön viel los in dieser Gesellschaft,
in der es ja nicht nur Dating-Apps gibt.
Sondern dann auch mit Joy Club und so weiter ganz explizite, hier geht es zur Sache.
Ja gut, aber das wiederum glaube ich ist ein Phänomen, das sich weiter ausbreiten wird.
Also dass Leute sich selbst haben und ihren Weg verfolgen, der für sie relevant
und wichtig ist und dass der auch mal Flirts,
irgendwelche sexuellen Erlebnisse mit einbezieht, ist vollkommen klar.
Aber dass man nicht mehr mit jemandem zusammen etwas gemeinsam aufbaut,
das glaube ich wird sich eher noch verstärken.
Zum einen, aber auch nur in einem gewissen Level,
also ich glaube in einem Bereich, wo Leute sehr gut verdienen,
wo auch so Zweckgemeinschaften gar keine Rolle spielen und wo man so viele Möglichkeiten
hat, wieder kennenzulernen, neue Erfahrungen zu machen.
Und zugleich auch noch in einem größeren Bekannten- und Freundeskreis eingebettet
ist, also dass man nicht diese existenzielle Einsamkeit laufend hat und dann
hat man mal ein One-Night-Stand, sondern man ist eigentlich gut eingebettet.
Das, glaube ich, wird sich weiter verstärken.
Aber zugleich haben wir eben gesehen, die Heimatfront, ja, die Leute werden ärmer und all das.
Dies sorgt eher dafür, dass wieder Zweckgemeinschaften vielleicht wichtiger werden.
Wir haben einen Maximilian Graf
von der AfD, der sagt, echte Männer sind rechts und dieser ganze Graf.
Wir werden gleich noch auf Männer so ein bisschen eingehen, aber können ja erstmal
festhalten, naja, es gibt…,
All diese neuen Entwicklungen jetzt hin, auch weg vom klassischen Rollenmodell, gerade bei Frauen.
Wir haben aber diese Studie ja besprochen im Salon, im letzten Salon von der
Financial Times vorgestellt, dass also die Männer rechter konservativer werden,
die Frauen progressiver.
Und ich würde sagen, das ist noch nicht alles ausgemacht, denn wenn die Krisen
sich verschärfen, kann durchaus auch sein, dass wieder so ein Ernährermodell
plötzlich sehr attraktiv wird.
Durch Corona sind wir ja genau 30 Jahre da zurückgesprungen,
was die Rolle der Frau in sowas angeht.
Zu dem Thema, weil das immer so interessant ist. Aber ich glaube,
die Aufmerksamkeit ist so groß für alle Leute, die in Beziehungen sind,
mal da zu hören, wie ging es dann noch.
Und das ist sicherlich ein Problem, das du aber ansprichst.
Wir reden ganz viel über Einsamkeit und sehen Singles vor uns.
Aber was glaube ich sehr stark ausgeblendet wird, ist die Einsamkeit in Beziehungen.
Also wo nicht artikuliert werden kann vieles, was man auf dem Herzen hat und
man zugleich nicht einen Freundeskreis hat, wo man es artikulieren kann.
Ja, vor allem, wenn du dich sozialen Netzen ausgeliefert siehst,
aus denen du nicht rauskommst, obwohl du dir andere wünschst.
Du bist deiner Familie ausgeliefert, du bist deiner Arbeitswelt ausgeliefert
und überall bist du unglücklich.
Wir hören jetzt mal Scott Galloway, den haben wir ja zu dem Thema schon häufiger
gehört. Das ist jetzt ein Interview vom vergangenen Jahr von CNN.
The story reported that as of 2022, Pew Research Center found 30% of US adults
are neither married, living with a partner, nor engaged in a committed relationship.
Nearly half of all young adults are single. Now, look at these numbers.
34% of women, twice as many, a whopping 63% of men. What explains that?
I pulled the Pew study and I read with interest. Turns out, since 2019,
the share of single men who say they're looking for dates or a relationship
has declined from 61% to 50%.
In 2018, 28% of men ages 18 to 30 reported they'd had no sex in the past year,
compared with 18% of women of that age.
Die Hill-Report sagte, Männer in ihren Zwanzigern seien mehr möglich als Frauen
in ihren Zwanzigern, romantisch unentwickelt, sexuell dormant,
freundlich und traurig zu sein.
Sie stehen auf der Vangarde einer Epidemie von deklinierender Beziehung,
Sexualität und Verhältnissen, die alle jungen Amerikaner verursacht.
Zwischen den Gründen, zwischen den Faktoren, eine Bedeutung auf Social Media und Online-Porn.
But also, more young women are hooking up with each other, or dating and marrying
slightly older men, and heterosexual women are getting more choosy.
Other troubling statistics about men come from a 2021 study from the Survey
Center for American Life.
They found the share of men who have six or more close friends,
which in 1990 was 55%, by 2021 had shrunk by half.
Ja, sehr gut.
Übrigens ist mir gerade noch eingefallen, es gab in der FAS im vergangenen Monat
einen größeren Artikel darüber, dass Frauen,
die beruflich erfolgreich sind und über 50 sind, jetzt gerade das Dating,
vor allem das Dating jüngerer Männer für sich entdecken.
Und das ist ein großes Thema, handeln wohl auch viele Podcasts von.
Wir hören hier nochmal zur Ökonomie etwas.
Das ist ein Zurück in die natürliche Ordnung von Dingen.
Für die Mehrheit der Geschichte, hat ein kleiner Teil der Männer die Mehrheit
der Möbel-Opportunitäten.
Aber in Amerika haben wir entschieden, ein großes Investment in das,
was wahrscheinlich die größte Innovation in der Geschichte wäre,
und das ist in der mittleren Klasse.
Von 1945 bis 1947 wurden sieben Millionen Männer von der Kriegsführung zurückgezogen.
Wir haben ihnen die GI-Bill, die finanziellen Beträge und die Bildungsrate von
5% bis 45% gegeben. Sie wurden wertvoll und wir hatten eine so starke Begegnung,
eine Manufaktur-Base, dass man eine massive Beziehung und Haushalts-Formation
hatte und manche Männer wurden als ökonomischer und emotional nachhaltiger gesehen.
Und man hat das Gegenteil gesehen, mit dem Aufstehen viel unserer Manufaktur-Base,
mit einer Gesellschaft, die ganz ehrlich gesagt junge Männer nicht wertvoll ist.
Wenn wir über Probleme mit Menschen von Farbe oder Frauen sprechen,
sehen wir es als ein systematischer sozialer Problem.
Wenn wir Probleme sehen oder die Zahlen, die du gerade erwähnt hast,
sehen wir sie als dass die Männer sich nur noch umsetzen müssen.
Aber verheiratete Haushalte und die Formation der Haushalte sind bessere Bürger.
Sie wählen, sie verdienen zweimal die Rente, sie sind weniger möglich,
Schmerzen zu verursachen.
Und wir haben weniger und weniger verfügbare Männer.
Wir haben einen Schmerz von ökonomischen und emotional verfügbaren Männern.
Aber die Mittelklasse ist ein Unfall. Obwohl man investiert, passiert es nicht.
Eisenhower hat entschieden, 500 Billionen Dollar in ein National-Highway-Projekt zu investieren.
Also die ökonomische Unsichtbarkeit von jungen Menschen sorgt für Vereinsamung,
sorgt dann bei den Männern besonders für Vereinsamung, da sie auch immer noch
eigentlich sich in der Rolle sehen des Mannes, der es schafft.
Und das ist aber ökonomisch einfach nicht vorgesehen. Also das ist dann nicht
die individuelle Schuld, sondern es ist ökonomisch nicht mehr vorgesehen.
Da ist nicht ein Eisenhauer, der sagt, wir machen jetzt mal Geld locker und
dann geht's los. Das ist ja das große Thema von Scott Galloway.
Sehr gute Kommentare von Scott Galloway in diesen Angelegenheiten.
Ich würde es aber jetzt mal so ein bisschen...
Auch kritisieren wollen. Wir hören mal weiter, was er sagt.
Das will ich erst mal nicht kritisieren.
Das will ich erstmal nicht kritisieren, sondern würde sagen,
ja, das ist so der Fall und das belegen ja auch ganz viele andere Statistiken noch,
also dass Männer es sehr viel schwieriger haben auf diesen Plattformen,
während Frauen wiederum das Problem haben mit sich schlecht verhaltenen Männern.
Also das ist etwas, worunter jetzt die Männer haben jetzt in der Regel nicht
ein Problem, dass die dort beschimpft werden oder irgendwelche Pics gesendet
bekommen, die sie gar nicht sehen wollen.
Das ist eher das, worunter die Frauen auf den Apps zu leiden haben,
während die Männer darunter zu leiden haben, dass ihnen kaum Aufmerksamkeit
zuteil wird und dann versuchen sie Geld zu investieren, damit ihre Profile gepusht
werden, damit sie dann möglichst vielen Frauen angezeigt werden.
Und er spricht jetzt über den High Heels Effekt.
Effekt,
In den letzten 40 Jahren haben mehr Frauen von der Schule aufgewachsen als Männer
und sie interessieren sich nicht mehr für die Ausbildung von unkollegierten Gradstätten.
Sie haben jetzt mehr Wohnungen, Single-Women als Single-Männer.
Also was Sie haben, ist, dass Frauen sagen, dass sie niemanden kürzer als sie
verabschieden werden, 50 Prozent von ihnen.
Effektiv, was Sie metaphorisch haben in den letzten 40 Jahren,
ist, dass Frauen immer höher und höher werden und Männer immer kürzer und kürzer werden.
Wie viele von uns haben gesagt, ich kenne eine Menge großartige Single-Women,
sie können ein Date nicht finden. Das ist nicht wahr.
Sie können ein Date nicht finden. Sie können einen Mann nicht finden,
den sie ökonomisch oder emotional verantwortlich finden.
If we don't make a massive investment in young people and make more economically
and emotionally viable men, we're going to see a lack of household formation,
we're going to see a decline in the middle class, and we're going to see,
quite frankly, just a lot of young men who are terrible citizens.
Ja, ich habe nichts dagegen zu sagen, der ökonomische Status muss angehoben
werden, auch jenseits des Datings ist das von Vorteil.
Was ich nur glaube ist, dass wenn man das zu sehr auf diesen Status hin sieht,
dann manifestiert man eigentlich damit erneut doch so das Bild,
dass irgendwie der Mann ökonomisch stärker sein muss und die Frau will dann
auch den ökonomisch stärkeren Mann.
Ich sage nicht, dass das auch die Realität widerspiegelt, was er da beschreibt,
ist ja richtig und ich habe dann Ähnliches auch dazu gefunden und Frauen daten
in der Regel etwas nach oben, also finanziell Männer nicht,
für Männer ist das nicht das entscheidende Kriterium.
Und wenn natürlich immer weniger Männer den Aufstieg schaffen können und diese
Frauen aber zum Teil eher noch den Aufstieg schaffen und die wollen dann sich
nach oben daten, dann kann man sich vorstellen,
dass die Frauen da oben nicht so viel finden und es gibt aber ganz viele Männer,
nur sind die Ansprüche andere.
Und da würde ich aber einfach auch beiden zurufen, Männer wie Frauen,
warum das so sehr in den Mittelpunkt gerückt werden muss.
Also wie viel trägt man da von den alten Ideen?
Überholt geglaubten Modellen noch gerade mit sich, warum ist das jetzt plötzlich
das ausschlaggebende Kriterium wieder, das hängt mit unsicheren Zeiten und all
dem zusammen und dann sind dann doch die Kontoauszüge entscheidend.
Aber das ist eine ganz vertrackte Situation,
was ja auch dann dazu führt, dass bei YouTube unglaublich viele Videos zu finden
sind, wie man so einen Rich Look als Mann oder auch als Frau sich schaffen kann.
Also wie kann ich mich ästhetisch so updaten mit einer entsprechenden Frisur
und einem entsprechenden Make-up, dass ich reich wirke, auch wenn ich es gar nicht bin.
Und wenn wir jetzt mal so eine konservative Einschätzung da hören,
das ist eine YouTuberin, die heißt Real Alex Clark, die geht nämlich dann schon
so einen Schritt weiter.
A man's instinct to be a hero and to achieve is tied directly to how men show their love.
Since the beginning of time, men have hunted and women were the gatherers and helpers.
We switched this up as women and insisted that we can hunt instead,
leaving men feeling confused and purposeless.
In an act that drives men further into disorientation, women have chosen to
blur the line between masculine and feminine energies, Erkennung der verschiedenen
Rolle, die Männer und Frauen biologisch auf den Platz gelegt,
Das bedeutet nicht, dass Frauen unsere Gleichheit zurückgeben müssen.
Es bedeutet nur, dass Männer motiviert sind, die Möglichkeit zu zeigen,
dass sie sich als kompetitiv, ehrgeizig, abenteuerlich und traurig in der Erfüllung zeigen.
Aber wir haben sie gemacht, als ob diese Traiten nicht mehr wert sind,
weil Frauen die Chance haben, diese Traiten selbst zu demonstrieren.
Aber was hier ja erstmal gesagt wird, ist, naja, die Frauen finden ja dann eigentlich
den Abenteurer attraktiv oder dies und das attraktiv.
Und ich habe dann darüber nachgedacht, naja, offenbar sind solche Bilder so stark verankert,
dass sie auch immer wieder neu aufgerufen werden können und dann kann man damit
auch Wahlen gewinnen oder so etwas. war es.
Aber wenn man jetzt mal sich zum Beispiel das bei Schwulen und Lesben ansieht,
dann haben wir ja da eine große Bandbreite von verschiedenen Typen.
Ja, also da ist ja nicht jetzt irgendwie das eine präferierte Ding.
Also hier wird ja immer so getan, also eigentlich muss ein Mann so und so aussehen
und dann am Ende kommt, weiß ich nicht, Henry Cavill im Masernzug rein spaziert oder so.
Oder bei der Frau ist dann, wer ist Taylor Swift oder so. so, ja.
Und das ist, glaube ich, also so eine ganz klare Verengung, so muss er eigentlich
oder so muss sie eigentlich sein.
Und wenn man sich jetzt mal prominente schwule und lesbische Persönlichkeiten
vor Augen führt, Hella von Sinnen, Anne Will, ähm.
Wer wäre weiter zu nennen? Kristen Stewart, da haben wir schon eine Bandbreite
bei, Männern, Troye Sivan, Thomas Hitzlsperger, Bruce Danell.
Ja, also völlig anders so. Und was da ja zu erleben ist, ist,
dass man zwar auch irgendwelche Rollen verkörpert, ja, also man ist nicht völlig
irgendwo aufgelöst, sondern verkörpert irgendwelche Rollen.
Und das ist aber nicht an irgendwas noch gebunden, also im Sinne von,
ah, das ist jetzt hier Karriere, das bedeutet Geld, das bedeutet,
ist emotional abweisend oder emotional so und so und so, sondern es sind wie
man fast so beim Sex sagen würde, Rollenspiele, ja,
heute macht der eine das, der andere das oder so, ja, und ich glaube,
dieser spielerische Umgang Mit Rollen, also mit Geschlechterrollen,
nicht im Sinne von, ich will hier nicht erklären, alles ist fluide oder so,
das glaube ich in der Tat nicht, aber das,
wie man sein männlich sein oder sein weiblich sein ausgestaltet,
dass das viel spielerischer eigentlich sein müsste, als es momentan der Fall
ist und dass das dann doch am Ende so ganz hart fest geankert wird an ökonomische
Kategorien und noch politisches und und und.
Das sorgt eigentlich für unglaublich viel Konfusion und dann Frustration und
das viel spielerischer aufzufassen und da eher darin auch den Reiz zu sehen,
das ist glaube ich etwas,
was sehr stark fehlt eigentlich im Gesellschaftlichen.
Ja, aber du hast ja durch Corona gesehen, wenn es hart auf hart kommt,
werden Aufgaben verteilt.
Dann steht derjenige für Homeschooling zurück,
der durch Lohnarbeit nicht allzu
viel und so weiter und dann fällt alles zurück ins klassische Muster,
das nun mal ökonomisch getrieben ist, so wie Scott Galloway sagte,
die Mittelklasse ist eigentlich ein Unfall, sie muss gestaltet werden,
wenn man da nicht investiert, passiert sie nicht.
Also du bist hier ganz marxistisch, das Sein bestimmt das Bewusstsein,
bist du eigentlich jetzt hier am Argumentieren, während ich sage ja, also das stimmt ja auch.
Aber alles, was wir vorhin diskutiert haben zum Thema Ausfransen und Entgrenzen
von Paarbeziehungsvorstellungen hin zu Polyamorie und so weiter und so fort,
sind im Grunde Spiränzchen über, ja eigentlich haben wir keine Probleme,
wir können es uns leisten.
So und dann wird es gemacht und umso härter die Zeiten werden und wir kommen
gleich auf den Wohnungsmarkt zu sprechen ist einfach knallhart,
also das ist einfach, da kannst du dir keinen,
also da ist kein Wunder, dass man das Dating wie ein Bewerbungsgespräch führt
da müssen die Zahlen einfach stimmen weißt du, ansonsten ist da kein Matching
möglich, weil du kannst ja nicht jenseits der ökonomischen Möglichkeiten in
so einer Traumwelt, ja aber eigentlich,
nee, da ist kein Raum mehr für Liebe Okay.
Ich muss das glaube ich nochmal konkreter machen. Du hast absolut, was das angeht, recht.
Nur das Problem ist ja gerade bei so einer konservativen YouTuberin und wir
könnten ähnliche Fälle noch anführen, ist es ja so, dass man dann den ökonomischen
Status auch noch verknüpft mit einem gewissen Bild von Männlichkeit.
Und jetzt soll das bitte alles so sein.
Und was ich jetzt eben mit diesen Aufzählen von prominenten,
nicht heterosexuellen Persönlichkeiten meinte war, ja.
Und da sagt man nicht, so ist der reiche Mann oder so etwas.
Also da ist das als Spiel aufgehoben. Und hier wird das ja bis hin zum biologistischen,
wir machen jetzt nochmal Physiognomielehre und so, wird das ja alles miteinander verbunden.
Und da würde ich sagen, also neben dem ökonomischen, was sich verbessern muss,
da bin ich ja sehr dafür, muss es aber auch eine Auflockerung geben,
was die Rollenbilder angeht.
Also dass man es mehr als Mode betreibt. Dass man es mehr, also nicht,
dass man jetzt sich laufend neu erfinden muss, aber dass man eine größere Varianz zulässt.
Ich meine, das erleben wir bei jungen Leuten, auch gerade im urbanen Raum natürlich,
aber das ist noch sehr, sehr marginal.
Wenn man sich so im Ganzen anguckt, dann ist dann doch das alles noch sehr,
sehr klassisch und setzt dadurch Männer unter Druck und Frauen gleichermaßen,
weil sie sollen nicht nur beruflich erfolgreich sein, sie sollen auch so genau sein,
so muss jetzt die erfolgreiche Frau und die schöne Frau sein und so muss jetzt
der erfolgreiche, schöne Mann sein und der darf dies und das nicht tun.
Die Antwort auf die Frage, warum diese Appelle ins Leere gehen,
hat Scott Galloway gerade gegeben.
Auf dem Matching-Markt kommt Humor, Persönlichkeit und so weiter nicht zur Geltung,
weil sie es nicht entfalten kann.
Wenn alles über Bilder läuft, läuft es über Bilder. Und damit ist da einfach
ein Haken dran und dann wird weiter geswiped oder wie auch immer.
Also die Vorstellungen werden geprägt über die Wünsche, die man entwickelt,
danach, wo man Standards definiert und wenn man nur Bilder hat,
um Standards zu entwickeln, entwickelt man halt optische Standards und dann
spielt alles andere keine Rolle.
Wie in einem Club, da muss man tanzen, da kommt man sonst nicht weiter,
deswegen sind jetzt für mich Clubs, ich bin nicht so der Non-Verbal-Erotiker,
deswegen ist dann eher der Club nicht das Richtige.
Du sitzt in der Oper und guckst zwei Stunden direkt geradeaus und ich auch.
Ganz genau. Wir hören nochmal gerade hier zum Thema Ökonomie.
Das ist der Date-Bill-Podcast.
Es gibt natürlich ganz viel. Alles beschäftigt sich damit.
So gut ich diese First-Date-Sendung finde, aber dieses dändige Betonen,
da wird ja nicht einfach, wir wollen jetzt gerne die Rechnung haben und gehen
oder so, sondern die Rechnung wird in einer Schatztruhe mitten auf den Tisch
gestellt, damit möglichst theatralisch
und keiner kommt und die Auslandungsprozesse drum geklärt wird.
Wie gehen wir jetzt mit der Rechnung um? Ach wirklich?
Ja, ja, ja.
Und das finde ich jedes Mal wieder.
Ich dachte, das haben die nur mal gemacht.
Nein, das ist immer. Das ist die eine Konstante in diesem ganzen Ding,
dass die Holztruhe danach auf den Tisch gestellt wird und wer greift zuerst aus.
Es wird auch noch so von den Kellnern so, ja, dann bringe ich mal die Rechnung.
Ich stelle sie mal in die Mitte, weißt du, so ganz explizit,
wo ich mir echt denke, einer, also einer der Männer, machen die natürlich nie,
sollte mal den Arsch in der Hose haben und sagen,
in so einem Sinne von, komm, erlaub mir den Scherz, ich habe keine Lust zu bezahlen, machst du es?
Einfach nur ganz spielerisch, aber explizit damit umgehen, dass man hier jetzt mal nicht bezahlt.
Aber das ist, ja, also da wird immer wieder, da denkt man so,
okay, wir gucken mal die Sendung, vielleicht ist ja mal irgendwas Innovatives
dabei, ist meistens nicht dabei.
Und spätestens in dem Moment, wo die Schatztruhe auf dem Tisch landet,
weiß man, hier will auch keiner eine Veränderung.
Es ist eines der wichtigsten Anliegen der Sendung, Es soll bleiben,
wie es immer ist. Das Sendekonzept muss auch in zehn Jahren noch funktionieren.
Also egal, welche Innovation sich hier spielerisch oder wie auch immer im Gespräch
der beiden herausgestellt hat, am Ende schlagen wir den Pflock wieder ein.
Der Mann bezahlt und die Frau sagt dann als erstes, ob sie sich ein zweites Date wünscht.
Also wirklich, es ist, was das angeht, ein bisschen lame.
Ja, interessant. Ich glaube, dass diese...
Frage wird ja, also die wird ja auch bei diesem Film von Ruben Östlund sehr
stark verhandelt, wie das denn ist, wenn beide sehr viel Geld verdienen,
wer zahlt denn dann noch die Rechnung?
Aber es ist auch glaube ich so etwas, was im deutschen Diskurs sehr stark ist, dass man.
Es ist eine urdeutsche Angelegenheit.
Ja, also diese ganze schwäbische Hausfrau-Geschichte, das ist natürlich in allen
deutschen Köpfen drin und deswegen spielt das so eine große Rolle.
Ich fand es sehr schön, dass hier dieser Begriff Ick fiel.
Das ist ja auch so ein Trend bei TikTok, dass man so sagt, was ist dein Ick?
Also du sagst, sie ist eine 10, aber sie,
weiß ich nicht, macht das und das und das ist auch dann so etwas,
also zum Beispiel gab es auch so ein TikTok dazu, dass Timothée Chalamet Willy
Wonka spielt und dann sagt man,
oh das ist bestimmt dann für seine Freundin, die aus dem Kardashian Clan ein
Ig und hier ist dann auch das Nichtzahlen der Rechnung seitens des Mannes wäre so ein Ig.
Ja, also ich frage mich dann immer, wie kommt man aus der Nummer raus?
Also eigentlich GIT-Fühling.
Genau. Könnte man irgendwie so sagen, es ist mir eigentlich egal.
Soll ich bezahlen? So ungefähr.
Ja, man muss es ja dann thematisieren. Also man kommt ja um die Thematisierung nicht rum.
Also wenn man es ganz elegant macht, dann hat man schon gezahlt irgendwie so
ganz schnell. Ja, so ging es dann.
Ja, das ist ja eigentlich der klassische Weg. Das geht ja heute durch,
dass man mit der Uhr bezahlt noch besser.
Ah ja.
Man sagt, man will mit Karte zahlen und wie viel und dann kommen die mit dem
Gerät und es dauert eine Sekunde und erledigt.
Oder man geht halt hin und bezahlt in günstigen Gelegenheiten.
Das ist ja auch ganz elegant.
Wir schließen das Thema ab nochmal mit dem Punkt, dass Frauen ein bisschen nach
oben daten wollen oder ganz nach oben.
Also da ist eine TikTokerin, die zeigt uns jetzt,
wie sie es geschafft hat, einen ganz reichen Mann zu daten und so etwas ist
sehr beliebt bei TikTok und ich sehe darin großes Frustpotenzial für alle Seiten.
Prinzess-Treatment only and I just met a guy who does just that.
If you're new here, welcome to my dating diaries where I overshare my dating life in New York.
This guy slid into my DMs on Instagram saying that my dating diaries are very
downtown-based and I should have an Uptown edition.
So, sie wird jetzt in einer riesen Luxus-Limousine abgeholt.
Sie trägt einen Pelzmantel und High Heels.
Wie alt wird sie sein? 20, 21 Jahre wahrscheinlich?
Ja, so ungefähr.
So, let's call this guy Uptown-Man. I asked what a night Uptown entails and
he said shopping at Hermes and dinner at Daniel.
21 Jahre ist die Alter. Sie waren jetzt bei Hermes shoppen. durfte da sich Schuhe aussuchen.
Listen to any dusty man when they tell you your standards are too high.
Und da stellt sich gar nicht mehr die Frage, wer zahlt die Rechnung, das macht natürlich er,
sie waren in einem absoluten Luxusrestaurant zu Gast und so etwas ist schon
sehr, sehr beliebt bei TikTok und ich glaube, dass ja, gerade da,
wo die Zeiten unsicherer werden,
wir glaube ich so eine Rückkehr zu alten Rollenbildern zu befürchten haben,
dann in einer neuen Form, einer neuen Ausprägung.
Also ich glaube, das ist ja jetzt auch bei ihr so in ihrem Auftreten mit einem,
mit gewissen Girlboss-Vibes auch versehen.
Also es ist jetzt ja nicht, dass wir hier jemand sehen, wo wir sagen,
ach, das ist ja wie in den 50er Jahren, sondern dieses, ich nehme mir jetzt,
was ich kriege und habe nicht zu hohe Ansprüche, sondern eher noch zu niedrige.
Ich glaube, das wird so einen neuen Typus hervorrufen, wo man zwar dann die
Frau an der Seite eines Mannes ist,
aber zugleich auch noch sagen kann, ja, ich bin nicht nur das,
sondern ich bin das in ganz emanzipierter Weise,
denn ich habe mich nicht unter Wert verkauft und all das.
Das wird ja hier ausgedrückt und warum sollte ich jetzt auch über eine berufliche
Entwicklung nachdenken, wenn ich hier einfach das bekomme,
was ich wirklich will und das glaube ich wird sich noch sehr stark ausdrücken
und das wird ja zu vielen Verwerfungen führen.
Ja, dieses Dating-Thema wird immer so als gefühliges und so weiter,
Lebensgestaltung, man möchte seine Freiheiten und pipapo, aber in all diesen
Fragestellungen, die sind einfach nicht zu entkoppeln von ökonomischen Fragen.
Und jeder, der diesen Wunsch hätte, er möchte gerne nur gefühlig und so weiter
über dieses Thema reden und es leben, kann sagen, sorry, aber geht nicht.
Wir sind hier mitten in einem hochpolitischen Aushandlungsprozess,
der sich dann immer wieder niederschlägt.
Ich glaube, alle unsere Hörer sind klug genug, um zu verstehen,
sodass wir abkürzen können. Wir haben jetzt über das Dating gesprochen.
Paare finden sich, verlieben sich aneinander, gestalten ihr Leben zusammen und
so weiter und so fort. und,
co-evaluierend mit diesem Thema, es ist ganz nah verknüpft, ist die Frage Wohnen.
Gefühl, Geld, Treffen, Treffpunkt, es ist ein richtiges Matching-Thema,
wenn wir jetzt über das Wohnen reden, indem wir so über das Dating gesprochen haben.
Und es ergab sich Erstaunliches zu Jahresanfang, es fand das Highlight jetzt
im Februar statt, aber wir können noch ein bisschen auf den Januar zurückgreifen.
Jetzt gerade zum Beispiel mehr als 200.000 Hamburger Haushalte bekommen Post,
weil der Mietspiegel angepasst wurde.
Die Miete darf bis zu 5,8% angehoben werden. Die städtischen Vermieter sagen,
wir sind ein bisschen gnädig, wir machen nur 4 oder so.
Plus Index-Mietverträge gibt es in Hamburg auch 100.000-fach.
Die kriegen natürlich auch gerade Post, weil 10% Inflation heißt, Mieterhöhung 10%.
Also das ist die Regel, da kommt man dann nicht raus und das ist ja ein Skandal
für sich. Wir haben es ja schon thematisiert. Hier ein kleiner Börsenbericht
zum Thema Wohnen. Wo ist eigentlich das Problem? Das ist so Mitte Februar.
Die Stimmung im deutschen Wohnungsbau ist an einem Tiefpunkt angekommen.
In einer Umfrage des IFO-Institutes bewerten Bauunternehmen sowohl die aktuelle
Lage als auch die Aussichten so schlecht wie noch nie seit 1991.
Neue Aufträge blieben aus oder Planungen und Projekte werden gestoppt.
Mehr dazu von Markus Gürner.
Es fehlt an Geld, an Vertrauen und auch an Aufträgen von öffentlicher Seite.
Denn die Regierung wollte mal 400.000 Wohnungen pro Jahr bauen.
In diesem Jahr werden es wohl nur knapp halb so viele, sagt das Forschungsinstitut IMK.
Wer bauen will, hat mit hohen Baukosten und mit hohen Zinsen zu kämpfen.
Hoffnung legt die Bauwirtschaft vor allem in die Europäische Notenbank.
Denn die EZB könnte angesichts sinkender Inflation den Leitzins in diesem Jahr senken.
Damit würden dann Finanzierungen günstiger und vor allem attraktiver werden.
Sinkende Zinsen wären zwar keine Sonderkonjunktur, aber ein hilfreicher Impuls.
So, nichts davon ist unerwartet. Ich war ja letztes Jahr um diese Zeit bei dieser
Tagung da in Berlin, wo die ganze Baubranche einmal da war und da stand ja der
Immobilienweise da und meinte, das ganze Ding fährt jetzt einmal vor die Wand.
Wir geben gerade nochmal richtig Gas, aber die Zinswende, Baukosten haben sich
verdoppelt innerhalb von zehn Jahren und die Kreditkosten quasi verdrei- oder vierfacht.
Das ist kein gutes Zeichen. Die größte Angst ist, die ganze Baubranche muss
den Baubetrieb für ein, zwei Jahre einstellen.
Es gibt gar keine neuen Aufträge. Es ist ja genau so gekommen.
Zinswende und so weiter sorgte dafür.
Wir verlieren alle Mitarbeiter, die wir auf der Baustelle haben.
Das sind aber keine deutschen Nachwuchskräfte, die mal kurz was anderes machen,
sondern das sind einfach Gruppen, riesige Kohorten ausländischer Fast-Rentner.
Wenn die einmal verloren sind, sind die verloren. Also die kann man nicht einfach
wieder anwerben, die ziehen weiter
nach Polen oder nach Spanien oder nach Frankreich oder wie auch immer.
Also da ist einfach ein großer Verlust. Man hat so vom Gastro-Effekt gesprochen.
Die Studenten suchen sich einen anderen Nebenjob, die kommen nicht einfach zum
Kellner zurück, nur weil es plötzlich heißt, ja wir könnten jetzt mal wieder
zwei Monate irgendwas anbieten oder so.
Jetzt Marietta Slomka, die also am 20.02. wie folgt moderiert.
Dass einzelne Wirtschaftszweige über ihr Schicksal klagen, ist natürlich nicht
neu. Geklagt wird ja eigentlich immer.
Aber was sich derzeit in der Baubranche abspielt, ist tatsächlich dramatisch.
Das bestätigt auch der heute vorgestellte Bericht der sogenannten Immobilienweisen.
Der Einbruch kam praktisch ungebremst und plötzlich.
Und lässt das noch vor zwei Jahren von der Bundesregierung ausgerufene Ziel
Ziel von jährlich 400.000 neuen Wohnungen, geradezu absurd aussehen.
Plötzlich?
Es kam ganz plötzlich für Marita Slomka. Keiner konnte es vorhersehen.
Ungebremst und plötzlich. Ja, ich verstehe sowas nicht.
Also das ist mir völlig undenkbar, wie man so, gerade weil wir es hier mit einem
grundlegenden Problem zu tun haben, das sich mittlerweile wirklich kulturell
niederschlägt. Dass niemand baut.
Dass es Ideen gibt, wie man bauen könnte, die aber keiner zieht und stattdessen
geil wird es irgendwie da sitzt und meint, ja, wir fördern jemanden noch ein bisschen oder so.
Das schlägt sich ja mittlerweile überall nieder. Wir hören mal rein,
beispielhaft in den Podcast Feuer und Brot von Alice Hastas und Freundin Maxi,
Nachname, keine Ahnung, steht auch nicht auf der Webseite.
Wir hören einfach so die Reden über das Manifestieren, das haben wir auch schon gemacht.
Und dann gleicht man natürlich ab, was kann man sich wünschen,
was ist die Realität und so weiter. Wir hören mal, welche Themen da so eingeflochten werden.
Und sage, nee, warum träumst du von so dusseligen Sachen? Lass es doch.
Du hast genug im Hier und Jetzt zu tun. Und das ist schade. Und deswegen ist
so eine Idee von, ich erstelle mir noch in meinem Kopf eine Idee davon,
wie ich mal leben möchte oder was ich mir wünsche.
Das ist für mich halt ein total schöner Aspekt daran. Und sich irgendwie zum
Beispiel immer zu sagen, du wirst eh nie wieder umziehen, du musst alles so bleiben, wie es ist.
Das macht mich halt manchmal dann traurig oder unzufrieden und umso schöner
ist es doch zu sagen, aber ich kann mir das doch vorstellen und wünschen.
Und wenn ich, und das haben wir ja eigentlich schon in Ansätzen gesagt,
aber das auch nur nochmal so klar gesagt,
es hat natürlich etwas Motivierendes und kann auch eine eigene Kraft natürlich
entfalten, wenn ich etwas ständig vor Augen habe und mich in diese Richtung
auch motiviere. Ist ja klar.
Ja, man denkt immer manifestieren. Ja, was manifestieren sich die jungen Leute so?
Den Mr. Perfect, die Millioneneinkommen oder was auch immer?
Nö, einfach mal wieder umzuziehen.
Das verfällt jetzt schon ins Manifestieren, weil es in der Realität einfach ausgeschlossen ist.
Es macht sie traurig, dass sie eigentlich in der Welt lebt, von der sie weiß,
du wirst eh nie wieder umziehen.
Es gibt diese Wohnung nicht, sie werden nicht bezahlbar sein du wirst für immer
da sein, wo du jetzt bist und was nicht im Rahmen dessen, was da ist für dich,
Das ist kein Leben mehr. Du kannst keine Biografie gestalten.
Und das finde ich wirklich mega dramatisch. So, jetzt gab es im Januar einen Hinweis.
Jetzt befassen wir uns gleich mit den
Immobilienweisen. Das ist natürlich Bundespressekonferenz und so weiter.
Es gibt aber auch ein Bündnis aus Mieterbund, Baugewerkschaften,
Sozial- und Branchenverbänden.
Die nennen sich Bündnis Soziales Wohnen und die haben eine Studie in Auftrag
gegeben mit folgendem Ergebnis.
In Deutschland fehlen laut einer Studie mehr als 910.000 Sozialwohnungen.
Die Untersuchung des Pestel-Instituts aus Hannover wurde heute von einem Bündnis
aus Mieterbund, Baugewerkschaft und Sozialverbänden vorgestellt.
Es wirft der Bundesregierung vor, die Förderung massiv vernachlässigt zu haben.
Besonders viele Sozialwohnungen fehlten in Baden-Württemberg,
Bayern, Berlin und Niedersachsen.
So, ein großes Bündnis verschiedener Verbände und Branchen und so weiter sagt,
es fehlen 910.000 Sozialwohnungen.
Vor allem in Bayern, Baden-Württemberg und Berlin.
Finden wir das jetzt intuitiv plausibel? Ja oder nein?
Ja. Ich würde sagen, ja. Also es fehlen 910.000 bezahlbare und darüber hinaus
nochmal in den Ballungsgebieten weitere eine Million Wohnungen.
Unsere Bauministerin zum Thema.
Das heißt 910.000 Wohnungen, die fehlen, das ist tatsächlich eine realistische Zahl.
Also die Pestel-Studie, auf die Sie anspielen, halte ich persönlich für hochgradig
unseriös. Das sind Zahlen, die die Kollegen sich ausgedacht haben.
Das kommt dann auch zu relativ absurden Ergebnissen. Zum Beispiel ist der Fehlbedarf
an Sozialwohnungen in Nordrhein-Westfalen wesentlich kleiner als in Sachsen,
wo angeblich zehnmal so viele Sozialwohnungen fehlen würden. Das ist nicht seriös.
Soll ich dir mal sagen, was die SPD in ihrem Europawahlprogramm stehen hat?
Dass man sich dafür stark machen wird, dass die Europapolitik so aussieht,
dass mehr Sozialwohnungen entstehen.
Und sie schreiben diesen Text in dieses Programm und man denkt so,
schick das doch einfach mal an Geiwitz.
Ich halte das für unseriös und
ausgedachte Zahlen, sowas überhaupt zu fordern. Es fehlt ja gar nichts.
Außerdem, irgendwer hat irgendwie da reingeschrieben, dass Nordrhein-Westfalen,
also da würde ich mal prüfen, ob das wirklich da drin steht.
Nun gut, sie nimmt sich da irgendein Ding raus und sagt, nee, nee, nee, nee, so.
Sie distanziert sich also im Januar von dieser Pestelstudie,
die sagt, 910.000 Sozialwohnungen fehlen.
Setzt sich aber bei den Immobilienweisen dazu, weil sie weiß,
mit denen kann ich mich jetzt nicht anlegen. Also da muss ich jetzt double down all in gehen.
Das sind meine Freunde und das Problem ist die Vorgängerregierung oder irgendwas.
Man braucht jetzt hier eine Strategie.
Also es beginnt diese Veranstaltung der Immobilienweisen jetzt am 20.
Wenn man alle Einflussfaktoren auf den Bedarf an Wohnungen saldiert,
dass uns im nächsten Jahr ungefähr 720.000 Wohnungen fehlen werden.
Sie müssen sich das so vorstellen, das ist der gesamte Wohnungsbestand im Saarland,
und dem Bremen zusammen und es wird schlimmer.
In 2027 werden es 830.000 Wohnungen sein, immer vorausgesetzt,
es wird nicht noch größere Flüchtlingsströme geben.
Ja, bei dieser Frage, was ist jetzt der Unterschied zwischen 910.000 Sozialwohnungen
und, ja gut, 800.000 Wohnungen müssen aber nicht Sozialwohnungen sein.
Ja. Es ist im Grunde dasselbe. Das ganze Land hat mittlerweile Anspruch auf
eine soziale Förderung und so.
Also es ist in der Hinsicht, da sitzt sie dann plötzlich mit auf der Bühne.
Finde ich schon mal verlogen. Verlogen, das Thema so weit wie möglich abstreiten,
bis dann, naja gut, die Immobilienweisen, den Eintermin im Jahr muss ich dann halt machen.
Gut, er macht natürlich hier so einen besonders flotten Spruch,
denn warum gibt es keine Wohnungen, obwohl die ja so hochpreisig nachgefragt
werden, weil irgendwas im Gefüge nicht steht, auf das gehen wir ein.
Er setzt folgendes Paradigma.
Und um es ganz plakativ zu sagen, wer heute baut, geht bankrott.
So, jetzt haben wir ja im Journalismus schon gehört, es kam plötzlich und so weiter ein Einbruch.
Jetzt habe ich gesagt, vor einem Jahr standen die schon auf der Bühne,
also diese Immobilienweisen haben gesagt, wir fahren hier vor die Wand.
Wir können uns das noch nicht ganz vorstellen, aber wir haben einen sogenannten
Bauüberhang. Es dauert ja immer eine Weile, die ersten Verträge werden gemacht,
es wird geplant, Gewerke werden beauftragt, Finanzierung ist geklärt,
dann gehen Jahre ins Land und irgendwann ist es fertig.
Also wenn die jetzt sagen, okay, wir haben Bauüberhang, nächstes Jahr sieht
es schon ganz anders aus. Ja, sind wir jetzt schon an die Wand gefahren oder
fahren wir immer noch an die Wand?
Also es klang ja schon sehr dramatisch, es fehlen so und so viele Wohnungen
und so, aber ist das vielleicht immer noch der Weg zur Katastrophe,
also sind wir noch gar nicht angekommen? Dazu hat er folgende Einschätzung.
Das heißt, wir erleben noch immer, und das wird noch bis in 2025 reingehen,
Fertigstellungen aus der alten schönen Zeit.
Und die war doppelt gut, weil sie mit einem Prozent finanziert worden ist.
Das reicht schon, um noch heute diese Dinge fertigzustellen.
Und sie haben einen Nachlauf aus etwa dem großen von mir eben erwähnten KFW 55-Programm.
Sie können noch 48 Monate lang nach Bewilligung diese Mittel in Anspruch nehmen.
Das heißt, wir leben von der Vergangenheit. Das muss man deutlich sehen.
Und deswegen gehen wir ja hin in der ersten Tabelle, die wir ihnen gegeben haben
und tun eine Reihe von Faktoren, versuchen miteinander aufzulösen und zu prognostizieren
und kommen dann zu solchen Ergebnissen.
Also wir leben noch in der Vergangenheit, noch wird gebaut.
Wir fahren gerade noch gegen die Wand. Es kann noch 48 Monate so,
aber genauso träge, wie wir das dann verzögert merken, ist dieser sogenannte
Hochlauf, wie jetzt immer alle sagen, genauso ein Drama.
Er sagt doch an einer Stelle auch, ja mit Immobilien ist das ja so,
dass sie nicht mobil sind. Sie sind geplant und dann werden sie irgendwann gemacht.
Es ist ein sehr träges, fleppendes Gut, das einfach entweder stattfindet oder nicht. So und jetzt?
Hast du das, was er zur Miete sagt, wie hoch die Miete sein müsste dabei?
Weil er ja eben jetzt sagte.
Der… Er spricht ja von, eine 70 Quadratmeter Wohnung müsste 1500 Euro kosten,
damit sie überhaupt finanzierbar, planbar ist, also überhaupt als Bauprojekt
durchgezogen zu werden.
Ja, als anderen Zahlen nennt er noch, dass also pro Quadratmeter 21 Euro verlangt
werden müssten, damit das sich für die Immobilienindustrie deckt und damit eine
schwarze Null rauskommt.
Das kann er aber so natürlich man machen, aber man wird sie nicht bekommen.
Also das hat er einmal durchgerechnet, diese 21 Euro und 1500 Euro für 70 Quadratmeter
und dann kam seine Schlussfolgerung, wer heute baut, geht bankrott.
Was ja bedeutet, bankrott heißt, der ist dann einfach nicht mehr am Markt.
Jetzt kommt ja Clara Gawitz und sagt, wir fördern hier mal noch ein bisschen,
wir machen da noch ein neues Projekt und so weiter. Dazu sagt der Folgendes.
Ich konzentriere mich im Moment wirklich auf die Frage, dass gebaut werden kann.
Weil wir sind in der Frage, dass man digitalisiert, dass die vielen Maßnahmen,
die wir im Bündnis beschlossen haben, was nicht 180 oder was auch immer, goldrichtig sind.
Nur lassen Sie mich die Wahrheit nochmal sagen.
Wir können nicht etwas beschleunigen, was wir gar nicht bauen können.
Das heißt, ich konzentriere mich jetzt erstmal darauf, dass wir bauen können.
Und da geht es nicht ohne solche Wirkung.
So, wenn jemand sagt, Bauzinsen 3-4%, ich baue nicht.
Dann ist das Förderprogramm egal. Dann gibt es da weder was zu digitalisieren,
noch zu beschleunigen, noch so weiter. Dann wird einfach nichts gebaut.
So, dann hat man einfach eine Lücke von Jahren.
Wenn dann die Politik so, achso, wir sollten mal was machen,
ja, bis dann die ersten Verträge geschrieben, die Gewerke eingeladen,
die Ausschreibung gemacht und so weiter, dauert es auch wieder fünf Jahre,
bis dann sowas wieder anläuft.
Also wir haben eine wirklich hochgradig dramatische Situation,
weil jetzt, nachdem der Wohnungsmarkt quasi ausgefallen ist und junge Frauen
schon sagen, ich ziehe eh nie wieder um, fällt jetzt auch noch die Baubranche
hinterher aus, die überhaupt als einzige da Linderung verschaffen kann.
Weil klar, wir haben irgendwelche Wohnungen, aber sie sind eben immobil,
sie nützen uns nichts in der Eifel oder in Sachsen oder irgendwo.
Es sind die Urbanzentren, die Urbanisierung ist das, was bleibt.
Und ich sprach kürzlich mit einem Architekten darüber, wie denn das ist alles
mit diesen KfW-Förderungen jetzt und ob das dann nicht ein Anreiz sei zu bauen.
Er sagte nein, natürlich nicht, denn solche Sachen kosten ja erst einmal Geld.
Man kriegt dann vergünstigte Kredite und so etwas dafür.
Aber die an sich, die Bausumme ist ja noch höher dadurch.
Mag sein, dass sich das irgendwann amortisiert. Nur erstmal ist die Hürde dann zu bauen noch größer.
Also rät er den Leuten, die bauen wollen jetzt und das auch gerne schnell hätten
und dann noch bezahlbar, davon dringend ab.
Das heißt, dadurch, dass die Lage so ist, wird weniger energieeffizient gebaut.
Ja, es ist ein ganz großes Drama. Und jetzt haben wir schon gehört,
der Mattner ist so ein bisschen okay. Der erkennt irgendwie so Probleme an.
Neben ihm sitzt Lars Feld.
Der ist in diesen Gutachten zuständig für die gesamtwirtschaftliche Lage,
die er besonders gut im Blick hat. Und wir kennen ihn ja als Verfechter des,
nee, das sind Strukturänderungen, die müssen halt ausgelebt werden.
Da darf der Staat nicht eingreifen. Wenn Player vom Markt verschwinden,
verschwinden sie erstmal.
Die hinterlassen ja glücklicherweise eine Lücke und dann springt da wieder jemand rein.
Also eine völlig asoziale, mini-axoletaristische Vorgehensweise.
Es muss alles einmal selbstständig vor eine Wand fahren, die Politik darf da
nicht eingreifen. Madna,
Kennt natürlich, wie Lars Feld da argumentiert und in einem Punkt sagt er jetzt,
da sind wir uns mal einig mit folgendem.
Und jetzt bin ich mal, verbinde ich mich mal wieder mit Professor Feld,
der ja sehr deutlich gesagt hat, wir müssen runter von den staatlichen Abgaben,
Unterwerbsteuer und ähnliches.
Ich will Ihnen nochmal eine Zahl auf Ihre erste Frage geben,
dass Sie mal ein Gefühl dafür bekommen.
Die stärkste Förderung, die wir je in Deutschland haben, war die eben genannte
KfW 55, die vor mir aus 10 Jahren oder was auch immer gekostet.
Sie hat in unseren Wirtschaftlichkeitsrechnungen lediglich 5% ausgemacht, 5% Verbesserung.
Und wenn Sie jetzt die 37% Staatsabgaben daneben setzen, dann habe ich eine tolle Idee.
Lass uns doch auf 10% Staatsabgaben verzichten, verzichten wir auf die ganze Förderung dort.
Wir sparen uns eine Riesenbürokratie und können sofort loslegen.
So, die Staatsquote im Bauen, 37 Prozent, bedeutet alles zusammengerechnet,
die Lohnnebenkosten für irgendwelche Gewerke, die da arbeiten,
die Grunderwerbssteuer, irgendwelche Steuerkram und so weiter.
Umsatzsteuer.
Umsatzsteuer mündet im Gesamtkostenapparat, der mobilisiert werden muss,
damit zwei Leute sich ein Haus mit einem Wohnzimmer, einer Küche und zwei Kinderzimmern bauen.
37 Prozent davon geht an den Staat. Auf der einen oder anderen Weise.
Das größte Förderprogramm, das je aufgelegt wurde, von dem Habeck sogar damals,
ich weiß noch, beim Wohnbautag auf der Bühne stand und meinte,
wenn ihr sowieso nach diesem EH-Dings 55 Standard baut, sagt uns das doch,
dann fördern wir das nicht extra, sondern wenn das eh Standard ist,
wir wollen hier und so, und da hat er irgendwie versucht.
So, das war also damals das größte Programm und das hat die Gesamtkostenlast um 5% gesenkt.
Man könnte jetzt also rechnen, okay, eine Grunderwerbsteuer alleine zu erlassen,
könnte schon ganz schön viele Förderprogramme ansonsten rausnehmen.
Und ich habe Tilman Kuban im Podcast gehört bei Table Media,
der meinte dann, er nennt das Förderitis,
wenn man Geld über Steuern und Abgaben abzieht, dann Förderprogramme entwickelt
und die auf dasselbe Problem, von dem man vorher abkassiert hat, wieder drauf legt.
So und ich bin nicht ganz abgeneigt, Förderitis als Problem mal zu thematisieren,
zum Beispiel beim Thema Wohngeld oder so.
Das ist ja auch so eine Förderitis, die völlig fehlgeleitet einfach den Markt
künstlich hochhebt oder wie auch immer.
Nur würde ich jetzt mal gerade einhaken wollen bei dieser Staatsquote 37 Prozent
und dann hast du jetzt gerade gesagt, wovon die sich zusammensetzt und wir wissen
ja eine Grunderwerbssteuer beträgt je nach Bundesland irgendwas zwischen 3,5 und 6,5 Prozent.
Das ist ja gar nicht so viel, das heißt würde man die ganz weg streichen,
wäre man immer noch bei einer hohen Quote und das ist ja aber auch hier bei
dieser Staatsquote das einzige, was man überhaupt weg streichen könnte,
denn man müsste ja sonst verminderte Mehrwertsteuer anbieten oder.
Genau, das ist jetzt die Frage, da gehen wir jetzt darauf ein,
wie geht man mit solchen Sachen um?
Also ich habe ja schon mal das Modell vorgeschlagen, eine Grunderwerbsteuer
streichen, weil sie bei der Größe der Grundstücke und der Häuser,
die darauf entstehen, so ziemlich eins zu eins die Kosten einer Solaranlage ersetzt.
Also man könnte sagen, keine Grunderwerbssteuer, dafür verpflichtende Solaranlage,
damit hätten alle was davon,
außer der Staatssäckel, wie wir gleich hören, aber dafür haben wir ja ein ziemlich
großes Klimaprogramm, da wird eine neue versiegelte Fläche, direkt mal ein Solardach
drauf und so weiter, solche Programme.
Nur um das deutlich zu machen, weil das mit dieser Staatsquote jetzt so verrückt
klingt, man kann jetzt auch sagen, ja, das ist ja bei einem Lohn auch so.
Also wenn ich jetzt meinen Bruttolohn
versteuere, dann werde ich auch bei irgendwie 37 Prozent etwa sein.
Ja, ja, genau. Die Frage ist halt, genau, also du hast absolut recht,
haben wir es beim Thema Wohnen mit so einem speziellen Thema zu tun, bei dem wir sagen …,
Da brauchen wir spezifische Leitzinsen, spezifische Umsatzsteuerzugriffe und
eben bei der Frage, gelten manche Sachen nicht.
Also wenn ich zum Osteopathen gehe, bezahle ich keine Umsatzsteuer.
Wenn ich jemanden bezahle, der mir ein sicheres Kinderzimmer baut zum Schutz
meiner Kinder, bezahle ich Umsatzsteuer.
Also könnte man ja auch solche Erwägungen und das ist eben jetzt dieser Punkt
Februar 2024, wo alles mal so auf den Tisch soll. Also wo man wirklich mal alles durchdiskutiert.
Und eines dieser Themen, die Sie hier durchdiskutieren, klar,
Lars Feld hat es wahrscheinlich mit angestoßen, ist diese Staatsquote.
Also könnte man den Wohnungsmarkt hier mal besonders ausflacken.
37 Prozent, da setzt sich Mattner jetzt sehr an die Seite von Lars Feld mit einem Spruch.
Wenn die Staatsquote nicht 37 Prozent wäre, sondern wie etwa bei unserem Nachbarn
in Frankreich nur 22 Prozent oder in Schweden so ähnlich, dann würde die Miete,
schon die 21-Euro-Miete, sich reduzieren um drei Euro.
Oder wenn wir bei den Mieten in der Vorkrisenzeit wären von 15 Euro,
könnte man die auf 12 Euro runterbringen, wenn der Staat sich noch nicht mal
gänzlich von Abgaben entfernt,
sondern wenn er nur von 37% auf 32% runtergeben würde.
Ich muss es hier einmal deutlich sagen, weil dort viel Falsches gesagt wird,
wer dafür verursacht, verursächlich ist.
Es ist der Staat, der hier die fette Beute macht.
Und ich bin geneigt, dem so ein bisschen zuzustimmen.
Denn wenn die Baukosten so hoch sind, dass keiner mehr baut und damit ganz viele
Biografien nicht in der gewünschten Form zustande kommen,
dann macht es keinen Sinn, diese Staatsquote im Sinne von Belastung dieser Biografie,
weil man konkret das benennen kann, um was es geht, weiterzutreiben.
Es ist so ungefähr im Großen wie im Kleinen so eine Rechnung aufgemacht wird,
könnte man nicht sagen, manche Sachen im Supermarkt, die Grundlage sind oder
Schulmittel oder Hygieneartikel sind umsatzsteuerbefreit, weil man das einfach
ausflaggt als ist wünschenswert,
wir haben ja von Scott Galloway gehört, wie wünschenswert es ist,
dass man relativ früh in seinem Leben dann doch mal zu der entweder bezahlbaren
Mietwohnung oder vielleicht sogar zu Wohneigentum kommt.
Dem steht jetzt hier der Staat im Wege. Und die Beispiele Frankreich,
22 Prozent Staatsquote im Vergleich zu 37 Prozent in Deutschland.
Also das heißt ja, Spielräume sind irgendwie da. Und wenn das bedeutet,
drei Euro Miete im Monat, dann sind wir schon bei 15 Prozent Mietsenkung.
Statt wie jetzt in Hamburg 5,8 Prozent nach oben.
Aber erheblichen Einnahmeverlusten auf Seiten des Staates.
Und jetzt ist ja die Frage der Refinanzierung. Fehlt das Geld volkswirtschaftlich
oder ziehen wir es gerade nur aus der falschen Richtung ab? Wir könnten ja genauso
gut Erbschaftssteuer, Kapitalertragssteuer und so weiter.
Aber das müsste man dann machen. Müsste man gemeinsam rechnen.
Diese verminderte Mehrwertsteuer, die ja auch immer wieder gefordert wird auf
lebensnotwendige Produkte, also dass sie dort,
da gibt es sie ja zum größten Teil, aber dass sie dort ganz abgeschafft wird,
das wäre etwas, was man hier tatsächlich überlegen könnte, aber wird da nur
mit Umverteilung gehen.
Neue Schulden will man ja offenbar nicht machen und man kann es natürlich auch
nochmal so rechnen, dass das Geld, das da mehr vorhanden ist dadurch,
das geht ja in der Regel wieder in die Wirtschaft rein, also das wird ja auch
dann ausgegeben und dadurch, dass jetzt alles so teuer ist und gar nicht gebaut
wird, davon hat der Staat ja auch nichts, also da kassiert er auch noch nicht
mal eine Grunderwerbsteuer.
Ja, also es ist ein schwieriges Gefüge, bei dem ich aber auch jetzt in der Priorität abwägen würde.
Ist es wichtiger, jemanden mit Wohnraum zu versorgen oder ist es wichtiger,
dass der Staat auch da noch sein, was auch immer, wie man es dann lehrgerechten
Anteil erhält oder sowas.
Also manche Sachen kann man ja auch im Sinne von die Investition in Wohneigentum
für zu gesünderen, psychischen, jungen Männer, die dann auch im Erwerbsleben
und so weiter, also ein richtiges Scott Galloway-Mega-Theorie drüber bauen.
Will ich mal noch einhaken, er tut das jetzt natürlich auch so ein bisschen,
also heute spielen alle so ein bisschen, bei Fuß haben wir es auch schon erlebt,
Sozialismus und sagt, ja es gibt so einen Bedarf und den würden wir eigentlich
gerne befriedigen, aber es ist so teuer mit dem Bauen.
Und nun ist es ja so, dass er nicht nur Leute vertritt, die mal ein Eigenheim
für sich bauen und dann ein Leben lang da drin wohnen, sondern er vertritt ja
die Immobilienindustrie.
Und die Immobilienindustrie profitiert ja sehr gut dadurch, dass verknappt wird.
Sie profitiert dann, wenn jetzt die Zinsen so hoch sind, irgendwann nicht mehr,
weil dann kann man die Mieten nicht mehr nochmal in die Höhe weiter treiben
und man kann da die Spielräume nicht mehr weiter ausweiten.
Man versucht es ja jetzt gerade mit Mieterhöhungen, aber man kann zumindest
dann nichts Neues bauen, weil die Kredite zu hoch sind.
Aber generell ist die Immobilienindustrie ja nicht daran interessiert,
dass alle gut und günstig leben können, sondern die Verknappung sorgt ja gerade
dafür, dass Leute wie die, die er vertritt, sehr viel Geld machen.
Deswegen muss man glaube ich das mit dieser Staatsquote, auch wenn ich das zustimme
und da jetzt auch nicht sagen würde, da muss der Staat auch mal ruhig zulangen,
muss man es skeptisch sehen,
weil natürlich seine Industrie das Problem ist und er zum Beispiel derjenige
wäre, der wahrscheinlich aufspringen und gehen würde, wenn jetzt Geiwitz verkünden würde,
ja wir bauen jetzt von Seiten des Staates 200.000.
Wohnungen. Das lassen wir uns mal offen als Thema, weil das Geld,
also da kommen wir nachher drauf zurück. Die Frage hier ist ja…,
schätzt man gerade in der Lage richtig ein oder nicht. Also sowohl wir als auch die Politiker.
Denn wir haben hier in Frankfurt das Phänomen, dass wirklich sehr große Investitionen,
wo alleine Grundstücke für 200 Millionen Euro gekauft werden und danach erst
die Bauinvestitionen in Milliardenhöhe kommt, ausfallen.
Und zwar nicht, weil dem Eigentümer das Projekt sich nicht mehr rechnet,
sondern weil der Eigentümer einfach pleite geht.
Ist einfach nicht mehr existent, nicht mehr am Markt. Und solche Kalkulationen,
wenn die ausfallen, dann läuft wirklich was schief.
Wir haben es auch bei Benko mal kurz thematisiert. Ja, man kann jetzt immer
auf Benko reinhauen und sagen, der kriegt es nicht hin oder so.
Aber es dreht sich hier wirklich gerade ein ganzer Markt und der überstrahlt auch alles.
Also diese Immobilieninvestitionen, gerade hier in Frankfurt und so,
das sind so immense, immense, immense, immense Werte.
Es gibt in Frankfurt einzelne Gebäude, die sind doppelt bis dreifach so teuer,
wie dieser Gewerbesteuerüberschuss, den Frankfurt hat und so weiter.
Also da kann man nicht einfach mal die eine Rechnung mit der anderen,
ach so ist was am Markt, dann machen wir ein Nothilfeprogramm.
Nein, das kriegt man nicht mehr aufgefangen. Also hier sterben einfach so richtig Märkte weg. weg.
Ja, die Eigner werden ihre Millionen in Sicherheit gebracht haben für sich, aber es gehen trotzdem.
Milliardenwerte einfach, werden so aus dem Betrieb rausgezogen,
was bedeutet, okay, hier löst sich gerade so eine ganze materielle Industrie einfach auf.
Also ich finde es wirklich brenzlig, wenn man sich so mal die Einzelheiten,
man hört ja dann auch von Leuten, ja, den kenne ich, diesen Düsseldorfer Investor,
da habe ich einen Freund, der da arbeitet, also es ist wirklich,
da zittern mittlerweile bei allen die Hände, Also es ist schlimm, schlimm, schlimm.
Gut, Geiwitz betont so, wir investieren jetzt 18 Milliarden in sozialen Wohnungsbau.
Das verbuchen wir mal unter der Frage, die wir später aufgreifen.
Ja, kann sie das nicht direkt investieren irgendwie?
Muss sie das wieder irgendeinem privaten Akteur geben, der dann hofft,
dass seine Kalkulation irgendwie hinhaut?
Mattner, macht ihr mal diesen Problembogen auf? Wenn wir immer sagen,
Staatsquote, der Staat, ja wer profitiert genau?
Das mag man doch bitte jetzt mal aussetzen für zwei Jahre. Diese beiden Sachen
würden reichen, um auf 10 Prozent zu kommen.
Er redet von einer Grunderwerbsteuer zum Beispiel. Also er fordert ja konkret
mal für zwei Jahre keine Grunderwerbsteuer erheben. ...
Zu kommen. Grunderwerbsteuer und die kommunalen Abschöpfungsmodelle.
Und ich habe ja eben auf die erste Frage nochmal gesagt,
wenn 10 Prozent weg wären, das wäre die doppelte Förderung in Anführungsstrichen
und es wäre keine Subvention gegenüber dem, was wir vorher gehabt hätten.
Nochmal rübergelehnt zu Lars Feld, das ist auch keine Subvention,
keine Angst, wir sagen nur, wir setzen mal für zwei Jahre so eine Grunderwerbsteuer
aus, damit es überhaupt zu Bauprojekten kommt.
Also einfach so ein kleiner Kickstart, so ein kleiner Katalysator.
Jetzt Skywitz zur Grunderwerbsteuer.
Das Land macht keine fette Beute, sondern die haben die Grunderwerbsteuer,
ich war ja auch 15 Jahre Landtagsabgeordnete, erhöht, weil sie die Polizisten
bezahlen und weil sie auch mehr Polizisten brauchen,
weil sie mehr Kindergärtnerinnen und mehr Lehrer bezahlen.
Wunderbar, wenn wir mehr Kinder haben und, und, und.
Das heißt, da sitzt ja keiner auf einem Sack Geld.
Also ich habe Christian Lindner vor kurzem getroffen. Er sah jetzt nicht aus wie Dagobert Dack.
Sondern wir nehmen diese Einnahmen, um damit natürlich Daseinsvorsorge und Sachen
für die Bürger zu bezahlen.
Nur haben wir das leider so kompliziert organisiert, dass man jetzt nur noch
bauen kann, wenn Clara Geibitz oben fördert, damit dann unten in der Mitte die
Länder noch Unterwerpsteuer kriegen Es.
Gibt also einen Streit darüber, wie katalysiert man jetzt diesen kleinen Kickstarter,
den man braucht? Macht man von oben Förderprogramme?
Baukindergeld oder sowas? Der Bund zahlt?
Oder müssen die Länder auf die Grunderwerbssteuer verzichten?
Das ist also ein Aushandlungsprozess.
Und wenn man jetzt sagt, Clara Geiwitz ist in Verantwortung und sie sagt,
naja, ich habe ja 18 Milliarden bezahlt, aber die Länder nutzen,
ah ja, dann kommt sie wieder da zu Geldflüssen, wir greifen die mal ab,
dann steht man sich da selbst im Wege.
Dass sie da so komische Sprüche mit Dagobert Duck macht und so, ist natürlich lame.
Und die Idee wäre jetzt von dir, man sagt, man streicht die Grunderwerbssteuer,
sie nimmt ihre Milliarden und gibt sie den Ländern direkt, dann haben die keinen Verlust.
Ja, genau. Man kann es einfach eins zu eins verrechnen oder geht eben grundsätzlich
in so ein, ich will es schon mal auch erwähnen, das öffentliche Bauen.
Man kann durchaus mit dem ganzen Geld, das der Politik zur Verfügung steht,
gerade wenn man so ein sicheres Gut hat.
Man weiß ja, wenn wir jetzt in Berlin eine Wohnung bauen, wir werden einen Mieter
oder Käufer oder was auch immer finden.
Das ist jetzt nicht das große Problem. Warum macht es der Staat dann da nicht selbst?
Lars fällt natürlich besonders scharf, wenn sich der Staat bereichert.
Erster Satz. Christian Lindner sieht nicht aus wie Dagobert Dugter, stimmt.
Und der Bund ist eben auch derjenige, der von den Gesamtsteuereinnahmen einen
deutlich geringeren Anteil hat.
Also man muss schon auch als Teil der Wahrheit feststellen, es sind die Länder
in ihrer Gesamtheit, die in den vergangenen Jahren deutliche Überschüsse gemacht haben.
Also auch in der Krise immer noch deutliche Überschüsse gemacht haben.
Und wir hören nur mal ganz kurz in den allerletzten Satz von dem Mattner rein
und interpretieren ihn mal wohlwollend.
Und die Länder müssen hier meines Erachtens ihrer Verantwortung eben auch nachkommen.
Und dann sollten sie, wenn Probleme in der Wirtschaft da sind,
erstens bei den Gemeinschaftssteuern, Stichwort Wachstumschancengesetz,
zweitens bei der Grunderwerbsteuer eben auch ihren Teil tragen und die Verbesserungen
für die Wirtschaft herbeiführen.
Was uns beweist, dass es eben leider nicht nur in die Kitas geht,
damit hätte ich ja kein Problem, sondern es geht in das allgemeine Staatssäckel und das ist das Problem.
So, Clara Geiwitz hat ja eben auf die Tränendrüse gedrückt, wenn die leider
keine Grunderwerbsteuer kriegen, ich war ja auch mal Landtagsabgeordneter,
dann können wir die Polizei nicht immer bezahlen und so.
Stimmt ja nicht, so eins zu eins. Wir haben ja nicht eine Abgabe,
die sagt, die Grunderwerbsteuer ist die Abgabe für die und so.
Also, sondern es ist, er sagt jetzt, dass das ins allgemeine Staatssäckel geht, ist das Problem.
Und da würde ich sagen, das kann man durchaus mal wohlwollend interpretieren,
ob wir nicht den Wohnungsmarkt grundsätzlich unter wirklich Special Interest
Daseinsvorsorge von allem entkoppeln.
Auch von der Zinsentwicklung oder wie auch immer. Ich nenne auch da gleich Beispiele.
Das ist ein eigenes Ding.
Und das würde dann bedeuten, wenn irgendwas dort im Sektor Immobilien bauen
besteuert wird, dann zweckgebunden für den Kindergarten?
Wenn jemand in München eine Immobilie kauft für 37.000 mehr Prozent als vor 60 Jahren,
dann sollte davon neben allen Steuerbelastungen eine zusätzliche Abgabe dazukommen,
die den direkten Infrastrukturumraum um diese Immobilie fördert.
U-Bahn-Stationen, billigere Kioskmieten, damit da ein bisschen was zu kaufen
gibt und so weiter und so fort. Und das gibt es ja in Deutschland so gar nicht.
Sondern man kriegt seine Mieter,
Lebt aber eigentlich schon in der Schweiz und überweist sich einfach 100% vom
Mietkonto auf sein Konto in der Schweiz und es bleibt nichts in München.
Die Städte werden ja leer gesogen von diesen Eignern, die einfach über Vermietung
alles abkassieren, die Miete so hoch treiben, wie es geht und dann nochmal vom
Staat ein Wohngeld obendrauf fordern und davon hat dieser soziale Nahraum gar nichts.
Also das ist ja eins der größten Sorgen.
Wir hören jetzt kurz im Deutschlandfunk der Tag, die im Januar schon mal kurz
thematisierten, wie dieses Gefüge aus Bauwirtschaft, Staat und so weiter hier zu verstehen ist.
Ich komme nochmal zurück auf das Bündnis Soziales Wohnen, weil das habe ich
noch nicht ganz geblickt. Vielleicht kannst du mir weiterhelfen.
Das sieht ja ein Dilemma.
Da geht es einerseits um den Zusammenhang von Mietübernahme durch den Staat.
Also das, was du ganz am Anfang auch schon mal erklärt hast und aber eben auf
steigende Mietkosten auf der anderen Seite. Wie hängt das miteinander zusammen?
Das habe ich noch nicht ganz geblickt. Das ist auch nicht ganz einfach zu verstehen.
Es ist im Grunde so, der Staat gibt, wie gesagt, jedes Jahr rund 20 Milliarden
Euro aus für Wohngeld und Co.
Also der Staat zahlt Leuten mit wenig Geld eine Art Subvention,
staatliches Wohngeld und Co. Und der Staat ist dann eben gezwungen,
die immer weiteren steigenden Mieten auf dem freien Wohnungsmarkt zu akzeptieren.
Also Stichwort Angebot und Nachfrage. Der Staat zahlt zum Teil sogar Mieten
für die Leute, die Wohngeldempfängerinnen und Empfänger sind,
die deutlich über der örtlichen Durchschnittsmiete liegen.
München wurde da heute als Beispiel genannt, als Extrembeispiel.
Und am Ende ist es so, dass natürlich die Menschen, die Wohngeldempfängerinnen
und Empfänger profitieren, weil sie nicht aus ihren Wohnungen geschmissen werden,
weil sie nicht umziehen müssen.
Aber natürlich profitieren auch private Vermieter. Denn die sagen ja,
naja klasse, die Miete, die ich von meinem Mieter bekomme, die kommt letztlich vom Amt.
Dann muss ich da nicht extra super großzügig sein mit der Miethöhe,
sondern kann durchaus das ausreizen, was rechtlich möglich ist.
Konstruktion, die Fürth vereinfacht gesagt hat,
Gelinde gesagt nicht gerade dazu, dass die Mieten unten bleiben,
sondern dass sie steigen. Sondern dass sie steigen. Okay, jetzt habe ich es
verstanden. Vielen Dank fürs Erklären.
Und stabilisiert wird es ja nur über diesen Bund-Länder-Dissens, der da einfach drin ist.
Dadurch muss immer irgendwer, irgendwem quasi die Steuereinnahmen über Steuerausgaben
sozusagen, Stadtsbudgetausgaben finanzieren.
Gut, also das könnte man grob anpassen, indem einfach Bund,
Länder einen Wohnungsschulterschluss machen und sagen, das französische Modell
muss hier möglich sein, mal 15% weg von dieser sinnlosen Belastung,
rechte Tasche, linke Tasche, damit einfach nicht so ein allzu hoher Betrag auf
der Rechnung steht, die so ein Bauherr dann hat.
Dann haben Sie hier über die Zinsen gesprochen, da wäre ja dasselbe möglich.
Lars Feld, kommt ihr mal mit diesem Automatismus? muss.
Jenseits der Sonderfaktoren haben wir aber auch einen Effekt,
der sich automatisch dann ergibt, wenn die Inflation hochgegangen ist und die
Geldpolitik mit höheren Zinssätzen versucht, die Inflation in den Griff zu bekommen.
Das hat sie gemacht. Das sind diese, wie Herr Mattner sagt, schlagartig oder
plötzlich angestiegene Zinsen. Es war ein schneller Zinsanstieg,
den man verkraften muss.
Und das bedeutet für alle Investoren, aber vor allen Dingen für die zinsreigible
unerhebliche Bauwirtschaft, dass sie in die Bredouille gerät und insofern muss
man sich nicht wundern, dass die Investitionen hier nicht im gleichen Umfang zustande kommen.
So, er sagt jetzt, das ist ein Zinseinstieg, den man verkraften muss,
da muss sich auch keiner wundern. Das waren seine Worte.
Und der Mattner hat das wahrscheinlich mit ihm sehr viel diskutiert,
im Gutachten kann man das vielleicht nachlesen, in der Pressekonferenz spielte
das dann so eine kleine Rolle, aber hier macht er mal ganz deutlich,
man kann durchaus einen eigenen Bauzins einführen.
Also dass der Leitzins bleibt, aber der Bauzins einfach ein anderer ist.
Aber so richtig wirksam sind nur die beiden Dinge, die ich angesprochen habe.
Zum einen die degressive AFA würde viel bewegen und unser Zinsprogramm,
weil man wie gesagt mit drei Milliarden plötzlich 100.000 Wohnungen fördern kann.
Programme, die es früher gab, große Programme in der Vergangenheit,
hatten Volumina von bis zu zehn Milliarden.
Nur, dass Sie da mal ein Gefühl haben, die sehr große EH55, also die klimatisch
bedingte Förderung, war eine solche.
Und deswegen glauben wir auch, dass mit dem geringen Beitrag,
den man für Zinsprogramme braucht, im höchsten Maße effizient etwas bewegt werden kann.
Sie haben den kleinen Unterschied zwischen Professor Feld und mir bemerkt.
Daraus machen wir beide kein Geheimnis, weil wir bei allen anderen Punkten einer Meinung sind.
Ich habe da eine andere Auffassung. Ich glaube nicht, dass es gegen die EZB-Wirkung geht.
Sie müssen sich vorstellen, dass wenn Sie das gesamte Kreditvolumen in Deutschland
mal zusammennehmen und daran mal, ich sag mal ganz groß,
9 Milliarden messen, die wir ja vorschlagen, dann sind das mal gerade 0,3 Prozent
und das ist für mich eine Nussschale, die gegen einen Tanker knallt, das ist egal.
So, er sagt, man kann einen eigenen Bauzins machen, der die EZB-Politik nicht
unterläuft, weil ja das Gesamtaufkommen dieses Volumens im Kreditrahmen Thema
Bauen nur 0, irgendwas der gesamtwirtschaftlichen Kreditlage.
Ich würde sagen, er hat jetzt die ganzen virtuellen Finanzmarktsachen damit eingepreist.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass die Kreditsachen in der Realwirtschaft nur
0, irgendwas Prozent ausmachen.
Aber die Argumentation von Lars Feld ist ja hier, EZB-Zinspolitik wird betrieben,
um die Inflation zu bekämpfen.
Das heißt, wir erhöhen den Zins, wir erhöhnen den Zins, wirken damit die Wirtschaft ab.
Wenn jetzt aber die Wirtschaft im Bereich des Bauens nicht abgewirkt wird durch
so einen niedrigen Bauzins, dann hat das eher inflationäre Wirkung.
Das ist die Idee von Lars Feld, die ist in gewisser Weise auch nicht ganz falsch.
Es wird ja teurer.
Ja, es wird teurer und damit wird auch, naja, das Bauen wird teurer,
aber es wird auch nicht gebaut und dadurch lässt die Nachfrage nach dem Bauen
nach und damit erleben wir dann etwas Rezessives.
Ja, das ist eigentlich die große Dramatik. Das Gesamtvolumen sinkt,
aber trotzdem kann man sich für sich positiv verrechnen. Man muss nur ausblenden, dass alle leiden.
Und das ist ja, wir haben es ja mit dem japanischen Notenbankchef da kurz durchgelesen,
wie man auch einfach hätte die Füße stillhalten können, weil man sieht,
naja gut, das ist nur ein Schock. Das hat ja Maruise Hoffgren auch immer wieder betont.
Jetzt haben wir bei der Staatsquote dieses Problem gehabt, der Staat sind eigentlich
zwei Player, die sich gegenseitig im Weg stehen, Land und Bund.
Der eine fördert wie blöd und der andere zieht es per Steuern wieder raus.
Wie ist das eigentlich bei der Frage Grundstückskosten und Zinslast?
Und das heißt, wir leben hier in einer Branche, wir arbeiten mit einer Branche,
die nicht nur einen Einflussfaktor hat.
Der kurzfristigste, heftigste Einflussfaktor sind die Zinsen.
Gehen die Zinsen hoch, wird Bauland teuer, weil dann Leute in die Lage versetzt
werden, sich Eigentum zu erwerben, die es sonst nicht könnten.
Und so ist es andersrum. Jetzt gehen die Zinsen hoch, geht das Bauland im Preis runter.
Aber das ist nicht der einzige Bestimmungsfaktor. Die Kapazität der Bauindustrie
ist ein weiterer wesentlicher Faktor.
Deswegen erzähle ich die ganze Zeit vom sehr jähligen, modularen und systemischen
Bauen. Weil wenn wir von 300.000 auf 400.000 Wohnungen kommen wollen,
ist das Sinnniveau wichtig, aber irgendwer muss die zusätzlichen 100.000 Wohnungen
in Deutschland ja auch bauen.
In Deutschland haben wir Grundstücksverkäufer, die einfach gucken,
was kostet gerade die Finanzierung? Ah, so blöd, so teuer. Dann muss ich bei
mir den Preis runtergehen.
Weil der Gesamtpreis muss ich irgendwo stabil halten, weil der ist ja ausgereizt.
Also haben wir es hier mit so einer Schieflage zu tun, wo wieder zwei Player
den Preis hochtreiben und nur weil man die eine Seite absenkt,
heißt das noch nicht, dass der Gesamtpreis sinkt, sondern das heißt nur,
okay, jetzt müssen wir Zugeständnisse machen, dann beißt man so einen sauren Apfel.
Wenn sie das so als politisches Problem versteht,
Warum macht sie dann nichts? Das ist doch genau ihre Domäne,
da dann politisch einzugreifen.
Also das versteht einfach niemand. Sie will, und das ist ja der zentrale Begriff,
es gibt da Mitnahmeeffekte.
Der eine sagt, ach die Zinsen sind gerade niedrig, dann ist mein Grundstück besonders teuer.
Das ist ein klarer Mitnahmeeffekt und sowas will sie dann auch nicht,
aber die Schlussfolgerung zieht sie nicht.
Wenn man mit großen Gießkannenprogrammen im Bereich einer so großen Branche
arbeitet, hat das immer auch einen Preis- und Mitnahmeeffekt.
Und wir müssen die staatliche Förderung so machen, dass sie zusätzliche Investitionen
anreizt, dass sie Marktaktivitäten auslöst, die ohne diese Programme nicht stattfinden würden.
Aber nicht, dass das, was in der Vergangenheit gemacht wurde,
Tilgungszuschüsse in einem ausgelasteten Baukapazitätsmarkt haben dazu geführt,
dass die Preise für Baumaterialien, für Handwerke alle noch nach oben gegangen sind.
Der Staat hat in den letzten Jahren Bauen durch die Förderung,
die alte Förderung der Vorgängerregierung nochmal zusätzlich teurer gemacht,
anstatt an die Substanz zu gehen. Planungsbeschleunigung, Vereinfachung.
So, wenn der Staat jetzt selber als Player hier käme, könnte er sagen,
hört mal zu, wir haben gesehen, dass ihr in der Lage seid, für den und den Preis zu bauen.
Nur weil wir es für den Endkäufer jetzt beim Grundstückspreis billiger machen,
heißt das nicht, dass wir euch Mitnahmeeffekte gönnen, sondern wir schreiben
als öffentlicher Bauherr aus, das sind die Kosten.
Nehmt ihr das Angebot an, ja oder nein? Hier muss man nicht die Marktlogik durchregieren
lassen und höchstpreisig vor sich gehen.
Und all das macht sie nicht, weil sie nicht öffentlich baut.
Und das ist eins der größten Dramen. Ganz Wien ist öffentlich,
also nicht öffentlich gebaut, aber inzwischen öffentlich vermietet.
Der größte Vermieter der Welt ist Wien. Die können ja nicht alles falsch machen.
Naja, die SPD eröffnet jetzt neue Dependancen von Rüstungskonzernen,
macht da den Spatenstich, hier müssen wir mal mit dem Spaten rein,
hier zeigen wir uns, wir sind die Sozialdemokraten und da könnten sie tatsächlich
sozialdemokratisch handeln, sie könnten selbst bauen,
sie könnten das in Auftrag geben von der Grundstückvergabe, mal ganz abgesehen,
wir haben damals über Ulm gesprochen als Beispiel, wie man es anders handhaben
kann und dann gibt es auch keine Mitnahmeeffekte.
Ja, natürlich gibt es Mitnahmeeffekte, wenn man jetzt jedem 20.000 Euro hinterher
wirft, der bauen will, dann sagt die Bauindustrie, toll, da schlagen wir das
oben drauf, die haben ja 20.000 mehr.
Aber hier könnte man, und das würde aber dann wahrscheinlich auch Herrn Mattner unglücklich machen,
als Konkurrenz auftreten, als staatliche Konkurrenz zur Privatwirtschaft und
da ist dann ein Lars Feld abwägen, eine Geiwitz und insofern sind sich dann
doch am Ende alle einig, dass es das nicht sein kann.
So und jetzt hören wir mal, wie das bei Geiwitz klingt. Der Staat kann nicht
selber bauen und so weiter.
Sie sagt es nicht so deutlich, sondern sie macht es einfach andersrum.
Sie nutzt sehr viel Zeit, um nochmal zu sagen, wir haben eine positive Bevölkerungsrechnung,
der Markt findet immer Nachfrage, eigentlich ist das sicherer Grund und deswegen,
es müssen die Privaten machen. Sie gleitet es in diese Worte.
Wir haben ein riesiges Potenzial von ungenutzten Gewerbeimmobilien,
insbesondere in C-Lagen, die auch ein großes Baupotenzial für Wohnungen haben.
Aber ich denke im Leben nicht daran, dass wir die alle mit staatlichen Mitteln umbauen.
Wirtschaft wird in der Wirtschaft gemacht. Das ist ein Modell,
mit dem Menschen Geld verdienen.
Sie haben eine Immobilienanlage, das ist heute ein Büro und vielleicht kann es auch übermorgen...
Wirtschaft wird in der Wirtschaft gemacht.
Ja, das sollte man mal ständig irgendwo sagen. Rüstung, was haben wir damit zu tun?
Ja, Wirtschaft wird in der Wirtschaft gemacht. Sollen sie doch bezahlen.
Wir geben, um das mal, also für den Wiederaufbau der Ukraine ist geplant,
dass wir den Unternehmen, die dann dort ansässig werden, die dort investieren,
Garantien geben, Abnahmegarantien und alles. Das ist ja unser Unternehmen.
Weißt du. Wirtschaft wird in der Wirtschaft gemacht. Wir kickstarten nur.
Anders als im Wohnungsmarkt, da wird nichts gekickstartet. Der darf totlaufen.
Ja, Wirtschaft in der Wirtschaft gemacht ist nicht der einzige Satz.
Sie warten noch auf den nächsten.
Geld verdienen. Sie haben eine Immobilienanlage, das ist heute ein Büro und
vielleicht kann es auch übermorgen eine Wohnungsimmobilie sein und Sie verdienen
dann Geld, indem es die Miete ist.
Wir haben es jetzt alle noch nicht gut eingeübt, diese Umbaukultur zu entwickeln,
dass wir flexibler sind und die Bestände umbauen.
Und dieses Lernen der Architekten, das Lernen auch der Immobilienbesitzer,
dass man flexibler sein will, das kann man mit so einem kleinen Programm anreizen.
Aber ansonsten, wenn Leute Geld verdienen wollen mit Immobilien,
ist das eine prima Sache,
aber das müssen die dann auch selber hinkriegen und nicht davon ausgehen,
dass es für alles eine hundertprozentig staatliche Bauunterstützung gibt und
wenn es dann auch noch umgebaut werden muss, der Staat es dann auch noch zahlt.
Wir brauchen da eine Umbaukultur.
Ja, das ist ihre Lösung.
Und die Architekten sind schon darauf, da meint sie dann,
wenn die das jetzt flexibler stellen, so besonders exponierte Objekte,
wo man Leben und Arbeiten zusammenbringt und man könnte auch unten noch einen
Pop-Up-Store errichten, aber sonst hat das natürlich nichts mit dem zu tun.
Wenn jetzt jemand ein Mehrfamilienhaus errichtet oder ein Shoppingcenter,
wie soll er das ausrichten, dass man sowohl in dem Einfamilienhaus ein Shoppingcenter
auch anlegen könnte, als auch im Shoppingcenter Büroräume und dann plötzlich Räume zum Schlafen.
Das ist völliger Humbug, den sie da erzählt und dann müsste man auch die Stadt
mal ganz anders denken, denn da haben wir ja diese Geschäftsräume unten,
die leer stehen, oben drüber sind Wohnungen noch aus Beginn des 20. oder 19.
Jahrhunderts, diese Wohnungen erreicht man aber nur, indem man durch das Geschäft
geht, das ist aber ja wie gesagt nicht möglich und deswegen stehen diese Wohnungen alle leer.
Naja, da geht es ja nur, dass der Staat auch gezielt Sachen aufkauft und dann
müsste er das machen, weil das kann sich für,
da muss man ja dem Matten auch wirklich glauben, das kann sich ja niemals rechnen,
dass man das macht und dann kann man sagen, ja ich nehme jetzt 30 Euro für die
Miete oder so, wer soll das am Ende zahlen?
Und dass sie das völlig so jetzt nur dreht wie, ja wir fördern ihnen nicht die
Gewinne, das ist ja zum einen richtig, zum anderen vergisst sie aber,
dass es nicht nur darum geht, sondern dass Menschen an.
Gute Wohnungen rankommen, das wäre ihre Aufgabe und die sieht sie überhaupt
nicht und sagt, ja das soll der Markt machen und wenn der Markt das nicht schafft,
dann hat der Markt Pech gehabt.
Das bedeutet aber im Immobilienwesen eben, dass ganz viele Leute keine Wohnung finden.
Die ganze Gesellschaft einmal zusammenknickt.
Bei den anderen Sachen, ich bin ja auch nicht jemand, der sagt, man muss alles planen.
Der Markt hat auch seine Mechanismen und ich bin auch sehr dagegen,
dass alles, was untergeht, irgendwie gerettet wird.
Es ist kein Problem, wenn es keinen Schlecker mehr gibt.
Man wird dann nicht verhungern oder sonst irgendetwas. Und wenn das falsch gewirtschaftet
war, dann ist das so und dann muss man nur den Menschen helfen,
dass sie vielleicht woanders besser unterkommen.
Aber hier geht es ja um was vollkommen anderes. Wenn der Schlecker zumacht,
dann muss man sich um ein paar Arbeitslose kümmern.
Aber wenn nicht mehr gebaut wird, dann ist die Not halt gesamtgesellschaftlich.
Sie macht jetzt so eine Rechnung auf, sie nennt die Zahlen und wir sagen,
naja, aber Frau Geibert, 1 plus 1 ist doch 2.
Und das heißt, wir haben die Gleichzeitigkeit von einem strukturellen,
problematischen Zusammenkommen von ganz vielen Planungs- und auch natürlich
steuerlichen Regelungen, die bauen in Deutschland und natürlich unsere schönen
DIN-Normen, die bauen in Deutschland langsam und teuer machen.
Das gilt immer unabhängig vom Zinsniveau und daran müssen wir arbeiten.
Und zu diesem strukturellen Problem ist jetzt noch die kurzfristige Zinsentwicklung gekommen.
Und deswegen ist es nicht so einfach zu sagen, schütte oben 10 Milliarden rein,
kommen unten 400.000 Wohnungen raus.
Ich finde, das sollte der Anspruch sein. Den Markt so in den Griff nehmen,
auch unter der Maßgabe, ansonsten gibt es die Bauwirtschaft nicht mehr,
wir können sie jetzt beschäftigen, aber wir machen das mal zu kontrollierten Preisen.
Einfach nur so fast planwirtschaftliche Beschäftigungstherapie.
Die Hauptsache, die Branche bleibt sozusagen.
Dass man sagt, also wie viele Wohnungen können wir denn bauen für 10 Milliarden,
wenn wir sagen, das ist nur unsere.
Garantie und Anschubfinanzierung. Wir sichern damit Kredite ab,
sodass dann so und so viele Menschen über 20 Jahre zu einem gesicherten Zinssatz
wie eine Mietzahlung das abzahlen.
Und ich glaube, da kommst du mit 10 Milliarden super weit.
Wenn du da einmal als Staat sagst, das ist unser Projekt für die nächsten 30
Jahre, 400.000 Wohnungen, ich glaube, müsst ihr jetzt durchrechnen,
aber 10 Milliarden und der Rest über abgesicherte Kredite, bei denen jeder weiß,
das ist ja Immobilienmarkt, also die Nachfrage ist da, müsste eigentlich funktionieren.
Also ich will zur Pointe dieses Themas zwei Clips spielen und einen was vorlesen.
Denn wir haben es nicht nur mit Wohnen zu tun, sondern eben auch mit diesem
nahen Umfeld um das Wohnen herum.
Und da gibt es hier zwei Beispiele, wo das gelingt, wenn so ein Schulterschluss stattfindet.
Also wenn nicht die Kommune eigentlich gegen den Bund kämpft oder gegen das
Land und nicht der Eigentümer, der irgendwas verkaufen will,
gegen die Bank kämpft und dann da Mitnahmeeffekte, Sondern wenn alle mal beieinander sind.
Mittlerweile fallen ja in den Innenstädten die Kaufhäuser aus.
Also gibt es jetzt Versuche, und wir hören hier zwei, Innenstädte zu retten.
Das erste Beispiel ist ein Kaufhaus in Hanau.
Ich glaube, wir befinden uns in einem Schicksalsjahrzehnt für die Innenstädte.
Wir versuchen in Hanau kräftig dagegen zu halten, um Innenstädte zu bewahren.
Und deswegen war es logisch und konsequent, diese Kaufhofimmobilie zu erwerben.
Noch ist das Gebäude nicht übergeben. Gezahlt hat Hanau mit Nebenkosten 27 Millionen Euro.
Bis zu 40 Millionen Euro werden für die Sanierung veranschlagt.
Viel Geld für eine 100.000-Einwohner-Stadt. Aber was kommt jetzt rein ins ehemalige Kaufhaus?
Es wird schon darum gehen in Zukunft, dass es nicht nur um Einkaufen geht.
Es geht um Gastronomie, es geht um kulturelle Nutzung, es geht um Orte der Begegnung,
die wir schaffen wollen.
Orte der Begegnung beim Einkaufen, Essen gehen, Leute treffen, Kultur arbeiten.
Im früheren Hertie-Kaufhaus von Oldenburg passiert das schon.
So, Hanau, jetzt Oldenburg. Da sind sie schon fertig soweit,
das ist schon relativ etabliert.
Core heißt dieser Marktplatz, Core für Englisch Kern, der Kern einer neuen Entwicklung.
Privatleute haben insgesamt rund 20 Millionen Euro investiert.
Seit fast drei Jahren läuft das Projekt, gestartet mitten in der Pandemie.
Es hat sich in Oldenburg trotzdem etabliert.
Ich denke, es funktioniert, weil wir das Konzept auf vielen Säulen,
auf mehreren Säulen abgestellt haben. Wir haben verschiedene Dinge,
die Stadt ausmachen, hier zusammengebracht, um Leben zu generieren.
Wir haben verstanden, dass städtisches Leben die Basis ist für einen wirtschaftlichen Erfolg.
Im 1. Obergeschoss wird gearbeitet, in Büros und Konferenzräumen, die man mieten kann.
150 feste oder flexible Arbeitsplätze für Freiberufler, Studierende oder gleich
ganze Firmen. Trotz der Kaufhausarchitektur ist die Büroetage hell und aufgeräumt.
Im Erdgeschoss gibt es bis abends Essen und Trinken an sieben verschiedenen Theken.
Ein Platz zum Verweilen, wo man sich trifft. Die Gastronomen zahlen überschaubare
Mieten und eine Umsatzbeteiligung.
Richtig voll wird es an mehreren Abenden im Monat, wenn Veranstaltungen im Chor
stattfinden, wie hier eine Lesung mit der Autorin Alexandra Zykunov.
Der Abend ist ausgebucht, so erfüllt das Chor eine Magnetfunktion.
Das Chor ist auf jeden Fall ein Anziehungspunkt, ist ein Referenzpunkt geworden hier in der Stadt.
Wir haben es ja gegründet als Plattform, als Verstärker für Kräfte, die es hier schon gibt.
Also ein Stück weit ein Knotenpunkt, ein Schnittpunkt zwischen Strängen,
die hier in der Stadt und in der Region schon da waren.
In das ehemalige Hertie-Gebäude in Oldenburg sind neben dem Chor auch eine Bank,
ein Fitnessstudio, zwei Einzelhändler und auf der Rückseite ein Hotel eingezogen.
Die 15.000 Quadratmeter werden vielfältig genutzt.
So, er sagt Leben generieren. Das ist ja im Grunde das Thema des ganzen Blogs.
Und in Berlin soll jetzt auch Leben generiert werden.
Die Protagonisten, die Macher selbst sprechen von einem Jahrhundertprojekt.
Sagt der DZLB irgendwas?
Nein.
Das ist die Zentrale Landes- und irgendwas-Bibliothek Berlin. Ja.
Also so, dass die große staatliche Einrichtung, die sich darum kümmert,
dass die jungen Menschen noch Kontakten zum Buch haben.
Genau. Zentral- und Landesbibliothek Berlin.
Ich lese mal aus einem Text, der sich damit befasst. Du wirst wahrscheinlich
gleich überrascht sein. Ich war auch. Ich habe gedacht, das kann doch gar nicht sein. Aber gut.
Nikolaus Bernau schreibt für die Zeit. Allen Erwartungen der Zeit um die Jahrhundertwende
zum Trotz sind die Bibliotheken dann doch nicht den schnellen Internettod gestorben.
Wir sagen Gott sei Dank, du ja insbesondere, du brauchst ja noch das gedruckte Buch.
Sie sind gerade nicht zu musealen Orten geworden, in denen nur noch aufbewahrt
wird, was digitalisiert eigentlich gar keinen Platz mehr bräuchte, das physische Buch.
Im Gegenteil, Bibliotheken sind in einer Zeit, da frei zugänglicher öffentlicher
Raum in Städten eher abnimmt, mehr denn je Treffpunkt für Alt- und Neubürgerinnen,
mittellose Jugendliche, Senioren, Menschen mit festem Arbeitsplatz,
anderswo oder gar keinem geworden. Also Menschen ohne Arbeitsplatz geworden.
Überall sonst in der Stadt wird man permanent zum Kaufen angehalten.
Bibliotheken hingegen sind von dieser Art konsumzwangbefreite Orte,
an denen man lesen, lernen und die dort bereitgestellten Bücher,
E-Medien, Musik, Filme, CDs oder sogar das freie WLAN nutzen kann.
Also Bildungsmöglichkeiten und Kulturangebote ergreifen kann,
die allenfalls mit kleineren Bibliotheksgebühren zu bezahlen sind.
Wo könnte man in Berlin die ZLB unterbringen?
In der Friedrichstraße gibt es mehrere Kaufhäuser. Eins davon ist das Lafayette-Gebäude.
Du hast es bestimmt vor Augen, dieses große gebogene Glasding und so weiter.
Und dahin möchte die ZLB jetzt einziehen.
Erstaunlich, ja.
Sie nennen es selbst ein Jahrhundertprojekt und man kann auf der Webseite der
ZLB, also zlb.de, muss man an einer Umfrage teilnehmen, also beziehungsweise
einer Unterschriftenaktion, ob man das denn will.
So, jetzt sagen wir, die ZLB hat recht, es ist ein 100-Jahrhundertprojekt.
Mitten in der Innenstadt, eine Bücherei, einfach mal hier so eine Glasfront
und so weiter. In Berlin leben über drei Millionen Menschen. Menschen.
Diese Unterschriftenaktion läuft seit mehreren Monaten.
Was glaubst du, wie viele Unterschriften stehen hier auf der Webseite?
100.000.
11.000.
Oh Gott.
Es ist ein Drama. Es ist wirklich ein Drama. In deren Sicht geht doch alle mal
zur ZLB.de. Dann würde ich auch öfter mal nach Berlin fahren.
Ja.
Wenn man da mal hin kann, dann.
Das ist eine sehr gute Idee und das kommt ein bisschen aus skandinavischen Ländern,
wo man darüber nachdachte, was kann man eigentlich mit den Bibliotheken machen?
Sind das einfach nur Bücheraufbewahrungsorte?
Und ich sah da manche Entwicklungen da auch kritisch, wo man sich dann des physischen
Buches entledigte, aber wo beides zusammengeht, also wo man damit Bücheraufbewahrungsorte
und Orte der Begegnung zugleich schafft, dann ist das sehr sinnvoll.
Wir haben jetzt so viel über Dating und Apps und so weiter gesprochen.
So wie das da klingt in dem Artikel, den du vorgelesen hast,
ist das doch eigentlich ein ganz guter Ort, um jemanden kennenzulernen.
Richtig. Das sind die besten Worte zum Schluss. Sehr gut.
Lernt euch eine Bibliothek kennen. Dann sehen wir uns im Salon,
um über Künstliche Intelligenz zu sprechen.
Ich sage es nochmal, wir lesen The Coming Wave, Künstliche Intelligenz,
Macht und das größte Dilemma des 21.
Jahrhunderts von Mustafa Suleiman. Was bringst du uns sonst noch mit?
Äh, diesmal viel. Ich habe jetzt meine Liste nicht offen, aber der Monat war
sehr ergiebig, würde ich sagen. Crazy shit.
Ich werde einen Schwerpunkt haben, vielleicht auch nur das machen, nur Thema AI.
Wie ist die Kultur revolutioniert oder zerstört?
Wir müssen da über ganz viel reden. Ich habe so viele Texte gefunden,
ich muss noch ein bisschen auswählen, aber das wird dann geschehen sein in der
nächsten Woche. Und wie gesagt, im März gibt es dann auch den Live-Salon zu hören.
Man kann den Podcast abonnieren über Patreon, über Apple von Spotify,
kommt man aber auch schon direkt zu Steady und Steady ist sowieso die präferierte Seite.
Über neue20er.de findet ihr da alles, wer den Podcast so unterstützen will.
Wir bedanken uns und freuen uns dann auf den Salon.
So ist es, bis denn.